GOOD MORNING OF THE SENATE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL MEET TODAY'S
SCHEDULE IS TO HEAR FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE GOVERNOR'S
MAJOR REVISION WE HAVE OVER
FIFTY MEMBERS OF THE- GOVERNOR'S
CABINET AND FINANCE DEPARTMENT
ENERGY COMMISSION- FISH AND
WILDLIFE. AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN REST THE SENATE
COMMITTEES- CONTINUES TO WELCOME
THE PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED
ACCESSIBLE IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCES PATIENT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE. PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON OUR WEBSITE- OUT ITS WE WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AS IT
IS RIGHT NOW AND I'LL I WILL NOT
SAY THAT THE PARTICIPATION
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO.
ONE SIX THREE. FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. FOURTEEN ONE ONE
ONE FOUR ZERO THAT FORTY. ONE I
WILL BE MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING WHICH IS CUSTOMARY
AND IS INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY HAVE TO BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR BAG. BACK
CONNECTIONS MUTED WE'RE HOLDING
DISK ARE COMMITTEE HEARING HERE
IN THE- STREET BUILDING I ASK
ALL MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
. TO BE PRESENT ROOM ABOUT
TWELVE HUNDRED TO. THAT WE CAN
COMMENCE THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
FOR OUR ROW PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES AND COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I ASKED EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED- THAT YOU
USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURED. IN THE PROGRAM SINCE
THERE ARE FIFTY PEOPLE HERE I
KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF STAFF
PEOPLE THAT CAN ANSWER A
QUESTION WE MAY. BE ASKING THIS
. AND SO- PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
HIT THAT THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO UNMUTE PLEASE
SELECT A MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
TO SPEAK R. I. T. STAFF WILL PUT
YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU'RE DONE
ONCE RECOGNIZED SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN YOU CAN BE
SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT TO SOCIAL DISTANCE.
REQUIREMENTS A LOT AND WE WILL
BE USING THE TOP CONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO REACH OUT TO TESTIFIED TODAY
PUBLIC IT WILL BE HEARD. AFTER-
THE DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED. WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM SO. WE'LL DO THAT I HAVE-
SO TODAY'S HEARING IS AN
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNORS MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL- RELATED TO
RESOURCES ENVIRONMENT PROTECTION
AGENCY- MY AGE AND THE SCHEDULE
CALLS FOR A TO START THE
DISCUSSION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- WHO PEOPLE WHO WILL
PRESENT THEM WE'LL GO WITH THE
ALEJO THEN WE WILL GO WITH
SECRETARY CROWFOOT- STAT.
MISTRUST OR IS THAT HOW YOU
WOULD LIKE TO GO WHICH LIKE TO
CHANGE UP THE ORDER. YEAH YEAH
WE'LL DO AN OVERVIEW OF THE
WHOLE MAYOR VISION AND THEN.
LIKE YOU MENTIONED WE DO HAVE.
MADE APARTMENT INCLUDING BE A
SECRETARY HERE TO ANSWER ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON
ANY ONE OF OUR REGION FOR BOTH.
LOOK FOR TO THAT DISCUSSION
PLEASE PROCEED WHAT START. HI
GOOD MORNING HERE IN MEMBERS SO
I'M GOING TO JUST PROVIDE A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF SOME OF THE
KEY INVESTMENT AND THE GOVERNOR
MAYOR VISION- AND- WE WILL NOT
GO OVER EVERYTHING CALL ME
REGION PROPOSAL AS MANY ARE WORK
LOOK. FULL BUT- IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS ON ANY OTHER PEOPLE
THAT WE DON'T NECESSARILY COVER
INTO A REVIEW- DEFINITELY EITHER
HAPPY TO PREVENT THAT AT THE DAY
OR FOLLOW UP- WITH THE COMMITTEE
IF WE DON'T HAVE THE INDIVIDUAL
FOR THE PACIFIC- I WORK WITH. A
BIGGER ARE OFTEN LITTLE AT OF A
KIND OF HIGH LEVEL ON THE
OVERALL PLEDGE ARCHITECTURE
THOSE THE MAYOR VISION DOESN'T
THAT A SIGNIFICANTLY UPGRADED
REVENUE FORECAST DUE TO RETHINK
CASH FRIENDS AND ALSO
IMPROVEMENT SOME KEY ECONOMIC
INDICATORS HOWEVER GIVEN THE
UNCERTAIN FUTURE. GENERATIONS I
BELIEVE AT THAT IT REMAINS
ESSENTIAL- FOR THE STATE TO
FOCUS MAINLY ON A ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES TO MAINTAIN
PHYSICAL ABILITY OUT FURTHER
GIVEN BE. A BREATH. YOUR
REVENUES. THERE ARE A FEW AREA.
OF THE BUDGET- INCLUDING THE
WITH THE- YOUR AFTER REPORTS
THAT HE T. AREA WHERE WE ARE
FROM TO HELLO FUNDING IN THE
CURRENT. I FUNDING IN THE CROWD
YEAR- HELP THE SOME IMMEDIATE
NEEDS THE STATE IT ENABLES.
BAKER PRIORITIZE PROGRAMS OR
PROJECTS GOING FORWARD AT A
POINT WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE
AVAILABLE RESOURCES AND THEN IT
ALSO HELPS ALIGN THE
APPROPRIATION THE FISCAL YEAR IN
WHICH THE RESOURCES THAT THE
REVENUES ARE ARE AVAILABLE- SO
JUST GOING A LITTLE BIT INTO THE
KIND OF OVERALL I MET BUDGET
PICTURE. BUILDING ON. THE
LEADERSHIP AND THE HISTORIC
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLAR MULTI
YEAR CLIMATE RESILIENT
INVESTMENTS THAT WE- ENACTED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DID
PROPOSED AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION OVER FIVE
YEARS- TRANSFORMATIVE I'M
INVESTED TRANSPORTATION ENERGY
HELPING EDUCATION QUALIFIER
THEY'LL IN DROUGHT AND HEALTH-
AND TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
PRESSING ISSUES THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL. NINE
POINT FIVE BILLION OVER FOUR
YEARS FOR A TOTAL OF THIRTY TWO
BILLION THE CONTAINS ADVANCED
BASED CLIMATE AN OPPORTUNITY
AGENDA. NOW WHEN YOU COMBINE
LAST YEAR BURKE INVESTMENT WITH
THAT NEW INVESTMENT AND DID
BUDGET- THIS REFLECT THE
HISTORIC FORTY SEVEN POINT. ONE
BILLION INCLINED AND THAT. NOW
GOING ON SOME OF THE- KEY MAJOR
INVESTMENT THAT WE HAVE IN THE
MAYOR VISION AUTHOR OFFER WITH
WATERS BILLION AND DROUGHT
RESPONSE. SO THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT INCLUDED FIVE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA WATER
FROM THE FOR IMMEDIATE RALPH AND
LONGER WATERS BILLION- IN THIS
YEAR THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAD
BOTH ADDITIONAL. INVESTMENT OUT
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND- NOW GIVEN THE INTO
THE VISION OF THE DROUGHT THAT
JANUARY. THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT
THREE BILLION GENERAL FUND AND
ALSO ALLOCATE THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION- DROUGHT
CONTINGENCY FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. OR CURRENT BILLION AND
RESPOND WHICH IS DESIGNED TO ONE
HEALTH COMMUNITY AND FISH OR
WILDLIFE AVOID IMMEDIATE
NEGATIVE IMPACT AS A RESULT THE
CREAM DROUGHT. WHILE TO CONTINUE
TO ADVANCE OUR PROJECT A PROGRAM
THAT EIGHT TO BE. MORE RESILIENT
TO FUTURE GROWTH. THIS INCLUDES
FIND ACROSS MANY DIFFERENT-
BURKE CATEGORY ADDING- WATER.
AND I THINK YOUR WATER ANYTHING
WATER PROJECT- AGRICULTURAL
CONSERVATION TECHNICAL. LEAD
GRANT HERBAL WATER DISTRICT AND
SMALL. FIRE FOR RELIEF.
ACCORDING DATA AND WATER
CONSERVATION EDUCATION CAMPAIGN
EMERGENCY DRINKING WATER BOND.
ADDRESSING FISH AND WILDLIFE IN
FACT BUT BOTH HE WOULD DRIVE I
MEAN CHANGED AMONG MANY OTHERS
THAT- HOLD OPEN NOTE THAT THE
MERE VISION DOES INCLUDE. FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION GENERAL FUND.
THREE TWENTY FIVE FORTY- BAD-
MULTI YEAR. TO PROMOTE STRATEGIC
WATER FIVE IN THE- THAT BEEN
WATER SUPPLY REALIZED AND THE
ENVIRONMENT- THESE RESOURCES
WILL BUILD ON THAT TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION PROVIDED IN
PROPOSITION ONE UNDER THE WATER
STORAGE INVESTMENT PROGRAM- NOW
MOVING ON- HAPPENED GREAT- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAVE BOWS-
NINE HUNDRED FORTY. MILLION IN
THE DISCRETIONARY- HAPPY GREAT
FUNDING ACROSS SEVERAL PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THEIR MISSION VEHICLE-
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN.
PROTECTIONS FOR THE PATIENT AT
THE- END AND ALTHOUGH COMMUNITY
MODERATE- MEMORY CAN BE DOT
RESULTED IN AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION. IN IN
GROSS REVENUES ABOVE BE
PRELIMINARY ESTIMATE- WITH A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY OF THE FOUR
TEN BEING DISCRETIONARY REVENUES. AVAILABLE FOR THE MAY
REVISION. SO THE MAYOR MADE
PRIORITIZES OTHER THIRTY HUNDRED
FOR MILLION OF THE PROGRAM- THAT
THE HUNDRED MILLION. TO EXPAND
THE NUMBER OF SATELLITE LAUNCHED
FOR MAPPING OPERATION I WHICH
WILL PROVIDE DEEPLY MEASUREMENT
OF LARGE AND- METHANE EMISSIONS
IN THE STATE- WHICH ALSO HELP
ENHANCE ENFORCEMENT
CAPABILITIES. AND THEN AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY MILLION ONE
TIME FOR EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
MEDIA PROTECTION PROGRAM WHICH
WHEN COMBINED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INVESTMENT-
BRING THAT FULL PROGRAM
INVESTMENT TO ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION- IS ALSO IMPORTANT
. TO HIGHLIGHT THAT MANY OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY RECEIVED CAP AND
TRADE I. LIKE THE TRANSFORMERS I
MEDIUM THE BAY METHANE REDUCTION
PROGRAMS FARMER HEALTHY FOILED
AMONG MANY OTHERS ARE ALSO SET
TO REPEAT GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE MULTI YEAR. WE'RE ENACT IN
LAFAYETTE BUT- NOW MOVING ON THE
VATICAN- MARCH THE
ADMINISTRATION ACCELERATE ONE
POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION AND-
THAT INVESTMENT YOU ARE
PRIMARILY SUPPORTER OF PASSENGER
VEHICLE INCENTIVES. ARE STILL BE
A CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ALTHOUGH UP THE ROAD FROM OPTION
PROGRAMS. THE ADMINISTRATION
MAYOR. BUILT ON TOP OF THE
MARKET COLORATION PROPOSAL BY
ACCELERATING ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN BETWEEN WHAT WE
DO WHICH BRINGS. COLORATION TO
I. TWO POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR DOESN'T THAT. OKAY
I'LL RING THE FUNDING WILL
ENABLE THE CALIFORNIA EVERY
FIRST WORD AND ENERGY COMMISSION
TO INITIATE THE PROCESS
IMPLEMENT THE FUNDING- IT HELPS
CREATE GREATER MARKET FEET AND
ALSO ENABLE CONSUMERS TO FIND
BETTER FOR VEHICLE PURCHASES.
BUT THE CONFIDENCE THAT THEY
WILL HAVE ACCESS TO THE REBATE
AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. I AND WE BELIEVE
EARLY PUBLIC INVESTMENT PROVIDED
A VERY CLEAR MARKET IN THE
PRIVATE MARKET AND ALTHOUGH MAKE
THE BET THAT NEXT ELLERY THEIR
ACTIVITIES. AND PROVIDE TANGIBLE
RELIEF TO CALIFORNIA AND. THEY
ARE FACING RECORD HIGH YEAH. NO
ON TO THE INVESTMENT WITHIN CAL
FIRE INCIDENT THAT WE ARE SEARCH
CAPACITY. THAT BEING AND OTHER
OPERATIONAL ENHANCEMENTS- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL BEGIN
TO GET YOU ADMIT TO CONTINUE
BUILDING OR WILDFIRE DOING A
WIDE. AND ALSO EXPANDED THATTHE
WILDFIRE RISK ARE AT. THE MAYOR
VISION BUILD ON THESE EFFORTS
WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
EXPANDED FIREPROOF. AND ERIC
BACK OPERATION. THE DIFFICULT.
IT INCLUDES- ABOUT EIGHTY AND
GENERAL FUND- TO AUGMENT
CALIFORNIA HI PROTECTION
RESOURCES THROUGH DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO GIVEN THE
CURRENT DROUGHT CONDITIONS
INCREASING HIGHER SEVERITY AND
FIVE AND ALTHOUGH THE INMATE
POPULATION- IN ADDITION THE
MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
POINT TWO MILLION AND FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
PROVISIONS WOULD HAVE HELLFIRE
CAPABILITIES TO MEET THE DEMAND
OF THE WALL AND FIRE FIGHTING IN
A CHANGING CLIMATE. AND THERE'S
A FEW DIFFERENT A BET THE BEER-
UNDER TO FOUR MILLION AND TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY POSITION THEY'VE
BEEN OVER SEVERAL YEARS HI CAL
BY OUR STAFFING- RELATED TO
APPEAR THE BUYERS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- THIRTY SEVEN- WE NEED
MILLION A HUNDRED NINETY
PHYSICIANS WOULD HAVE STAFFING
IMPROVE OPERATIONAL
EFFECTIVENESS AND ALSO PROVIDES
CRITICAL ADMINISTRATIVE AND
PROGRAM SUPPORT NECESSARY THE
FIFTEEN CAL FIRE'S MISSION
FUNCTION IN AN INCREASINGLY
COMPLEX ENVIRONMENT AND THEN
LASTLY THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL
POSITION. IT WITH- YOU QUIT MID
A COUPLE OF THE GOVERNOR BUDGET
. HE FOR ADDITIONAL I THIRTY I
FIREFOX HEALTH AND THEN A
COUNTRY FOR THE NEXT IF YOU
HELLO THINKERS. I'LL WORK NOW
HERE- YOU KNOW RECOGNITION OF
THE HEAVY TOLL OF THE AT THAT
WALL PARK VIEW IN IMMIGRATION IF
YOU THINK EIGHT WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION ON
OPTIONS YOU. THAT I FELT LIGHTER
TO GROW THE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
OF CALIFORNIA BY PARTS. NOW
MOVING ON TO A COUPLE INVESTMENT
WITHIN EACH. DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
AND RECREATION. OUR VISION
DOESN'T WHO AN ADDITIONAL EIGHTY
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION THE
INCREASE WILL AFFECT. THE BIG
PART THROUGH. A ONE TIME THAT. I
DIDN'T INCLUDE FIFTEEN MILLION
TO EXPAND EXISTING WORKSTATION
ENACTED PROGRAMS WORKING THROUGH
TWELVE BILLION- FORTY MILLION
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW
BETTER THAN THEIR CENTER AND
THAT ALTHOUGH OTHER INTERPRETIVE
IMPROVEMENT. AND COLONEL
ALLENSWORTH BURKE PARK. FIFTY
MILLION OR DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
TO PARTNER- WITH THAT CALIFORNIA
AFRICAN AMERICAN MUSEUM. TO
BETTER TELL ME THE STORY OF
BLACK HISTORY AND STATE PARK.
AND THEN ALSO. THIRTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION. TO EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF OUR PATH TO A MAJOR
THROUGH A PILE FOR. TO PROVIDE A
PART THAT THIS WORK CHECK OUT A
LOCAL- NOW WILL COMPLETE WITH
THE ENERGY PACKAGE. SO THAT
MAYOR VISION DOES INCLUDE AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT BILLION IN
INVESTMENT TO FURTHER STATE
ENERGY SYSTEMS RELIANT.
INCREASED RELIABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY AND ALSO A CALORIE
THE DEPLOYMENT AND RESOURCES
NEEDED TO ACHIEVE CALIFORNIA'S
CLEAN ENERGY TRANSITION AS WELL
AS PROVIDE COMBAT RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIA TO HELP HOLD. THEIR
IMPACTED BY KOBE NINETEENTH AND
DEMI- CLIMATE CHANGE JUST
CONTINUE TO CAUSE UNPRECEDENTED
STRESS. ON THE STATE ENERGY. IT
FOR AND RELIABILITY I WISH WE
COULD HELP THAT RECOVER
DISPARAGING. BOTH GIVEN GIVEN
THE CHALLENGES- THEY'RE VERY
INVESTMENT PROPOSED THAT PART OF
THE ENERGY PACKAGE. THERE'S A
FIVE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. IN STRATEGIC
RELIABILITY WHICH INCLUDES FOUR
POINT TWO BILLION FOR INVESTMENT
AND STRATEGIC RELIABILITY AT
THAT AT THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES. AND THEN NINE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION AT THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION UP
OR DISTRIBUTED ELECTRICITY BACK
ABOUT. AND UTILITY BILL AFTER-
THE RESERVE WILL BE STATEWIDE
RESOURCE CAPABLE OF PROVIDING UP
TO FIVE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS.
AVAILABLE WHEN THE GREATEST
THREAT. AND THEN WILL INCREASE
THE CAPABILITY TO WITHSTAND
EXTREME HEAT- AND WITH THAT-
CLIMATE EVENT. BUT WILL NOT TAKE
THE PLACE OF THE LONGSTANDING
OBLIGATION OF ALL LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES THAT PROCURE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO MAINTAIN
RELIABILITY- THE MAYOR VISION
ALSO PRODUCE TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE MILLION. OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS OR THE OPERATOR
OF THE COMMISSION AND DEVELOPING
DEMAND RESPONSE INITIATIVES IBM
EFFORTS WILL HELP REDUCE ENERGY
DEMAND. DURING. PEAK ENERGY
TIMES. THE FACT ALSO. THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE STRUCK TO PAY
ALEX BILLS AND- PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT TWO BILLION
IN REMAIN. OR ELECTRIC UTILITY
RATEPAYERS WOULD BE CALIFORNIA.
YEAH IT INCLUDES NINE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY MILLION SO THE
PUBLIC UTILITY COMMISSION TO
PROVIDE RESIDENTIAL SOLAR AND
STORAGE SYSTEM INVENTED BY
INCLUDING FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION- EIGHT
INCLUDED IN ENERGY PACKAGE WITH
BAD ELECTIONS RCOGNITION.
INCLUDING FROM THE FALL IN THE
IN THE POOR OF THE STATE WITH
YOUR VALUE VISION AND NEED FOR
CLEAN BERMAN WHAT COULD BE- FROM
NEW GEOTHERMAL REPORT THAT IN
THE REGION. AND THEN LAST WEEK
TO THE BUILDING ON THE SUCCESS
OF THE EPIC PROGRAM WHICH IS THE
DATE FOR ME HERE A RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM- THAT
CONRAD. THE ONE BILLION PROGRAM
TO COMPANIES HEADQUARTERED IN.
OKAY UNDEVELOPED COMMERCIAL LIFE
I NEW TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL SHE
PROCLAIM. AND CLEANER EAGLE.
THAT DOES PROVIDE THAT A HIGH
LEVEL- OF SOME OF THE KEY BACK
THEN AND AGAIN WE HAVE A MEDIUM
IS. COLLEAGUES HERE- AVAILABLE
THE L. BATCH BUT. OKAY THANK YOU
I. THE SELLERS WE HAVE THAT WAS
A HIGHLIGHT THE GOVERNOR'S
MOVING SOME DROUGHT MONEY FROM
LAST YEAR'S PACKAGE TO THIS
CURRENT FISCAL YEARS WHICH IS A
NICE ACCOUNTING THING THEY'VE
GOT. CAP AND TRADE REVENUES THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO MORE
COLLECTION OF DATA BUT NO
REDUCTION OF METHANE. AND WE'VE
GOT- ACCELERATION GIVEN THE
INFLATIONARY CHALLENGES THAT
WE'VE HAD SINCE JANUARY WE'RE
GOING TAKE SALARY THE PURCHASE
OF. A SEPT THE STEP PACKAGE
WHICH WILL HAVE HEAT UP THE
ECONOMY MORE AND WE HAVE. A
LITTLE BIT OF ATTENTION ON- A
PARKS AND RECREATION- OF A
MODEST ATTENTION BUT NOTHING ON
THE MAINTENANCE BACKLOG OF ONE
POINT TWO CAN YOU GIVE US. THE
L. A. YO'S ANALYSIS OF THIS MAY
REVISION. HEY MICHELLE GOOD
MORNING RACHEL EHLERS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
NICE TO SEE YOU ALL MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- SO AS MISTER
AGUILAR JUST WENT OVER THE MAY
REVISION IT HAS A LOT A LOT OF
ACTIVITIES AND A LOT OF FUNDING.
FOR IT FOR YOU TO CONSIDER A
MAJOR INCREASES AS NOTED FOR
WATER IN DROUGHT FOR ENERGY FOR
WHAT DEPRESSION ANYA ALL OF THE
SPENDING IS ONE TIME. ASSEMBLY
DEPENDING IS FOCUSED ON NEAR
TERM IMMEDIATE CHALLENGES LIKE
SUMMER WILDFIRES POTENTIAL
ENERGY SHORTAGES AB AND DROUGHT
UP QUITE A BIT OF IT IS FOCUSED
ON LONGER TERM ACTIVITIES AND
ISSUES LIKE- YOU KNOW WHAT LONG
TERM WATER RELIABILITY. AND
ENERGY DECARBONISATION
ACTIVITIES ARE SO OVERALL WE
THINK THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
FOCUSING ON A REASONABLE SET OF
ISSUES- THERE'S MERIT OBVIOUSLY
FOCUSING ON CLIMATE RELATED
CHALLENGES AS WE SPENT MONTHS IN
THIS SUB COMMITTEE DISCUSSING-
THERE'S MERIT. MKE OF A FOCUS
SHORT TERM A LONGER TERM
ACTIVITIES AND THERE'S MERIT IN
REALLY FOCUSING ON ONE TERM
RATHER THAN I'M GOING FUNDING
JUST GIVEN FUTURE BUDGET
UNCERTAINTY. BUT OVERALL I THINK
HER COMMENTS FOR YOU TODAY ARE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN THEY MIGHT
BE ANOTHER BUDGET CIRCUMSTANCES
AND THAT'S REALLY BECAUSE OF
THIS OVER ARCHING BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS THAT HAS EMERGEDTHE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT
YOURSELF- PER THE CONSTITUTION
THE STATE HAS TO SPEND A CERTAIN
AMOUNT WHEN THIS. LIMIT IS KIND
OF ACTIVE AS IT IS RIGHT NOW-
EITHER ON CERTAIN ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE EXCLUDABLE FROM THE
LIMIT OR ON ON TAX REFUNDS SO-
THE ESTIMATES ARE FOR THE PRIOR
FISCAL YEAR THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR. AND THE BUDGET YEAR
BECAUSE IT'S THOUGHT OF KIND OF
AS A MULTI YEAR ISSUE THAT THE
STATE NEEDS TO SPEND ABOUT FORTY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS ON THESE
EITHER EXCLUDALE ACTIVITIES ARE
TAX REFUNDS ACROSS THOSE THREE
YEARS. I AND IN OUR ESTIMATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL LEAVES ABOUT
THREE POINT FIVE BILLION
UNADDRESSED OF THAT REQUIREMENT
IN THE BUDGET YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE. AND WE REALLY
STRONGLY RECOMMENDS THAT YOU-
DON'T PASS A BUDGET THAT HAS
UNADDRESSED STYLE REQUIREMENTS.
IN PART BECAUSE WE REALLY SEE A
BIG PROBLEM LOOMING ON THE
HORIZON IN BUDGET YEAR PLUS.
TWENTY THREE. FOUR I WE HAVE
ESTIMATES THAT THE STATE WILL
HAVE ABOUT A TWENTY TWO BILLION
DOLLAR ITSELF ENDING
REQUIREMENTS. AND A MUCH LOWER
SURPLUS WERE WERE ESTIMATING
ONLY ABOUT YOU KNOW ALMOST A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS TO
ADDRESS THAT- CLASS. THERE ARE
SOME VERY CONCERNING SIGNS ON
THE HORIZON ABOUT A POTENTIAL
RECESSION SO WE'RE REALLY WE'RE
REALLY SEEING SOME OUT YOUR
CONCERNING SIGNS AND THINK IT'S
A REALLY IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY
THIS YEAR TO. HEARING FOR THAT
AND ONE OF THE WAYS TO DO THAT
IS TO PUT ADDITIONAL FUNDS IN
RESERVE. TIME AT THE WAY BUT
BECAUSE OF THIS SORT OF ISSUE OF
THIS ALEX GLUTAMYL ACTIVITIES
AND THE NON. EXCLUDABLE
ACTIVITIES ARE THOSE KINDS OF
SPENDING THAT COUNT TOWARDS THE
LIMIT IT DOES SET UP THIS- SORT
OF INTERESTING AND UNUSUAL AB
CHALLENGE FOR YOU AS YOU'RE
PUTTING TOGETHER YOUR BUDGET. SO
I THINK IN SOME OF OUR COMMENTS
WE SORT OF CONSIDER THOSE TWO
CATEGORIES OF SPENDING
SEPARATELY THOSE THAT ARE
EXCLUDABLE FROM THE LIMIT AND
THOSE THAT DO COUNT TOWARDS THE
LIMIT- AND WE THINK THERE'S A
REALLY EXCEPTIONALLY HIGH BAR
FOR THOSE THAT HAVE. THAT COUNT
TOWARDS THE LIMIT BECAUSE THE
TRADE OFF IS B. AS- IN PUTTING
FUNDING INTO RESERVES. SO FIRST
TALKING ABOUT THIS EXCLUDABLE-
ACTIVITY WITHIN THIS SUB
COMMITTEE ACTUALLY YOUR
DISCUSSION IS. A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN OTHERS BECAUSE
MOST OF THE ACTIVITIES PROPOSED
ARE EXCLUDABLE MISTER CAPITAL
OUTLAY- OR EMERGENCY SPENDING
WHICH DOESN'T COUNT TOWARDS THAT
LIMIT- BUT EVEN WITHIN THAT THAT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU NEED
TO TAKE THE SAME PACKAGE OF
EXCLUDABLE ACTIVITIES THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED. AND YOU
CAN AND PURSUE SOMETHING THAT
PACKAGE OF ACTIVITIES THAT
REALLY FOCUSES ON ON WHAT YOU
THINK THE HIGHEST PRIORITIES
ARE- THERE COULD BE ACTIVITIES
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PRIORITIZING- THAT YOU DON'T
THINK ARE ARE. OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITIES OR VICE VERSA YOU
KNOW JUST AS AN EXAMPLE IN THAT
SENATE MAJORITY PACKET YOU
DISCUSSED LAST WEEK THERE WAS
QUITE A BIT OF FUNDING FOR-
COASTAL RESILIENCE AND SEA LEVEL
RISE. THAT'S NOT REALLY A LARGE
COMPONENT OF THE MAY REVISION
BEFORE YOU SO THAT'S JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
PRIORITY YOU CAN FOCUS ON.
ANOTHER KEY CONSIDERATION TO
THINK ABOUT YOUR YOUR PACKAGE
AGAIN IN THIS EXCLUDABLE
CATEGORY IS CAPACITY- THERE'S
BEEN VERY SIGNIFICANT-
INVESTMENTS. LAST YEAR AND IN
SOME OF THE MULTI YEAR FUNDING
THAT WAS APPROVED SO THINK
ABOUT. ARE THERE PROGRAMS WHERE
MAYBE THERE ISN'T ENOUGH DEMAND
DIFFERENT THE AMOUNT. OF FUNDING
THAT'S PROPOSED MAYBE EVEN WITH
A MULTI YEAR. KIND OF INCOME
PERIOD MAYBE THERE ARE ENOUGH-
PROJECTS A BACKLOG IN SOME OF
THESE AREAS AND MAYBE. AND THERE
MIGHT BE OTHER AREAS THAT THAT
MIGHT HAVE GREATER CAPACITY.
ALSO THINKING ABOUT- PROGRAMS
THAT ARE KIND OF NEW AND HAD
JUST GOTTEN UP AND RUNNING IS IT
PREMATURE PERHAPS TO PUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THERE ARE
SOME EXAMPLES UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. I'M FOR
EXAMPLE THAT- MULTI BENEFIT
LANDRY PURPOSING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION. THE
STATE PARKS LIBRARY PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM YOU KNOW THE THESE THERE
ARE PROGRAMS THAT SHOW A LOT OF
PROMISE BUT THEY JUST GOT THE
FIRST ROUND OF FUNDING SO DO YOU
WANT TO WAIT AND SEE A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT DEMAND BEFORE YOU
POTENTIALLY. PUT MORE FUNDING
AND- ANOTHER IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION IS JUST THINKING
ABOUT THE MIX OF ACTIVITIES TO
ACHIEVE YOUR POLICY GOAL SO IN
THE WILDFIRE SPACE THINKING
ABOUT PREVENTION- VERSES
RESPONSE AND HOW YOU WANT TO
BALANCE. THAT IN THE ENERGY
PACKAGE THINKING ABOUT HOW MUCH
YOU THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
FOCUS ON POTENTIAL SHORT TERM-
SHORTAGES. AS COMPARED TO LONGER
TERM GOALS A PARTICULAR BECAUSE
SOME OF THE SHORTER TERM
ACTIVITIES DO YOU HAVE- A KIND
OF DEPEND ON FOSSIL FUELS. AND
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WHICH
IS A LITTLE BIT COUNTER TO THELONGER TERM GOALS OF THE STATE
SO THINKING ABOUT HOW YOU'RE
BALANCING THOSE ACTIVITIES- AND
THEN ALSO TIMING THIS IS A LOT
TO DECIDE ON. RIGHT NOW I AM A
BIG PRETTY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
SO IN SOME CASES YOU COULD THINK
ABOUT ADOPTING AN ARCHITECTURE
OR FRAME. SPENDING A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME OVER THE SUMMER AS YOU
DID LAST YEAR. ON DEVELOPING
DETAILS. BUT AS YOU MENTIONED
MISTER CHAIR QUITE A BIT OF THE
SPENDING IS SCORED INTWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- BECAUSE
OF THOSE SALVOR CHOIR MENTIONED
SO THAT COULD BE AN EXTRA
CONSTRAINT- IN SOME WAYS ABOUT.
HOW MUCH TIME YOU HAVE FOR SOME
OF THESE AREAS- SO THEN IT'S
KIND OF SHIFTING A LITTLE BIT TO
THINK ABOUT THAT NON EXCLUDABLE
ACTIVITIES SO NOT CAPITAL OUTLAY
NOT EMERGENCY SPENDING- THAT
DOES COUNT TOWARDS THAT LIMIT
AND DOES CREATE A TRADE OFF FOR-
FOR EXAMPLE PUTTING MONEY INTO
RESERVES. WHICH IS AWESOME NON
EXCLUDABLE- AGAIN WE THINK
THERE'S A MUCH HIGHER BAR FOR
THOSE ACTIVITIES BECAUSE OF
THOSE TRADE OFFS THAT COME WITH
THEM- SO YOU KNOW THINKING ABOUT
SOME OF THE NEW ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE PROPOSED THAT. AREN'T
ALREADY UNDER WAY WHERE THERE
MAY NOT BE A LOT OF DETAIL
AVAILABLE THOSE MIGHT BE THINGS
YOU MIGHT WANT TO THINK EVEN IF
THEY SEEM LIKE THEY HAVE SOME
AMERICAN CONCEPT YOU MIGHT WANT
TO THINK ABOUT. NOTED SOME OF
THE REALLY BIG NEW IDEAS
PROPOSED ARE AT CLIMATE
INNOVATION GRANTS. M. AND THEN
ALSO SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
ADMIN PROPOSALS WHICH ARE ARE
ARE NEW- AND AGAIN EVEN WITHIN
THIS NON X. LITTLE ACTIVITY
REALLY THINKING ABOUT WHAT ARE
THE HIGHEST PRIORITIES IF YOU
HAVE MOST OF THE WILDFIRE
SPENDING. IS NON EXCLUDABLE YOU
PROBABLY ARE GOING TO WANT TO DO
SOME OF THAT BUT THINKING ABOUT
THE MIX OF PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE AND WHAT ARE THE
HIGHEST PRIORITIES I AM ALSO
THINKING ABOUT ONE TIME AND
ONGOING- WHERE THERE ARE SOME OF
THESE ONGOING PROPOSALS IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU REALLY WANT TO
COMMIT TO NOW GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY IN THE FUTURE. I'M
JUST SPENDING A MOMENT
MENTIONING GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND AS AS THE CHAIR
NOTED. ON THE MAYOR VISION ONLY
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION INTO JACK'S
SPENDING- WITH A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION OF THAT ALLOCATED
TO NEW DISCRETIONARY SPENDING-
THIS WOULD BRING THE TOTAL
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING TO ABOUT
ONE POINT ONE BILLION. BASED ON
OUR OFFICES HIGHER ESTIMATE-
REVENUE ESTIMATES WE DO THINK
YOU HAVE SOME MORE- THAT YOU
COULD KIND OF SAFELY COMMIT TO
SPENDING. SPECIFICALLY AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
ROUGHLY- INDISCRETION OR GDR
REVENUE. THE G. G. R. F. CAN
PLAY A PIECE IN HELPING YOU IN
THIS LARGER BUDGET ARCHITECTURE
WE DO THINK THERE IS. SOME
OPPORTUNITY TO USE G. JEFF AND
GENERAL FUND KIND OF
STRATEGICALLY AND THINK ABOUT
WHICH ACTIVITIES YOU'RE FINDING
OUT OF THE G. G. R. F. MAYBE
THOSE NON EXCLUDABLE. KIND OF
NINE CAP OUTLAY WOULD BE BETTER
SUITED FOR GIGI R. F. TO FREE UP
SOME OF YOUR GENERAL FUND- TO
HELP WITH SOME OF THESE BUDGET
ARCHITECTURE ISSUES SO. JUST
JUST WANTED TO FIND OUT OF THE
POSSIBILITY AND WHERE WHERE OF
COURSE HAPPY TO HELP YOU- AS YOU
WORK THROUGH THAT.AND THEN THE
FINAL POINT I WANTED TO MAKE
WAS- REALLY A THEME THAT CAME UP
IN YOUR HEARING LAST WEEK
THINKING ABOUT OVERSIGHT AND
EVALUATION AND- WITH HIS LARGE
EXPENDITURES HOW ARE WE ENSURING
THAT WE ARE LEARNING WHAT WE'RE
GETTING. FOR OUR SPENDING- AND-
FUTURE VERSIONS AS WELL. I THAT
MIGHT INCLUDE REPORTING. JUST
YOU KNOW UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
MONEY BOUGHT- BUT ALSO. YOU
THINK MORE BROADLY THAN JUST
REPORTING LANGUAGE THINKING
ABOUT TRUE EVALUATIONS AND ARE
THERE. INFORMATION WE WANT TO
KIND OF COLLECT BASELINE UP
FRIENDS TO BAND MEASURE AGAINST
OUTCOMES DO YOU WANT TO PUT SOME
FUNDING IN FOR MORE RIGOROUS
KIND OF SCIENTIFIC EVALUATION
AND SOME OF THESE CASES
PARTICULARLY WHERE THERE ARE
PILOT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
PROPOSED- JUST SO THAT WE ARE.
NOT ONLY ENSURING THAT WE'RE
SPENDING STATE DOLLARS
EFFECTIVELY BUT AGAIN REALLY AS
WE'RE WORKING ON THESE. KIND OF
GENERATIONAL- EXISTENTIAL
CHALLENGES FROM FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE IN PARTICULAR HOW DO WE
KNOW WHAT'S WORKING HOW CAN WE
BE- INFORMING OUR FUTURE
DECISIONS AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE BEING AS STRATEGIC AS
POSSIBLE. SO WITH THAT HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND MY
COLLEAGUES ARE HERE ON THE CALL
AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
SECRETARY CROWFOOT YOU HAVE-
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS YOU'VE GOT
YOUR NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS- THE
CALIFORNIA REPLETE WITH FINANCE
TALKED ABOUT THAT PARKS AND
RECREATION- GOOD MORNING THE
BILL GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LET ME
FIRST THANK YOU CHAIR FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE. YOU
KNOW MUCH OF WHAT OF THE
PROGRESS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
FRANKLY IS AS A RESULT OF THE
LEADERSHIP AND- FORTITUDE OF YOU
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES ON THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE AND I UNDERSTAND
GIVEN TERM LIMITS THIS MAYBE
YOUR YOUR THE LAST BUDGET YOU
HELPED TO SHAPE SO JUST ON
BEHALF OF OUR ENTIRE AGENCY AND
DEPARTMENTS I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR ALL THAT YOU'VE DONE AND CAN
. TRYING TO I WAS THAT WAS VERY
KIND I WAS WONDERING IF SO MANY
PEOPLE FROM THE DEPARTMENTS ARE
ON JUST TO. SEE THE LAST SHOW OR
THEY ACTUALLY WANT TO ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS BUT I'LL PUT THAT
ASIDE- PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
. WELL LISTEN WE KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW WE DO THIS WORKING
TREMENDOUSLY CHALLENGING TIMES
CLIMATE CHANGE IS ACCELERATING
AND GENERATING IMPACT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE EXPECTED. IN
THE MIDDLE PART OF THE CENTURY
OR EVEN TOWARDS THE END OF THE
CENTURY. WE'RE IN THE THIRD YEAR
OF A WORSENING DROUGHT. WE'RE
STARING DOWN THE BARREL OF WHAT
COULD BE ANOTHER CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE SEASON. AND EXTREME
HEAT. AND THIS HEAT WAVE THAT
HIT THE ENTIRE SOUTHWEST. ARE
STRESSING OUR EECTRICITY GRID I
CERTAINLY MORE THAN WE HAD
ANTICIPATED. SEVERAL YEARS AGO
SO I THINK YOU FOR YOUR FOCUS ON
ACTING QUICKLY AND DECISIVELY ON
INVESTMENTS. THERE IS A WHOLE
LOT BETWEEN THE JANUARY PROPOSAL
AND THE MAY REVISION TO
CONSIDER. AND WE WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE DOING SO AS AS- AS
MUCH AS YOU CAN TO REALLY GET
THIS FUNDING OUT THE DOOR TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE. BUILDING OUR
RESILIENCE TO CLIMATE CHANGE- I
WANT TO. WANT TO PUT A SPECIAL
PLUGIN FOR IN BACK. IN OUR
DEPARTMENTS AND IN OUR PEOPLE.
THAT ARE DELIVERING THESE
PROGRAMS. YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD
REMARKABLE REVENUE GROWTH AS WE
KNOW IN THIS ONE TIME FUNDING AS
A RESULT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
MAKE. HISTORIC INVESTMENTS. IN
MANY CASES. WE HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO SCALE UP THE STAFF. AND
THE TEAM WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY GETTING THAT
FUNDING OUT THE DOOR AND
SUPPORTING ALL OF OUR PARTNERS.
HEALTHCARE IS A GREAT EXAMPLE.
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THE
HEROISM OF CALIFORNIA- FOLKS IN
UNIFORM. BUT THERE ARE HEROES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA- THAT HAVE
BEEN WORKING TO. ADMINISTER A
BUDGET THAT'S WELL OVER DOUBLE
IT WHAT IT USED TO BE JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO. I AM WE HAVEN'T GROWN
ADMINISTRATIVE CAPACITY. I IN
MANY OF OUR DEPARTMENT SO WHERE
YOU DO SEE FUNDING FOR CRITICAL
STAFF POSITIONS. IT MAY NOT BE
AS ALLURING AS SOME OF OUR NEW
PROJECTS OR OR PROJECTS GETTING
OUT ON THE GROUND. BUT I CAN
TELL YOU TO MAINTAIN. OUR OUR.
BUSINESS IN. IN THAT THE PACE OF
ACTS THAT WILL NEED TO OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS. THOSE
INVESTMENTS ARE REALLY REALLY
CRITICAL. SO THAT'S JUST A TOP
LINE COLOR COMMENTARY ONCE AGAIN
HUGE THANKS TO OUR DEPARTMENTS
YOU HAVE EXPERTS ACROSS OUR
AGENCIES. DAN AGENCY TO ANSWER
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE
THEM. WELL THANK YOU I'M- NOT
GOING TO WERE ANYBODY. CENTER
DOLLY HE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- SO I DO
HAVE- QUITE A FEW THINGS I
WANTED TO JUST TO. I WENT OUT TO
LA- ABOUT THIS FISCAL CLIFF THAT
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT WHAT YOUR
PROJECT PROJECTION- TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IS CAN YOU GIVE US
A LITTLE MORE BACKGROUND ON WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ONE TIME
EXPERT MOST OF THIS IS A ONE
TIME EXPENDITURES BUT- WE HAVE
ONGOING. ISSUES YEAH AND THANK
YOU SENATOR I THINK MOST OF THE
CONCERN REALLY DOES COME FROM
THIS KIND OF NEW- WELL IT'S NOT
NEW IT'S BEEN IT WAS APPROVED BY
VOTERS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE
BUT JUST THIS EMERGING- AB STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT OR SELF
CONSTRAINT WHERE IT REQUIRES
THAT A CERTAIN PORTION ARE AND
NOW DEFENDING THERE'S A LINK TO
THE AMOUNT OF REVENUES THAT ARE
RAISED- EITHER BEING. SPENT ON
THESE EXCLUDABLE PURPOSES OR OR
GIVEN BACK AS TAX REFUNDS AND
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HANDLE THAT-
OR ADDRESS THAT IN THE MOST
RECENT YEARS BECAUSE OF THIS
REALLY UNPRECEDENTED SURPLUS.
THAT WE HAVE KIND OF THIS SORT
OF. A FINDING THAT IS THAT IS
NOT DEDICATED TO OUR ON GOING
EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT CAN
INSTEAD BE AB DIRECTED TO
ADDRESS THIS- THESE THESE
REQUIREMENTS. ARE BUT AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT HAD YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT WE'RE NOT FORECASTING THAT
LEVEL OF SURPLUS TO CONTINUALLY
REALLY DIDN'T SEE IT AS AS KIND
OF AN UNEXPECTED UNANTICIPATED-
LARGE ONE TIME WINDFALL AND SO.
WHEN HAVING THESE CONSTRAINTS
AND THESE REQUIREMENTS FOR A
CERTAIN TYPE OF SPENDING WITHOUT
THAT- OKAY UNACCOUNTED FOR.
EXTRA FEW WELL FUNDING MEANS
THAT WE EITHER NEED TO COME UP
WITH A FUNDING ELSEWHERE- YOU
KNOW FROM RESERVES WITH IS
OBVIOUSLY THE LEAST IMPACTFUL OR
LOOK INTO BASED PROGRAMMING SO
IT IS IT IS A NEW. CONSTRAINTS
AND- ARCHITECTURE SITUATION THAT
THE BUDGET HAS TO DEAL WITH THAT
IS THAT HASN'T BEEN IN THE PAST-
SO THAT'S ONE SET OF CONCERNS
AND THEN THE OTHER IS THERE ARE
AGAIN PRETTY PRETTY CONCERNING
SIGNS OF A POTENTIAL RECESSION-
KIND OF ON THE HORIZON. WHICH
WOULD ALSO COMPLICATE THINGS IF
WE IF WE HAVE LESS REVENUE OF
COURSE IF WE HAVE LESS REVENUE
IT ALSO MEANS THAT ARE SELF
FUNDING REQUIREMENTS BUT DOWN SO
THAT HELPS A LITTLE BIT IN THAT
AREA BUT- YOU KNOW A LOT OF A
LOT OF UNCERTAINTY I THINK.
SPENDING AND SO I THINK. PART OF
OUR BIG MESSAGE IS OBVIOUSLY YOU
HAVE TO DRESS YOURSELF CONCERNED
REQUIRED- DOES HE SHARE WITH THE
WITH SOME OF THIS EXCLUDING.
INTO REFUND PROPOSAL. BUT TO THE
DEGREE. YOU CAN MINIMIZE YOUR-
ON THE HONDA. ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE SUBJECT TO THE LIMIT AND
INSTEAD PUT THAT FUNDING IN
RESERVES WE THINK IT WILL REALLY
HELP YOU. AT IN THE IN THE YEARS
TO COME. THANK YOU. LIKE TO
DIRECT MY QUESTIONS TO- MR
CROWFOOT AND HIS DEPARTMENT- SO
LAST YEAR WE HEARD FROM DIRECTOR
BONHAM ABOUT THE HATCHERIES WE
HAD SOME BIG ISSUES IN THE
HATCHERIES AND- IN IN THE IN
THIS. IN THE IN THE WATER
PORTION OF ALL OF MY NOTES HERE
THERE'S GOING TO BE QUITE A FEW
P. WISE ADDITIONAL STAFF. AND IF
YOU COULD GIVE ME AN UPDATE ON
WHERE THE RESOURCES THAT WE
SPENT LAST YEAR ON THE
HATCHERIES IN THIS IN THIS
SITUATION WITH THE HATCHERIES-
THROUGHOUT OUR SYSTEM IN THE IN
THE LEAST IN THE NORTHERN PART
OF STATE I'M- WAS WANTED TO GET
AN UPDATE ON THAT. AND THEN THE
SECOND QUESTION I HAVE- IS
ABOUT- THOUGH WE ALSO AUTHORIZED
FUNDS IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
BUDGETS TO- BASICALLY. GET OUR
WATER RIGHT SYSTEM- DATA SYSTEM.
SET IN A WAY WHERE IT'S NOT A
PAPER WOULD BE ONLINE AND I
WANTED TO GET AN UPDATE ON WHERE
WE'RE AT ON THAT THOSE PROJECTS
THAT WE FUNDED IN THE LAST
BUDGET CYCLE. YEAH I THINK SO
THANKS SO MUCH SENATOR LET ME
TURN TO DIRECTOR JOHN BONHAM AT
FISH AND WILDLIFE FOR THE FIRST
QUESTION. AND THEN OF COURSE OUR
OUR COLLEAGUE CHAIR JOAQUIN ASK
ABOUT AT THE STATE WATER BOARD
FOR THE SECOND. SENATOR DOLLY
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ABOUT- HATCHERIES THREE THINGS
IN RESPONSE. WELL I DON'T HAVE
ALL THE METRICS- READING MY
FINGER TIPS WE CAN FOLLOW UP
WITH YOUR OFFICE AND GIVE A
PRECISE ACCOUNTING. OF THE
CURRENT BUDGET AND THE PRIOR
BUDGET. WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR AUTHORIZED US
FIXING CERTAIN INFRASTRUCTURE
ACROSS OUR WHOLE SYSTEM. SO WE
CAN IDENTIFY THE EXACT NUMBER
PROJECTS NUMBER OF NEW TRAILERS
NEW CHILLERS NEW UV SYSTEMS
ETCETERA AND WE'D BE GLAD TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON THAT
FRONT. SECOND WITHIN THE MAY
REVISE RIGHT NOW IS A SEPARATE
PROPOSAL THAT YOU MAY BE
REFERRING TO ABOUT OUR
HATCHERIES AND INLAND FISHERIES
FUND REALIGNMENT. AND THAT MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL WOULD DEDICATE
FIFTEEN PERMANENT POSITIONS THE
LABOR FORCE WITHIN OUR
HATCHERIES AS SECRETARY CROWFOOT
WAS MENTIONING. WE'VE HAD
INFRASTRUCTURE CHANGE WE'VE HAD
PRODUCTION INCREASE BUT WE
ALWAYS HAVEN'T HAVEN'T ALWAYS
FOLLOWED WITH THE NECESSARY
NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO DO THE WORK
IN THE HATCHERIES WHICH ARE
OFTEN OUT IN THE RURAL
LANDSCAPE. SO THAT'S POINT
NUMBER TWO AND THEN THIRD.
WITHIN THIS MAY REVISED IS ALSO
ANOTHER HATCHERY RELATED
PROPOSAL SOMEONE SEPARATE SO I
THINK IT'S SEVENTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS. AND THIS PROPOSAL IS TO
LOOK ACROSS ALL OF THE TWENTY
ONE STATE AND FEDERAL HATCHERIES
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WITH EXPERT
HELP ANALYZE WHAT PRESSURES
THEY'LL FACE UNDER CLIMATE
CHANGE AND FIVE TEN FIFTEEN
YEARS OUT. AND THEN BEGAN TO
MAKE THOSE CHANGES A VERY GOOD
EXAMPLE RUSSIAN RIVER WARM
SPRINGS HATCHERY LAST YEAR IN
THE DROUGHT WITH THE U. S. ARMY
CORPS WE ALMOST RAN OUT OF COLD
WATER IN THE RESERVOIR. AND HAD
TO SHUTTER THE HATCHERY WE MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO RELY ON A LARGE
RESERVOIRS ABOVE HATCHERIES FOR
COLD WATER ANYMORE AND THE
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
SUSSMAN SPEAKS TO ANALYZING AND
FIXING FOR THAT FUTURE PROOFING
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
BOTTOM I PUSH IT THAT I WANTED
TO- ALSO PUBLICLY APOLOGIZE TO
YOU- LAST I THINK WAS LAST WEEK
I MENTIONED THIS SAFE HARBOR
AGREEMENTS AND YOU REACHED OUT
TO ME APPARENTLY YOUR PHONE. WAS
BLOWING UP I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THOSE ISSUES UP IN AND SISKIYOU
COUNTY- THE OTHER THING I WANTED
TO ASK ABOUT WAS THE YEARS-FUNDING IN HERE FOR- CANNABIS-
HELP I THINK IT IS FOR BUT IT
IT'S BASICALLY HOWEVER. WHO IS
TAKING CARE THAT THERE'S
POSITIONS FOR CANNABIS I THINK
IT'S TWENTY POSITIONS FOR IT'S
COMING OUT THE CANNABIS BUDGET.
OF NORTON POINT HERE. YES
ACTUALLY SIXTY ONE POSITIONS ON
GOING- SO HOW'S THIS GOING TO
WORK IS THIS GOING TO BE- IN
SUPPORT OF THE LOCALITIES
BECAUSE IN THE DID IN THE IN THE
COUNTIES THAT I REPRESENT THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES- GETTING CODE
ENFORCEMENT AND ENOUGH LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO GO IN. AND AND
DEAL WITH THE ILLEGAL GROWS THAT
WE HAVE- IT THROUGHOUT MY
DISTRICT AND I KNOW THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IT'S A HUGE PROBLEM.
YEAH I THINK SO MUCH I WOULD
FIRST MAYBE TURNED AT THE
CHARLESTON WELL TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION ON THE- ON WATER RATES
TO TODAY'S DEBATE DIGITIZATION-
AND INTERNET SHOPPING JOAQUIN ON
THE QUESTION OF CANNABIS
POSITIONS. OR MIGHT. YEAH THANK
YOU SENATOR ON- THE- FUNDING
THAT WE RECEIVED LAST YEAR WHICH
WAS THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO-
UPDATE OUR WATER RATES DATA
SYSTEM SO THIS IS THE ELECTRONIC
WATER RATES SYSTEM THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN UPDATED- HERE IN SOME
DECADES I IS IN A GOOD PLACE
WHERE ACTUALLY ACTIVELY
SELECTING CURRENTLY UP UNDER
WE'VE TAKEN- WHAT ARE
IMPROVEMENTS IN PROCUREMENT FOR
OTHER AGENCIES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND OTHERS. HAVE
REALLY ADVANCE TO BE ABLE TO
HELP STATE AGENCIES BETTER
NAVIGATE AND COME QUICKLY TO A
FINISHED PRODUCT- AND SO WE'RE
REALLY I'M HOPEFUL THAT HERE
WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR- EVEN AS
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO UNDER IN
SELECTING A VENDOR BURKE WE'RE
ALREADY SANDBOXING WITH REAL
SYSTEMS AND BEING ABLE TO WORK-
RELATIVELY QUICKLY FOR AN AGENCY
THAT. HAS IS REALLY NEEDED- AND
INVESTMENT LIKE THAT TEN MILLION
OF IT IS TO DIGITIZE- WHAT OUR
PAPER RECORDS. AND THAT ACTUALLY
PART OF THAT AND THE CONTRACTS
AND DISCUSSIONS ARE GOING ON FOR
THE SYSTEM THAT WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING TO BE ABLE TO INVEST IN
IN HERE WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR
HAVE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
POSITIONS THAT WE REQUESTED FOR
THIS FISCAL- COMING FISCAL YEAR
THIS WILL REALLY COMPLEMENT ALL
THE INCREDIBLE WORK THAT'S GONE
LAST YEAR TO WORK WITH WATER
RIGHT HOLDERS IN VARIOUS OTHER
STATES INCLUDING UP IN THE
KLAMATH WATERSHED ON SCOTTISH
SHASTA- AS WELL AS THE RUSSIAN
RIVER WATERSHED IN AND BROUGHT
THE DELTA. TO BETTER IT ACTUALLY
HAVE BEEN MISSED. AND WHO HAS
HAS ACCESS TO WHAT CAN BE ABLE
TO ONE REPORTERS IN THEIR
WATERSHED TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
WHAT ARE VERY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
DROUGHT SO THAT THE POSITIONS OF
REQUESTING NOW REALLY COMPLIMENT
WHAT IS THAT INITIAL INVESTMENT
IN JUST THAT THE DATA BACK AND
WHICH- YOU KNOW IT IT REALLY
TOUCHES SO MANY OTHER ASPECTS OF
THE PORTS WORK- IT'S YOU KNOW
OUR OUR WATER RIGHTS THE SYSTEM
DOESN'T JUST LIVE IN A SILO SO
WHAT IS ACTUALLY HELPING US TO
REALLY IS ACCELERATE A LOT OF
MODERNIZATION AT THE WATER BOARD
THAT WE THOUGHT SOARED. IT WILL
TELL. INTEGRATE DATA. ACROSS NOT
JUST WATER RIGHTS BUT WATER
QUALITY. DRINKING WATER AND
RESPONSE TO COMMUNITIES EVEN.
AND ROUTE SO- APPRECIATE THE
REQUEST ON THE UPDATE AND GLAD
TO. BE ABLE TO A BIG BROTHER ON
ON HOW THE PROJECTS GOING OVER
THIS NEXT YEAR. SO WE HAVEN'T
LET A CONTRACT OUT YET THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. I WE'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF- AND I HAVE THE
I'VE I'M NOT PART OF THE
SELECTION OF THAT THAT'S ALL
HANDLED APPROPRIATELY
<c.red>NDEPENDENTLY OF ME BUT AS I</c>
UNDERSTAND- FOLKS IN THE MIDDLE
OF SELECTING THAT BACK. AND-
THANK YOU. CENTER AS THE
CANNABIS SPECIFICALLY FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT TWO THINGS BACK IN
JANUARY- TEN AND THAT BUDGET
PROPOSAL FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
OUR DEPARTMENT- SIX- SEVEN
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS THOSE ARE
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE FORTY ONE WHICH IS YOU
KNOW IS AROUND- DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROLS LICENSURE AND
PROVISIONAL LICENSES WE WILL
HAVE A WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT. I THINK YOUR QUESTIONS
MORE ABOUT OUR WILDLIFEOFFICERS
WE HAVE OUR OFFICER RANKED AS
HIGH AS EVER BEEN BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S LEADERSHIP AND
WE'RE IN PRETTY REGULAR
COORDINATION WITH THE SHERIFF
AND SISKIYOU COUNTY AND OTHER
COUNTIES IN YOUR DISTRICT AND
WILL REMAIN SO BECAUSE THIS IS
THE TIME OF YEAR WHERE WERE
WORKING OUT IN A JOINT FORCE
DEPLOYMENT TO DEAL WITH THESE
ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES ACROSS THE
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE. AND
IT SHOULD BE USEFUL WE PROVIDE A
FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR OFFICE
OFFLINE ABOUT THE- I PERSONALLY
MY GOODNESS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE SIXTY ONE
INJECTIONS THAT WERE REFERENCED
WERE ACTUALLY POSITIONS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
RECREATION- THESE POSITIONS WILL
WORK ON THAT. PREVENTING ILLEGAL
CANNABIS- CULTIVATION STATE
PARKS REMEDIATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT RESTORATION
OF NATURAL HABITATS IMPACTED BY
ILLEGAL CANNABIS GROWS. AND I
CAN CONFIRM THAT THEY WILL ALSO
BE COORDINATING WITH LOCALS ON.
SO. OKAY THE PROJECT OUT TO SO I
WANTED TO MOVE ON TO CALIFORNIA-
I DO HAVE A COUPLE CONCERNS I
MENTION THIS TO. OTHER MEMBERS
ON THE COMMITTEE- SO A LOT OF
OUR- FUEL REDUCTION PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN LAID OUT IN YEARS
PAST HAVE- WE'RE BID THE
CONTRACT WERE BIT BY THE
CONTRACTORS. ON FUEL COSTS THAT
WERE AROUND THREE DOLLARS A
GALLON AND THAT'S DOUBLED. SINCE
THEY'VE TAKEN THOSE CONTRACTS SO
MANY THOSE CONTRACTORS- THAT I'M
HEARING FROM- THROUGHOUT THE
DISTRICT AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ARE NOT ABLE TO. MAKE MAKE
A PROFIT QUITE FRANKLY AND SO
THERE THERE'S BEEN A MOST THEIR
RESOURCES ON APPEAL SO IS THERE
AN ABILITY- FOR A STIPEND. TO
EXISTING CONTRACTS- SO WE CAN
KEEP THOSE- FUEL- REDUCTION
PROJECTS GOING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN
CERTAINLY LOOK INTO. M. WE ARE
REALLY PROUD OF. USING THE
FUNDING THAT YOU ALL PROVIDED
LAST YEAR STARTING WITH THAT
EARLY ACTION BUDGET IN APRIL
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX. MILLION
DOLLARS FOLLOWED UP BY EIGHT
HUNDRED SOME ODD MILLION. I JUST
SEVERAL MONTHS LATER AND WE'VE
GOT OVER FIVE HUNDRED. PROJECTS
WELL OVER FIVE HUNDRED PROJECTS
I THINK UNDER WAY AS A RESULT OF
THAT MONEY DOES THOSE PROACTIVE-
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE PROJECTS- THE CONCERN
YOU RAISED IS THE FIRST TIME
I'VE HEARD IT AND SO I CAN
COMMIT THAT BUT WE WILL GET BACK
TO YOU FROM OUR AGENCY. FOR
THOSE GRANT PROGRAMS THAT
ENTITIES THAT ARE NOT RELATED TO
CAL FIRE I ADMINISTER AND THEN I
WOULD TURN IT OVER TO CHIEF
TYLER TO ANSWER ON BEHALF OF CAL
FIRE. THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY
FOR THE QUESTION A SOMEWHERE TO
SECRETARY PRO BUT- IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT OTHER
GRANTEES ARE WORKING WITH THEIR
LOCAL- GRANT ADMINISTRATORS BUT
IT IS- HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR- I
WILL- CONFER WITH STAFF HERE- TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY. RECOGNIZING
THE INCREASE AND IN FUEL COSTS
FOR THOSE FUNDS. THIS JUST FYI
SO IF YOU'RE A LOT OF THESE
PROJECTS ARE FUNDED NOT JUST BY
. YOU KNOW CAL FIRE THERE FUNDED
BY A CONSERVANCY A FIRE CITY
COUNCIL FEDERAL MONIES ALL THESE
MONIES ARE COMPILED TOGETHER FOR
A LOT OF THESE. PROJECTS WERE
THEIR PROJECTS CROSSOVER FROM
PRIVATE PUBLIC AND FEDERAL LANDS
AND SO THE THEIR LET THE
CONTRACTS HAVE BEEN LET FOR SO
MANY DOLLARS PER ACRE TO TREAT.
AND THEN YOU KNOW THEY THEIR OF
THEIR TO COUPLE YOUR CONTRACT
WILL WHEN THE WHEN THE PRICE OF
FUEL GOES UP. THESE CONTRACTORS
IMMUNITY IS DOUBLING THEIR COST
OF FUEL SO THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
TREAT THE ACRES- BECAUSE THEY
JUST FRANKLY ARE LOSING MONEY
AND SO THEY'RE STOPPING- AND
WAITING FOR THE FUEL TO COME
DOWN WHAT MAY BE A LONG TIME
BEFORE THE FUEL COMES DOWN WE
NEED TO TREAT THOSE ACRE SO. I
BROUGHT IT UP TO CENTER MCGUIRE
I KNOW THAT HE'S HE'S AWARE OF
IT BUT THERE'S THERE ARE
FORMULAS- THAT WE ALL USE IN
PRIVATE INDUSTRY I'M IN THE
TRUCKING BUSINESS WE HAVE A
FORMULA THAT ADDS FUEL GOES UP.
THERE'S AND THERE'S A FUEL
SURCHARGE PUT ON. AN IDENTITY
QUAID'S TO WHATEVER THE AMOUNT
IS SO THAT THE CONTRACTOR CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK IN. AND CREATE
AND FINISH PROJECT
UNFORTUNATELY. OUR GRANT
PROGRAMS DON'T KNOW THEY- ARE. A
FIXED AMOUNT. SO THERE HAS TO BE
SOME. OF THE- ABILITY TO BUILD A
PUT IN. THOSE FUNDS TO COVER
THOSE COSTS SO I JUST WANTED TO
DO I WANTED ON RECORD I KNOW
IT'S A PROBLEM. WE NEED TO TREAT
THESE ACRES- SOONER THAN LATER
SO- I'M HOPING THAT WE CAN
FIGURE THAT OUT THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS MY LAST. A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS- I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE GRID- ROUTE. BRED
RELIABILITY- I DIDN'T SEE MUCH
IN HERE ABOUT- TRANSMISSION IN
CALIFORNIA FOR GETTING POWER
WHERE WE NEED. TO MOVE IT AROUND
BECAUSE OUR GREAT IS ANTIQUATED-
THAT'S ONE QUESTION IT WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE PLAN FOR LONG TERM
STABILITY IN THE GREAT WE HAVE A
LOT IN HERE. ON ON ZAPS IN DRIED
STRIKES AND ALL THESE THINGS
THAT ARE GOING TO USE- THERE'S
EIGHT SIX BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE NEXT FOUR YEARS ON ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. I'D LIKE FOR
SOMEBODY TO TOUCH ON- THE GRID
RELIABILITY- WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- ROLLING BLACKOUTS THIS
SUMMER AND WERE. YOU KNOW
TALKING ABOUT TAKING OFF- POWER
PLANTS LIKE- THE ONE IN SAN LUIS
OBISPO THE NUCLEAR BLAST NUCLEAR
PLANT IN CALIFORNIA SO CAN
SOMEBODY ADDRESS. A GRID
RELIABILITY FOR THE FOR THE OVER
THE NEXT FEW YEARS- PUTTING ALL
THESE- YOU KNOW ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. ON THE GRID QUITE
FRANKLY THAT'S WHAT THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING I'D LIKE TO SEE WHAT
THE LONG TERM PLAN IS BORDERS
SHORT TERM PLAN THEY JUST CAN.
CONTINUE TO BUILD MORE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES FROM WHAT I
SEE HERE IT DOESN'T TALK ABOUT
GRID RELIABILITY. YEAH I THINK
SENATOR WE'VE GOT LEADERS FROM
BOTH THE ENERGY COMMISSION AND
ARE INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR
IT'LL TURN TO IN JUST A MOMENT.
I WILL JUST EMPHASIZE BOTH
RELIABILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
ARE KEY PRIORITIES AS WE
MODERNIZE OUR GRID. AND AS WE
ALL KNOW WE'RE DEALING WITH
THESE UNPRECEDENTED HEAT WAVES
ACROSS THE ENTIRE SOUTHWEST THAT
ARE STRAINING OUR GRAD. SO A LOT
OF INVESTMENT IN THE IN NEAR
TERM RELIABILITY- BUT TO YOUR
QUESTION- LET ME TURN TO
COMMISSIONER SEE ABOUT GOING TO.
OUR FIRST- TO ANSWER. THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR YOUR QUESTION I
WOULD I WOULD KIND OF PLACE THAT
THE STATED THAT MANY HIGH LEVEL
I'M DELIGHTED YET YOU. ASKED FOR
AND I WOULD. REQUEST COLLEAGUES
FROM. CALAVERAS A TO HELP ANSWER
THE TENTH WE SHOULD QUESTION
PARTICULARLY IN HOW WE'RE
PLANNING FOR THAT. IN TERMS OF-
THE LIABILITY PLANNING. FOR THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS AS YOU AND
DENOTE. WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF
DIFFICULTY MAKING SURE. WE CAN
BALANCE SUPPLY AND DEMAND- AND
TO ENSURE THAT THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO DO ADEQUATE PLANNING. AND I
WOULD I WOULD WANT TO GO TO THE
AS TO THE S. AND P. METICULOUS
STEPS THAT'S HOW WE THINKING
CARRILLO. SO ONE YOU KNOW APPY
OBSERVATIONS OF. AUGUST TWENTY
TWENTY- WE ARE VERY CLEAR AND
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR TO US THAT
CALIFORNIA. IS AT THE TIP OF THE
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS TO. BOTH
OUR DEMAND SIDE AS WELL AS
SUPPLY SIDE. SO WE ARE DOING.
EVERYTHING WE CAN IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING THE RISK I TO
DEMAND. AS WELL AS SUPPLY AS WE
PLAN TO THE NEXT. FIVE YEARS THE
FIRST STEP ABOUT THIS IS STILL
DOING ADEQUATE PLANNING TAKING
ALL OF THOSE THINGS INTO
ACCOUNT. AND ENSURING ENOUGH
PROCUREMENT HAVE BEEN OPTIMIZED
REPORTS THAT. SECOND TEMPLE THAT
WOULD BE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
AUTHORIZED PROCUREMENT IS
ACTUALLY BEING BILLED IN A
TIMELY FASHION. AND FINALLY THE
THIRD PART OF IT IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO A PARTICULAR SUMMER. WE
LOOK AT- WHAT IF WHAT IS ON THE
HORIZON OVER THE NEXT SIX
MONTHS. AND THINK THROUGH WHAT
EXTRAORDINARY- MEASURES SHOULD
BE TAKEN IN ORDER TO TAKE YOUR
ADDED THAT A LIABILITY AND IN
THE SHORT TERM. ON THE PLANNING
AND PROCUREMENT OPERATING OF THE
PROCUREMENT PART. WE HAVE DONE A
NUMBER OF. THE STATE HAS TAKEN A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT ACTIONS. IN
TERMS OF PLANNING FOR CERTAIN
LEVELS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
AUTOMATING PROCUREMENT- SO IF
YOU HAVE AUTHORIZED- A LARGE
AMOUNT APPROACH GOVERNMENT I
ALMOST FIVE THOUSAND. MEGAWATTS
OF NEW. OUT COMMUNITIES. TO
SUPPORT THE GRADE TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT- THE LAY BUT THAT IT
TOOK. THAT YOU AMEND. AND THEN
WE- YOU KNOW AS WE LOOK THROUGH.
THAT THE POPE THAT WE'VE- IT
ALSO TAKE A ACCOUNT. THAT THE
DIFFERENT RESOURCES WE EXPECT TO
RETIRE INCLUDING. ADDED DIABLO
CANYON AT TWO THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
ROUGHLY AS WELL AS SOME OF THEIR
LEGACY- ONCE THROUGH COOLING
AFTER THAT I KNOW ABOUT ABOUT
FOUR THOUSAND MEGAWATTS. SO WE
HAVE TAKEN THAT INTO ACCOUNT.
WHAT ONE OF THE THINGS WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO CATCH NOT PLAN IS. A
COMPOSITE COINCIDENTAL EVENTS
THAT ARE CONTINUING TO UNRAVEL.
APPLE IN- AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY
WE LOK AT HIGH HEAT-
POSSIBILITY OF START PLANNING
FOR HIGH HEAT. BUT WHAT WE
OBSERVE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WHAT ARE THE LIABILITY SITUATION
WAS NOT BECAUSE OF HIGH KEY IT
WAS MORE BECAUSE THE FIRES AND
FIRE RELATED OUTAGES PUT ON THE
TRANSMISSION OF LAST GENERATION
SITE. SO WE'RE TAKING THOSE
THINGS INTO ACCOUNT AND TRYING
TO PLAN THROUGH AND NOW AS WE
LOOK AT THE COINCIDENTAL NATURE
OF ALL BUSINESS. IF THEY WERE TO
OCCUR IN EXTREME UP AN EXTREME
SITUATION THAT MODOC RESPECT WE
ARE LOOKING AT EXTREMELY
OBNOXIOUS. YEAH MUCH OF THE
BUDGET THAT THEY GIVE TODAY
DISCUSSED- REALLY REALLY LOOKS
TO THINK ABOUT THAT LOOKING A
STRATEGIC RESERVE TO- OTHER SUCH
AS SUCH AN EXTREME TO. IN TERMS
LONG TERM PLAN. AS YOU KNOW- WE
THE TIME PLAN THAT IT. THROUGH
AND IT HIGHLIGHTS AND I WILL I
TO THEM. IN A MOMENT- AND ALSO
WANTED TO OFFER THE PLANNING WE
ARE CONTINUING TO LOOK AT-
SCENARIOS. HI OF PETITIONS IN
OPERATING APPROACH. THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO REQUEST MY PROPERTY-
ARGUED MILLER. YES THIS IS MARK
ROSS FISHER- CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER AT THE CALIFORNIA ISO.
AND I WILL REPEAT- MUCH OF THE
MATERIAL THAT- VICE CHAIR GUNDA
HAD ALREADY EXPRESSED I'LL FOCUS
MY COMMENTS ABOUT THE
TRANSMISSION PLANNING. AND IN
THAT REGARDS THE TRANSITION PLAN
THAT WE DEVELOP IT IS- ALIGNS
WITH ULTIMATELY THE PROCUREMENT.
ACTIVITY IN THE RESOURCE
PLANNING THAT IS CONDUCTED THE
CPUC- SO WE TRY TO KEEP UP WITH.
THE TRANSMISSION NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT THOSE RECURSOS RESOURCE
PLANS. I THINK WE'RE IN AN
EXTRAORDINARY- DYNAMICSTHE RIGHT
NOW WHERE THE RESOURCE PLANS
HAVE BEEN INCREASING YEAR OVER
YEAR AND AS A RESULT OF THAT-
THE TRANSMISSION PLANNING- TO
SUPPORT THAT. HAS BECOME MORE
CHALLENGING AN INCREASE IN THE
FACT THIS LAST YEAR- WE
APPROVED- ABOUT TWO POINT NINE.
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF.
ADDITIONAL TRANSMISSION- TO
SUPPORT THAT INCREASING GROWTH
AND WE EXPECT THAT TO INCREASE.
IN THE COMING YEARS OF THE-
RESOURCE PLANS INCREASE. AS
WELL. I THINK IT IS THE SECOND
POINT IS- WE CONDITIONALLY- LOOK
OUT- IN THE FIVE TO TEN YEAR.
PLANNING HORIZON- THIS PAST YEAR
WE ALSO. LOOK OUT OVER A TWENTY
YEAR OUTLOOK. TO ALIGN WITH THE
CDC'S SB ONE HUNDRED- AND-
AND IN DOING SO WE TRY TO
PROVIDE SOME INSIGHTS INTO WHAT
IS THE TRANSMISSION NECESSARY IN
THE LONGER TERM- TO SUPPORT
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT FOR. THE
CLEAN ENERGY TRANSITION- THESE
WILL BECOME ACTIONABLE AS
THEY'VE KIND OF ROLL INTO MORE
THE TENURE RISE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TO ADAPT THOSE
AND IDENTIFY THOSE OF LARGER.
MORE SIGNIFICANT. PROJECTS THAT
ARE NECESSARY TO KEEP THE TRANS
ASIAN- MOVE FORWARD- SO THAT I
WILL STOP IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS. I JUST THANK YOU FOR
THOSE COMMENTS I WANTED I WANTED
ON RECORD BECAUSE I THINK THAT.
THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS WHO DON'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA RATE WE TALKED ABOUT
THE DIRECTOR TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT. THE RATES. CALIFORNIANS
PAY ALMOST A BILLION DOLLARS. IN
RATES TO SHIFT POWER OUT OF OUR
STATE BECAUSE WE OVER PRODUCED
DURING CERTAIN TIMES WE HAVE A
LOT OF WIND AND SUN- AND WE HAVE
NO ABILITY TO TRANSPORT THE
POWER TO PLACES IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE NEED IT WE HAVE A HUGE
TRANSMISSION PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA AND- YEAH WE TALK
ABOUT GETTING POWER WE WANT TO
GO WE NEED TO DO IF THERE'S IF
THERE'S ONE STATE OF EMERGENCY
IT'S BUILT ENDING POWER LINES IN
THIS IN THE STATE. TO GET THE
POWER THAT WE OVER GENERATE TO
THE PLACES THAT WERE UNDER
GENERATED SO I WANNA GO ON
RECORD AND WE TALK ABOUT I ONLY
HEAR ABOUT HIS BATTERIES ARE
GOING TO SAVE US. THEY'RE NOT.
THEY'RE NOT SAVING US AT THE
MOUNT OF POWER WE NEED TO
ELECTRIFY OUR TRANSPORTATION.
SECTOR AND ALSO POWER ARE. IN
INDUSTRY IN OUR HOMES- WE CAN'T
GET. PER PERMITTED FACILITY
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE I MEAN.
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
COMING ONLINE I'D LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT THE PROJECTION OF GETTING
ONE OF THOSE PLANTS BUILT IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE NEXT TEN
YEARS. BECAUSE TEN YEARS AND
DOLLARS WERE SUPPOSED TO MEET.
OUR ELECTRIC VEHICLE MANDATE.
AND SO I ACTUALLY USED TO BUILD
POWER LINES AND BUILD POWER
PLANTS WHEN I WAS YOUNGER. AND I
ME TAKE SOME YOU DON'T JUST DO
THAT OVERNIGHT. AND THE
PERMITTING PROCESS IN CALIFORNIA
SO ANTIQUATED THATFOR US TO GET
WHERE WE WANT TO GO IS GONNA BE
VERY DIFFICULT SO I WANT THIS
COMMITTEE TO UNDERSTAND. AND
THEN ON TOP OF THAT I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT AT LEAST- CANYON
WHICH I DON'T ONE OF THE MEMBERS
ON THIS COMMITTEE. REPRESENTS I
BELIEVE- THEY'RE DROPPING THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE USING
THAT THAT IS THE STORAGE FOR.
NATURAL GAS THAT RUNS PEAKER
PLANTS WHEN YOU HAVE. HI HE AND-
AND NEED ELECTRICITY SO WE HAVE
NO ABILITY TO. PRODUCE ENERGY
CALIFORNIA'S GONNA BE IN THE
DARK. AND WE'RE GONNA SEE A LOT
OF PEOPLE REALLY FRUSTRATED IN
CALIFORNIA'S I WANT. I WANT AND
WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT THIS WE
DON'T TALK ABOUT. THE LONG TERM
EFFECTS OF THE SHORT TERM
PROBLEMS BECAUSE WE DON'T DO
GOOD PLANNING AND- LOOKED UP THE
ISO IS BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
WHEELING POWER WE CAN'T WILL
POWER IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
RIGHT AMOUNT OF TRANSMISSIONS I
KNOW THAT. SENATOR BACKER IS
DOING A BILL ON TRANSMISSION WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THAT BILL WE
NEED TO BUILD ALLOW CALIFORNIANS
TO GET POWER WHERE THEY NEED IT
AND DRIVE THE COST OF THE SAME
TIME. SO THOSE ARE THE LASTING
THE LAST THING I HAVE MISTER
CHAIRMAN IS THERE'S NO WHERE IN
THIS BUDGET. THAT I COULD FIND
WHAT WE TALK ABOUT ACTUALLY.
BUILDING WATER STORAGE- SITES
RESERVOIR IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
THERE'S PLENTY OF MONEY IN THE
BUDGET WE SHOULD FUND THAT
PROJECT FULLY OUT OF OUR- OUT OF
OUR SURPLUS AND BILL SITES
RESERVOIR IT'S A GREAT PROJECT
FOR. NUMBER ONE ENVIRONMENT AND
ALLOWS THE DELTA OPERATED
EFFICIENT WAY IT HELPS FISH
HELPS KEEP US COLD WATER WHERE
WE NEED IT. AND WE NEED WATER IN
CALIFORNIA IF WE'RE GOING TO
SEE- WHAT WE'VE SEEN A LOT OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS. WHERE WE
SEE A LOT OF WATER FLOW BECAUSE
THE TEMPERATURES ARE RISING AND
ARSENAL BLACK PACK IS COMING IN
RAIN- WE SAW THE OROVILLE
SITUATION A FEW YEARS AGO WE
SHOULD CAPTURE THAT WATER.
INSIGHTS RESERVOIR WE'D HAVE IT
FOR TODAY DO USE BUT THESE
PROJECTS TAKE TIME AND WE NEED
TO FUND THEM RIGHT NOW AND MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I
THANK YOU FOR. ALL OF THE TO
ROUND A CALL TO- ANSWER MY
QUESTIONS I APPRECIATE IT DO WE
HAVE A COMMENT ON THE SITES
RESERVOIR AND WATER STORAGE- YES
COMMENT- THANK SENATOR DON. WE
AGREE SITES RESERVOIR CAN AND
SHOULD BE AN IMPORTANT PART OF
OUR SOLUTION MOVING FORWARD.
CAPTURING WATER IN THE WAIT
YEARS FOR USE IN YEARS LIKE
WE'RE EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW. I
AM I AM PROUD THAT THE WATER
COMMISSION HAS MOVED. OUT OF
SEVEN OF THESE PROJECTS THAT
WILL BE FUNDED BY OUR PROP ONE.
A GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND. NOW
WELL OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS
FOR STORAGE. THREE SURFACE
STORAGE PROJECTS FOR UNDERGROUND
WATER PROJECTS PROVIDING TWO
POINT SEVEN. MILLION ACRE FEET
OF STORAGE. I'M STATES IS MOVING
FORWARD IT'S OBVIOUSLY THE
LARGEST. A RESERVOIR OF ITS KIND
IN A GENERATION SO IT HAS A
NUMBER OF STEPS THAT IT HAS TO
GO THROUGH. BUT WE'VE GOT A BIG
SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF PUBLIC
FUNDING. I INTO THAT PROJECT. I
AND THEN THE THAT MAY REVISION
BUDGET ALSO CALLS FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
BUDGET YEARS- TO AUGMENT
PROJECTS SUCH AS SITES. I'M SO
WE DO NOT FEEL LIKE WE ARE
GROWING. FOCUSED ON HELPING THAT
PROJECT COME ONLINE AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE. LAST POINT NOW I'M
- GOVERNOR GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS
DIRECTED ME TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STATE PROCESS THESE ARE WATER
COMMISSION ISN'T- SLOWING DOWN
THE PROGRESS OF GETTING THOSE
PROJECTS ONLINE. AND SO WE'VE
BEEN REALLY FOCUSED ON THAT AND
HE'S RECENTLY DIRECTED US TO GO
FURTHER THAN THAT AND WORK WITH
THE SEVEN PROJECT TO IDENTIFY
HOW WE CAN REMOVE BARRIERS TO
ACCELERATE THOSE PROJECTS COMING
ONLINE BECAUSE I THINK WE ALL
RECOGNIZE WE NEED TO DIVERSIFY
OUR WATER SUPPLIES. JUST THANK
YOU FOR THAT COMMENT I JUST WANT
TO. SAY WE HAVE NINETY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS. AND WE
SHOULDN'T JUST BE RELYING ON
PROP ONE MONIES WE SHOULD PUT
SOME OF THIS MONEY INTO THE- THE
PROJECTS THAT'S AT ODDS ALL I'M
SAYING I NEED THERE IF THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND ONE TIME
MONEY. THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THAT WE SHOULD BE TALKING
THAT WE SHOULD BE SPENDING THE
MONEY THERE THAT'S ALL I'M
TRYING TO. PUSH ON THE BUDGET IS
TO PUT THE MONEY IN THERE. EVERY
DAY THAT WE DON'T. PUT A SHOVEL
IN THE GROUND. THE INFLATION IS
DRIVING THESE PROJECTS. IN
SOMETIMES DOUBLE THE PRICE AND
SO. EVERY DAY WE WAIT IT'S GOING
TO CONTINUE TO GO HIGHER. AND WE
WON'T HAVE THESE MONIES
ACCORDING TO THE L. A. IF BY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WE'RE GONNA
SEE A DIP. IN THE KANEMI AND
IT'LL BE FRUSTRATING TO NOT HAVE
A PROJECT BUILT ONCE AGAIN AND
RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME TO DO SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING EVEN MORE OF
THE GENERAL FUND. AND A SURPLUS
GOING TOWARDS THOSE PROJECTS
THANK YOU. SAN REQUIRED HAVE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR I JUST GONNA
PROVIDE JUST SOME COMMENTS- IN A
DISAPPOINTED MOMENT SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO THE HAIR CARE
WHAT KASKY FOR- HIS DUE
DILIGENCE- HIS HARD WORK- IN HIS
MANY YEARS OF COMMITMENT TO THIS
PROCESS AND PEOPLE CALIFORNIAN
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU TO THE
BUDGETS UP TO STAFF TEAM FOR ALL
THEIR WORK- IN GETTING THIS TO
US YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT
TO CRUNCH INTO THE ENTIRE SENATE
BUDGET TEAM AS WELL. THE JUST
GONNA BE DOING SOME COMMENTS AND
I KNOW THAT WERE ALL SPIT
BALLING ON SEVERAL ISSUES THAT
ARE IN FRONT OF US- IN THERE IS
A LOT OF WORK. TO CONTINUE. I'M
GONNA START OUT. LIKE A BROKEN
RECORD AS I WAS DOING TALK ABOUT
WILDFIRE SEASON AND- LOOK MY
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS WILDFIRE
SEASON IS A THING OF THE PAST IN
THE STATE- FIRES. ARE NOW- YEAR
ROUND CHALLENGE. AND THEY'RE
BURNING MORE INTENSELY. AND WE
HAVE SIMPLY NOT STAFFED UP. TO
MEET. THIS ERA OF MEGA FIRES. WE
HAVE. IN WE ARE NOW IN THE WORST
DROUGHT IN TWELVE CENTURIES. AND
WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
PREDICTIONS FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO YEAR AHEAD WE BURNED
ALMOST ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
ACRES ACROSS THE WEST- AND
THAT'S FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES MORE. COMPARED TO THE TEN
YEAR AVERAGE. SO PREDICTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA IT'S NOT LOOKING
GOOD. IN WHILE I GREATLY
APPRECIATE WHERE THE GOVERNOR
THE SECRETARY- IN CHIEF TYLER
HAVE ADVANCE IN THIS MAY REVISED
IT'S SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH- IN I
HAVE GREAT RESPECT. FOR
SECRETARY CRAWFORD I WAS JUST
SHARING WITH SENATOR STERN THAT
HE IS ONE OF THE HARDEST WORKING
IN STATE SERVICE. AND THE FIRE
CREWS IN THE SUPPORT STAFF THAT
ARE BEING ADVANCED IN THIS
BUDGET DOESN'T BEGIN TO FIX THE
SHORTAGE THAT WE SEE IN
CALIFORNIA. IT DOESN'T. AND I AM
GRATEFUL THAT WE'RE ADVANCING
CONSERVATION CORPS CREWS IN
STAFFING UP THE NATIONAL GUARD
BUT LET'S JUST BE CANDID WE HAVE
A CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA RANKS IN
THERE ARE PROUD BUNCH THEY DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS THAT EXIST BUT
THE FACT IS THAT WOMEN A MINUTE
CAL FIVE WHO WERE DEPLOYED FORTY
FIFTY SIXTY DAYS AT A TIME YEAR
AFTER DAM YEAR AFTER DAM YEAR IT
DOESN'T WORK ANY LONGER. AND THE
ONLY WAY THAT WE'RE GONNA GET
THROUGH THIS IS BY INVESTING. IN
RELIEF IN THE WAY WE GET TO
RELIEF IS BRINGING ON ADDITIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND THAT IS NOT THE
SILVER BULLET WE ALSO HAVE TO
INVEST IN PREVENTION IS WELL-
AND THAT'S WHY THE SENATE IS
GOING TO INVEST. IN ENHANCED
RESOURCES FOR PREVENTION BUT WE
SHOULD BE DOUBLING THE NUMBER
THE SIXTEEN HAND CREWS THAT WERE
HIRED LAST YEAR WE SHOULD. BE
BRINGING ON ADDITIONAL. RELIEF
FULL TIME PERSONNEL TO STAFF UP
FIRE ENGINES IT'S SIMPLY NOT
ACCEPTABLE IN JUST GOING TO BE
CANDID I KNOW YET AGAIN. FOR THE
SEVENTH YEAR IN A ROW WILL BE
STANDING ON A STREET IN A
COMMUNITY THAT I PROBABLY
REPRESENT WATCHING HOMES BURKE.
ON THE PHONE IT TOO I AM THE
CHIEF TYLER- IN BACON FOR
RESOURCES IN THOSE RESOURCES
SIMPLY WON'T BE ABLE TO COME
BECAUSE THE WEST IN THIS STATE
IS TAPPED OUT. AND WHY WE
CONTINUE TO SOUND THIS ALARM
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR AND
NOT INVEST. IT BLOWS MY MIND. IN
JUST BEING CANDID ABOUT IT I'M
SICK OF HEARING. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE COME IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND TALK ABOUT. WHAT
THEY'VE DONE IT'S SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH IT'S NOT ENOUGH. IN WHY
WE SIT HERE FRIEDGEN ACCEPTING
THIS. RIDICULOUS ANSWER THAT WE
SIMPLY HAVE ENOUGH STAFFING A
CAL FIRE IT JUST BLOWS MY MIND
AND YOU CAN TELL I'M INCREDIBLY
FRUSTRATED AND IT'S SUPER
PERSONAL FOR SO MANY OF US
BECAUSE WE ARE SEEN OUR
COMMUNITIES. LITERALLY BURNED
DOWN. SO NOW SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
STAFFING UP IN WE SIMPLY DON'T
DO IT WE DON'T DO IT. SO I WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO CONTINUE TO PUSH-
THE SENATE HAS ITS PLAN- IT'S IN
THE BUDGET AND AGAIN THESE ARE
JUST MY OWN COMMENTS ON ASKING
QUESTIONS BECAUSE HONESTLY I
DON'T WANT TO HEAR. THE ANSWERS
BECAUSE IT'S THE SAME ANSWER
THAT I HEARD LAST YEAR AND THE
YEAR BEFORE THAT SO THAT'S WHY
I'M JUST OFFERING COMMENTS AND
I'M NOT GOING TO SWITCH TO THE
ISSUE OF FIRE PREVENTION. SO ON
FIRE PREVENTION- AGAIN WE CAN'T
DO ONE WITHOUT THE OTHER RIGHT
WE HAVE TO STEP OFF THE CALFIRE
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO HAVE TO STEP
UP FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION. THE
WHERE THE SENATE WANTS TO GO IS
THE ONE THING FIVE BILLION PLUS
A SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR CONSERVANCIES. I
THINK THAT IS SMART IN WHAT WE
LEARNED FROM LAST YEAR WITH
CONSERVANCIES- WE ARE ABLE TO
GET THAT MONEY OUT QUICKER- AND
I THINK THAT IS A WINNING. MODEL
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH. I ON THE ISSUE
SALMON- REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
HUNDRED MILLION THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING. FOR
SALMON. A TO BE A PROTECTED
SPECIES FROM TOTAL COLLAPSE. I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO. DIRECTOR BONHAM DR
BONHAM HAS BEEN ON THIS LIKE A
HAWK- AND WE'RE ALSO GONNA NEED
ADDITIONAL DETAIL FOCUSED. ON
THE SPECIFICS ON HABITAT
RESTORATION WATER WAY
ENHANCEMENTS. IN I KNOW THAT
WORK IS STILL TO COME- IN AGAIN
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
AFTER AFTER BONTA FOR HIS WORK
ON THAT. JUST JUMPING- I'M
ALMOST DONE HERE AND MISTER
CHAIR IN REGARDS TO THE SENATE A
CLIMATE PROPOSAL AGAIN- AND I AM
SURE THAT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM SENATOR STERN IS WELL ON
THIS. ISSUE AND GRATEFUL FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THAT A LITTLE
CHAIRED BY CAL SKI IS. THE
REASON WHY THE SENATE IS GOING
BIG AND- ADVANCING THE MOST
AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE ACTION BUDGET
IN THE UNITED STATES THIS YEAR
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE LEVEL CRISIS
THAT EXISTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE LOOKING AN
ADDITIONAL THREE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS WHEN IT COMES TO
SEA LEVEL RISE IN PREPARING OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR SEA LEVEL RISE
IN LOOKING AT MANAGED RETREAT.
WHY WE'RE LOOKING AT A BILLION
DOLLARS TO INVEST FOR THE FIRST
TIME ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
COMMUNITIES- THE MOST VULNERABLE
TO THIS KIND OF CRISIS. DID
MANAGE COMMUNITIES. THAT'S WHY
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT MONEY BUT
DEVELOPING THE INTERIM TARGETS
TO BE ABLE TO HIT OUR TWENTY
FORTY GOALS THAT IS. REALLY
CRITICAL BECAUSE HONESTLY WE'RE
NOT WE ARE HERE TWENTY FORTY
GOALS UNLESS WE BENCHMARK THEM
HERE IN THE YEARS TO COME. AND
THEN ALSO. IT BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSS. ABOUT THE POWER GREAT I
THINK WE'RE GONNA BE SHORT ABOUT
FOURTEEN TO SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS. POTENTIALLY THIS
COMING SUMMER AND FALL WHICH IS
ALARMING. AND THAT'S WHEN THE
SENATE IS GOING TO BE ADVANCING
A PLAN. TO BE ABLE TO GET NEW
GREEN POWER EIGHT POWER
GENERATION FACILITIES ONLINE
FASTER WITH THE SEVEN YEAR PLAN
FOCUSING. ON INDUSTRIAL SOLAR
OFFSHORE WIND ON CHARLIE ENTRE
NGUYEN IN. DEVELOPING ADDITIONAL
COMMERCIAL GEOTHERMAL PLANTS
WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
FINALLY IN JUST SOME THANK YOUS
AS WELL ON CANNABIS- GRATEFUL
AND I KNOW WE'RE NT FOCUSING ON
THIS IN THIS COMMITTEE. AGAIN WE
- I AM BIASED I COME FROM A
COMMUNITY THAT GENERATES. ABOUT
TWO THIRDS OF THE CANVAS IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. YOU'RE
WELCOME- BUT- BOTTOM LINE IS
THIS THE TAX REFORM THAT WE NEED
ON THE CULTIVATION SIDE- IS
CRITICAL GRATEFUL THAT THE-
ADMINISTRATION- DIRECTOR
ELLIOTT- FROM BEER CANS CONTROL
GOVERNMENT NEWSON. IS FOCUSING
ON THIS BUT I ALSO BELIEVE-
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO CONTINUE
INVESTING ADDITIONAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE WE ARE
WE'RE STAFFING UP BUREAU OF WITH
ABOUT TWENTY POSITIONS OF
ADDITIONAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS JUST BEING HONEST. IT'S
BEEN CHALLENGING TO BE ABLE TO
HIRE ON FISH AND WILDLIFE HAS
BEEN AN INCREDIBLE PARTNER WITH
A LOCAL SHERIFF'S OFFICES. BUT
TO BE ABLE TO HELP STABILIZE THE
MARKET. WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON
WHERE THE- I'M LICENSE
UNPERMITTED CANNABIS PRODUCT IS
COMING FROM AND THERE ARE
LITERALLY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
ACRES IN THE STATE. THAT HAVE
BEEN POINTED WITH UNLICENSED
UNPERMITTED CANNABIS- MMHM. MANY
OF WHICH ARE TAKING FROM-
STREAMS THAT ARE IMPAIRED BY THE
DROUGHT OR STRAINS THAT HAD
ENDANGERED SPECIES. AND WE WERE
ABLE SECURE ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION IN THE BUDGET LAST YEAR
FOR LOCAL SHERIFF'S OFFICES TO
TAG TEAM WITH- THE BUREAU ALONG
WITH FISH AND WILDLIFE TO BE
ABLE TO GO IN. TO ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS. ON THESE ON LIGHT.
FARMS I THAT OUR THREAT THE
SPECIES IT'S A AS TAKEN FROM
IMPAIRED WATERWAYS. IN WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO DO MORE OF THAT
HAD TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST FISH
AND WILDLIFE PLUS OUR LOCAL
SHERIFF'S OFFICES. IN THAT ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION CANDIDLY IS A
DROP IN THE BUCKET. COMPARED TO
WHAT WE SEE ACROSS THE STATE
ESPECIALLY. THE NORTH STATE
LASTLY MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
SAY A FEW THANK YOUS. TWENTY ONE
TO SAY THANK YOU TO CHAIR ASK
ABOUT- ASK ABOUT AND HIS TEAM.
AT THE DEPARTMENT HAVE BEEN
ACTIVE IN ENGAGE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE NOT FOCUSING ON THIS
DROUGHT CRISIS- HE FOCUSES ON
LARGE COMMUNITIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND A SMALL
COMMUNITIES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA- AND TAKING A VERY
STRATEGIC APPROACH IN THAT. AND
TAKE ANY WORSE FOR STRATEGIES
THAT YOU'RE ASKING I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THAT. YOU
KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT MORE
WORK TO COME. ALSO DID DIRECTOR
BONHAM UP FOR HIS WORK ON ALL
ISSUES A SALMON AND FINALLY ON
SECRETARY. SECTOR CROWFOOT- YOU
ASK- THIS GENTLEMAN WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN SENATOR STERN
SISTER CREE ASKING WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN SENATOR DOLLY
SISTER T. AS HIS FINGER ON THE
PULSE. HE'S ACTIVE HE'S ENGAGED-
AND ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK ON
THAT. AND LOOK FOR THE SCENE-
THIS BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS. ON
COME TO FRUITION AND WORKING ON
GETTING SOME ADDITIONAL
CHARACTERIZATIONS- INTO. THE
BUDGET IS WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR SINISTER. YEP M. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
AND IT PRESHEAF THE TESTIMONY
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION- AND
THAT IN NO WAY DO I CONSIDER
THIS THIS HEARING YOUR SWANSONG
MISTER CHAIR BECAUSE- WE HAVE A
SERIOUS NEGOTIATION ON OUR HANDS
TO ENGAGE IN AND THE HISTORIC
BUDGET SURPLUS TO WORK ON AND I
THINK- THEIR THEIR RISKS. OF
UNDER DOING IT WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE WHETHER IT'S FIRE WATER
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS ENERGY.
ARE ARE SIGNIFICANT- I'LL MAKE
SOME COMMENTS AND I HAVE A JUST
A COUPLE QUESTIONS- I WANT TO
ECHO AS A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIAN
WHOSE DISTRICT IS ON FIRE AT THE
SAME TIME MY BROTHERS HERE TO
THE NORTH. AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
WERE ALSO ON FIRE THAT. WE'RE
ONE FAMILY WHEN IT COMES TO
FIREFIGHTING. AND THE CONCERN I
HAVE ABOUT THE CURRENT BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT IN CREWS- IS THAT. BY
FAILING TO INVEST DEEPLY NOT
ONLY IN IN THE CALIFORNIA RANKS
BUT ALSO IN THE RANKS OF OUR
CONTRACT COUNTIES. ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT ARE INVOLVED ARE
JOINT JOINT USE AGREEMENTS- THE
FOLKS WHO ARE THERE TO FLEX WHEN
NEEDED. I THINK OF OUR L. A.
COUNTY TEAMS THAT WENT NORTH TO
FIGHT IN PARADISE THE SAME I'M
AT THEIR BACKYARD WAS A FIRE
BECAUSE WE SIMPLY DIDN'T HAVE.
THE WOMAN AND MAN POWER TO
ADDRESS IT- I HAVE DEEP CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT AND I THINK WE CAN I
THINK WE CAN WE CAN ADDRESS IT.
I SEE IT IN THE SENATE'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL- I THINK WE NEED A
ROBUST PACKAGE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THAT URGENT
ISSUE- AND THIS IS GOING TO HAVE
TO BE. AS THE SECRETARY WELL
NOTED INVESTMENT PEOPLE. T IT'S
NOT YOU CAN'T JUST DO WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE ALONE- BUT I
THINK IT'S WELL WORTH IT- I'LL
SAY ON ON WATER- YOU KNOW THE
WORK CURRENTLY UNDER ZERO
ALLOCATION IN LARGE STRETCHES
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
THAT ARE DEPEND ON THE STATE
WATER PROJECT. AND THE
CONDITIONS ARE TO BE. QUITE DIRE
SPECIALLY IN FIRE COUNTRY- FIRE
IS GROWING IN A LACK OF WATER-
IS A VERY VERY BAD FORMULA AND-
I DID HAVE A QUESTION
POTENTIALLY I THINK FOR D. W. R.
ON ON SORT OF HOW THAT
ALLOCATION FITS IN WITH THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL HERE. BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT- UNDER THE
UNDER THE CONTRACT THAT D. W. R.
HAS- WITH AUTO ON STATE WATER
PROJECT THAT. THAT THERE IS AN
ALLOWANCE FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONDITIONS LIKE EXTREME FIRE
RISK AND YET NONE OF THOSE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONDITIONS ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE ALLOCATION-
JUST BROKE BEFORE I ASK YOU WHAT
THE BUDGET NEXUS TO IT DO I HAVE
THAT. THAT ACCURATE THAT FIRE
ZONES HAVE NOT BEEN RECOGNIZED
IN THE- IN THIS ZERO ALLOCATION. I DON'T KNOW IF THIS NAME IS
THERE ANYONE FROM HER TEAM A D.
W. ARE STILL. IS SENATOR I
BELIEVE WE HAVE SEEN THE-
MESSNER WHO IS THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE W. R. TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION BUT IF SHE'S NOT.
ABLE TO COME ON SCREEN I WILL DO
MY BEST TO ANSWER THAT. THANK
YOU THE BILL. MORNING SECRETARY
THIS IS TED CRADDOCK A SERVICE
THAT YOU DIRECTOR FOR THE STATE
WATER PROJECT. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SENATOR. FROM OUR STATE
WATER PROJECT ALLOCATION IS
CURRENTLY 5% OF FOR THE
CONTRACTORS TO RECEIVE WATER. IN
ADDITIONALLY WE'RE PROVIDING
HEALTH AND SAFETY WATER TO. A
FEW OF OUR CONTRACTORS THAT HAVE
ADDITIONAL NEEDS FOR HUMAN.
HEALTH AND SAFETY SO HOPEFULLY
THAT ANSWERS THE QUESTION. BUT
THOSE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
ALLOCATIONS DO NOT INCLUDE- THE
AREAS I REPRESENT. RIGHT DIDN'T
THAT MET REGIONS I MEAN I DON'T
KNOW WHAT WHAT AREAS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S NO
ACCOMMODATION FOR HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES ALL THROUGHOUT
THE SOUTH LAND IN THAT
ALLOCATION IS THAT TO HAVE THAT
ACCURATE I'M THINKING OF AREAS.
IN D. W. P. K. A GUESS LOS
VIRGINIS- I MEAN THOSE ARE
THAT'S MY BACKYARD I'M SURE
THERE ARE MORE SANTA CLARITA.
THE OF A SENSE. YEAH THE- WHAT
WE'VE ASKED FOR IS FOR OUR
CONTRACTORS TO IDENTIFY WHETHER
THEY HAVE ANY HEALTH AND SAFETY
NEEDS. BEYOND THE 5% WATER
ALLOCATION PROVIDED. AS ON THE
CASE THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT THEY HAVE REQUESTED
ADDITIONAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
WATER THAT THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING. A TO THAT DISTRICT
WHICH IS THEN DISTRIBUTED TO THE
RETAILERS AND THEIR THEIR
SERVICE AREA. OKAY LOOK I'LL
FOLLOW UP THEN ON THAT- AND
MAYBE JUST TRY TO GET A LITTLE
MORE GRANULARITY ABOUT WHAT TO
EXPECT BECAUSE I THINK WHAT WHAT
PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ABOUT I MEAN
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO SERVE
APPROACHING THIS DROUGHT.
SELFISHLY IN JUST SAYING I WANT
MY- YEAH I WANNA HOLD ON TO MY-
MIKE. BECAUSE MEDIC. BECAUSE
MEDICALLY INTERESTED AND WHETHER
IT'S A LONGER- YEAH THE
BOUGAINVILLEA. BUT I THINK FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT INTERFACE
WITH THE WILL BE- WE'VE GOT
SERIOUS COMMUNITY BENEFITS THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT AND SO IF
WE LET. THOSE ASSETS DIE OFTEN
WE LOSE OUR OAK WOODLANDS OR WE
LOSE THE INTEGRITY OF OUR- OF
OUR CHAPARRAL ON THE HILLSIDES.
THAT WE'RE NOT ONLY GONNA HAVE A
LOT MORE FUEL ON OUR HANDS BUT
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO HAVE-
POTENTIAL- EROSION MUD SLIDE
ISSUES IN THE LIKE SO LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING ON THAT-
MIGHT MY WATER QUESTION. BEYOND
THAT IN IN THE BUDGET CONTEXT
IS- ABOUT THE RECYCLED WATER
BUDGET AT I SEE HERE- HUNDRED
MILLION. IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL FOR WATER RECYCLING-
AND- I KNOW THE SENATE HAS. I
THINK- BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
ON THAT FRONT. AND I'M WONDERING
JUST IN TERMS OF HOW FAR YOU
EXPECT- WATER RECYCLING
GROUNDWATER CLEAN UP TO GO AND
HOW FAST WHAT'S THE- WHAT HOW
SHORT ARE WE GONNA BE IN TERMS
OF OVERALL. PROJECT NEEDS OUT
THERE WITH THE WITH THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL IN THE REVISED. I CAN
TAKE PART OF THAT SENATOR- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT THE HUNDRED MILLION IS FOR
GRANTS AND ANOTHER WAY THAT WE
FINANCE A LOT OF THESE WATER
RECYCLING PROJECTS IT'S THROUGH
THE STATE REVOLVING FUND. THERE
I THINK OVER JUST THIS LAST YEAR
WE'LL HAVE COMMITTED ABOUT ONE
POINT SIX BILLION TO WATER
RECYCLING PROJECTS THAT'LL
CREATE ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND ACRE FEET A YEAR OF NEW
SUPPLY SO THAT'S THE IF THE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION THAT'S BEEN REQUESTED.
FOR THE STATE MATCH FOR THE
STATE REVOLVING FUND THOSE COULD
BE CONSIDERED AS WELL- IMPORTANT
DOLLARS FOR WATER RECYCLING WHEN
IT COMES TO WHAT YOU KNOW THE
POTENTIAL NEED IS OUT THERE.
THERE'S A LOT AND WHEN IT COMES
TO- GRANTS- YOU KNOW IF IT IS
THEN YOU KNOW THE COMPONENT THAT
HELPS WITH AFFORDABILITY BUT SO
DO THE LOANS THAT STATE
REVOLVING FUND. CAN PROVIDE
WHICH ARE YOU KNOW HOW THE BOND
RATE WHICH FOR ME AT THE
SIGNIFICANT PROJECTS BUT THEY
CAN COST HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS- IT CAN BE A SIGNIFICANT
SAVINGS TO AFFORDABILITY AND
COMMUNITY ITSELF. JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE AND FLAGGED- THAT OF
THE PROJECT IS A PROPOSED.
POSSIBLE BEHIND- THIS PRINT
THESE PROJECTS BEING DEPLOYED
AND WE KNOW THE- YOU KNOW THE
UPGRADE POTENTIAL- JUST TAKE ONE
WATER RECYCLING PLANT- CARSON OR
HYPERION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
FIVE TO SIX BILLION DOLLAR
PROJECTS AND THAT'S JUST FOR-
THE SOUTH LAND ALONE SO I KNOW
THE NEED IS HUGE I KNOW YOU'RE
WELL AWARE OF IT- BUT I WOULD
LOVE TO SORT OF GET A SENSE OF
HOW FAR WE EXPECT BOTH WITH THE
COMBINATION OF THE REVOLVING
FUND. AND WITH THE GRANTS- A
QUICK YOU KNOW SORT OF IN
PROPORTION A NEEDS ASSESSMENT I
THINK WOULD HELP TO SET SOME
EXPECTATIONS BECAUSE THIS TO ME
SEEMS LIKE A- REALLY SMART YEAR.
TO BE GOING BIG ON THAT KIND OF
WATER RESILIENCE INFRASTRUCTURE
SO- LOOK FORWARD TO FOLLOWING UP
THERE. WHAT WHILE I HAVE YOU A
CHERISHED KABEL I WANTED TO A
PIVOT TO ENERGY BRIEFLY- IT MAY
SEEM ODD THAT I WOULD BE. ASKING
YOU I ALSO. I THINK THE QUESTION
ALSO GOES SOMEWHAT TO D. W. R.
BUT- YOU KNOW WE HAD A
DISCUSSION. I THINK IT WAS LAST
YEAR AND EVEN THE YEAR BEFORE
THAT- AROUND- THIS SORT OF ONE
TIME EXTENSION OF ONCE THROUGH
COOLING- GAS PLANTS AROUND THE
STATE. AND AS WATER CHAIR MY
CONCERNS WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS OF EXTENDING SOME OF
THESE ALREADY OUTDATED-
COMPONENTS OF OUR FLEET I'M
TRYING TO GET A SENSE HERE AND
I'M NOT SURE. WHICH PARTY
MINISTRATIONS BEST TO ASK THIS
BUT- IS THERE AN INTENTION WITH
THE STRATEGIC ELECTRICITY
RELIABILITY RESERVE- TWO WEEKS
FURTHER EXTEND THE LIFE OF. OF
THOSE KINDS OF GAS PLANTS AROUND
THE STATE. THANK YOU SENATOR AND
YOU KNOW HOW WE HAVE AN
INSTRUMENT KNOWN AS IRAQ GROUP
KNOWN AS A SACK WITH WHICH IS
OUR- A GROUPING OF ALLIES SO ON
THE ENERGY COMMISSION. IF YOU
SEE AND THEY- HAVE GATHER AND
CONSULT UP TO THE BOARD WHEN UP
AND FLAG WHEN POTENTIAL CHANGES
WILL WILL. AB I THINK AT THIS
POINT WE'RE WAITING OR- SOME
SIGNAL AND CONVENING FROM THE
SOUTHWEST TO DOUBLE TO LET THE
BOARD KNOW OUT WHAT. I REQUEST
MAY BE COMING TO THEM TO HELP
FACILITATE I KNOW WHAT R. I.
ENERGY CHALLENGES. THAT- HAVE
BEEN SPOKEN ABOUT. THANKS FOR
THAT. AND MAYBE I COULD TURN TO
I THINK. MAYBE W. R- OR THE OR
THE ENERGY COMMISSION- YEAH IT
LOOKS LIKE THE DVR FOUR POINT
TWO BILLION AND- AND THEN THE
ENERGY COMMISSION WHICH IS
PLAYING A REALLY IMPORTANT NOT
JUST DEPLOYMENT ROLE BUT ALSO
PLANNING FUNCTION. IN ENSURING
THAT NO THROUGH THIS RELIABILITY
CHALLENGE THAT WERE ALSO-
ACCELERATING OUR OUR CLIMATE
GOALS I THINK WE CAN DO BOTH. I
DON'T THINK IT'S A CHOICE
BETWEEN- YOU KNOW INCREASE
EMISSIONS ENDS FURTHER SETTING
OURSELVES BACK IN OUR OUR
SCOPING PLAN TARGETS. AND
MEETING RELIABILITY AS WE SAW
DURING THE EXTREME HEAT EVENTS-
AND THE FIRES THAT RELIANCE ON
CENTRALIZED BASELOAD GAS PLANTS
AS TEXAS DID THROUGH THEIR
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS WAS
ACTUALLY A- BAD STRATEGY- WE HAD
OVER HEATING. WE HAD
TRANSMISSION LINE CONSTRAINTS
AND YET THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
MEGAWATTS THAT I UNDERSTAND ARE
IN THE PIPELINE EITHER IN DEMAND
RESPONSE. THROUGH THIRD PARTIES
OR OR THE I. O. U.'S BUT
ESPECIALLY THROUGH THIRD PARTIES
AND AS WELL AS THE- THE SOLAR.
AND OTHER SORT OF FLEXIBLE
ASSETS THAT MAY BE BOTTLE
NECKED- AND HAVE SOME RISK IN
THE PIPELINE GIVEN THE- THE. THE
LARGER. THE FINANCIAL FACING-
THE SOLAR STORAGE COMMUNITY FROM
FROM SOME OF THE FEDERAL
INQUIRIES UNDER WAY- FTC IN
OTHER INVESTIGATIONS OF SORT OF
CAST TO. A BIT OF ANXIETY OVER
THE INVESTMENT CLIMATE AND I
WONDER IF WE CAN DO ANYTHING- TO
ACCELERATE DEPLOYMENT THERE IN A
WAY THAT DOESN'T COST THE
TAXPAYERS MUCH BUT SIMPLY DE
RISKS THE- THE PROJECT
DEPLOYMENT SO IF WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT. NO SEE THERE'S TWO
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF- COMMUNITY
SCALE- STORAGE AND SOLAR- IS
THERE FLEXIBILITY WITHIN THE
STRATEGIC ELECTRICITY
RELIABILITY RESERVE TO- TO SORT
OF. D. RISK THAT DEPLOYMENT AND
I'M TALKING A MATTER OF MONTHS
TO GET THOSE KINDS OF PROJECTS
ONLINE BECAUSE BUILDING A HIGH
VOLTAGE TRANSMISSION LINE WILL
TAKE YEARS IS CENTER DOLLY
RIGHTLY NOTED BUT THESE PROJECTS
WILL TAKE MONTHS AND THEY'RE IN
LINE IT JUST SOUNDS LIKE- WE
NEED TO JUST FIND A WAY TO. MAKE
THEM GO SO I JUST WANTED TO GET
A SENSE FROM WHOEVER THE
ADMINISTRATION SORT OF TAKING
THE LEAD ON. THAT RESERVE WHAT
THE WHAT THE OVERALL INTENTIONS
ARE- EXTENDING GAS MORE ABOUT
TRANSMISSION OR- OR SORT OF
DOUBLING DOWN ON ON CLEAN ENERGY
TO MEET THOSE NEEDS. YEAH I
THINK SENATOR STERN IN A MOMENT
I'LL TURN TO COMMISSIONER- AND-
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION AND YOU RIGHTLY KNOW
IT IS A PARTNERSHIP OF OUR
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR RCP
U. C. I CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION AND OF COURSE
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES
GIVEN. IT TAKES A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF ENERGY TO MOVE WATER
AROUND THE STATE. I WILL KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW PREVIOUS ACTIONS
TO ADDRESS THIS CRITICAL
PRIORITY OF MAINTAINING
RELIABILITY. YOU INCLUDED UNDER
. PROCUREMENT OF BATTERY STORAGE
WHICH I THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE
IS A LARGE PART OF THE FUTURE-
EMERGENCY GENERATION. AND
ACCELERATING. BUT COMMISSIONER
GUNTER CAN YOU JUST BECAUSE THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE RELIABILITY RESERVE I
THINK WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE CAN
YOU TO BACK UP AND EXPLAIN ITS
PURPOSE AND THEN THE SENATOR
STERN'S QUESTION- TALK ABOUT
SOME OF ITS CORE COMPONENTS.
THAT YOU ANTICIPATE INCLUDING.
THANK YOU AT CRAWFORD I THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR THE DETAIL
QUESTION- THANK YOU FOR CREATING
IT. OUT SO THAT ONLY SO I THINK
I JUST WANNA. FIVE STARTED THE
TOP AND IT JUST KIND OF TALKING
ABOUT THE- ENERGY TO LIABILITY.
AND THAT KIND OF AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE AND SECURING ENERGY
RELIABILITY. DURING THE-
TRANSITION. SO HAVE NO FRANKLY
SPEAKING IN OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS. THE CHALLENGES THAT
EXPEDIENCY ING- ARE. REALLY
EXTREMELY LARGE AND- YOU BELIEVE
IT. THANK YOU KNOW THE YOU KNOW
HEAT WAVES THE COOPER. HAVE I
THINK READING DEMAND BEYOND THE
MUCH BEYOND THE PLAN ASSUMPTION
. IT COULD BE EXTENDED DROUGHT.
YOU KNOW CURRENTLY- ARE LOOKING
GUY. A RECORD LEVEL TO DEBATE IN
IN HYDRO CONDITIONS AND IT COULD
BE SOMETHING LIKE A BOOK LIKE
WILDFIRE. THAT COULD KNOCK OUT
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND MEGAWATT
TRANSMISSION COMING INTO
CALIFORNIA. THE SERVER LOAD SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS- POTENTIAL
OF ALL THE THINGS CONVERGING. AS
WE MOVE PARTNER THE EXPLODING
THAT TOO AND I'M PRESS. LEVEL OF
RELIABILITY CHALLENGE. SO AS WE
THINK THROUGH THEN ADDED A
MEDIATION OF THAT- YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT THE GOT PROPOSAL-
PROPOSAL IS ABOUT. I DON'T HAVE
BILLION. FOR THE OVERALL
STRATEGIC RESERVE COMPONENTS.
AND THE RESERVE HAS TO BE KIND
OF THING THROUGH. AT THIS POINT
IN THAT THE AGENT COULD COME. TO
THROUGH. WE HAVE A NEED FOR.
ENSURING A LARGE AMOUNT OF
MEGAWATTS CAN QUICKLY COME
ONLINE SAID THAT THE- IF THE A
FUNCTION OF THESE RESOURCES THAT
WE COULD BRING IT TO THE STATE.
OUR IT'S ALSO THE- IN WHICH WE
DEPLOY THEM. I'M RESOURCE GUIDE
WITH THE- SO THAT WE NOT.
INHIBITED BY SUPPLIES ISSUES ON
A- TYPE. AND ALIGNMENT WITH
STATE AND PRIOR. AS WE THINK.
AND ALSO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEVERAGE FEDERAL FUNDING. SO
WHEN WE LOOK AT THAT- TALAGA.
THE TO TWO H. IN A WE HAD A AT.
QUICKLY RAMPING UP ITS FIFTY
RESERVE. AND THAT MIGHT NOT-
THREE. SOME THE ASSETS THAT ARE-
LOOKING TO RETIRE. BUT
MODERNISED THE THERE IN. THANK
SO THAT REMOVED HIM OF THE MY
PLACE. YOU'RE NOT TREATED IF THE
-REGULARLY WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
NEED FOR THE STRATEGIC. BUT
LOOKING AT SIXTY HOURS A YEAR
ROUGHLY SIXTY HOURS A YEAR. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHEN YOU HAVE THE
WALLET. OF BOTH INCREASED. AND
THE INTERSECTION OF POTENTIALLY
. A LOT MEGALITHIC SUPPLY. SO
MANY TIED TO OF AB THAT WHOLE.
AND FIX THAT OF OUR OF RESOURCE
. WE HAVE TO AT WHAT IS.
CURRENTLY A BILL. AND IT'S GOOD
DEAL TODAY. BUT BUILT IN THE CON
OF THE LAW. PRIORITIES CAN
BROUGHT THIS. RESERVE AT THE
WEIGHT US TO HOLD A TO THINGS.
ALL THERE INCLUDING AT THE END
BACKUP GENERATOR THAT ARE. WE
COULD HAVE PUT IN SOME- AND THAT
THE BUDGET HAS MONEY FOR
CLEANING COMING DIESEL ADDS THAT
. AND ALSO HAD MY FOR DEMAND BY
INCENTIVES. AND INCREASING
AMOUNT OF CLICK. THAT WE COULD.
EXPLORE SO OVERALL THE STRATEGY
WOULD BE GIVEN THAT THE LARGE
GAP THAT WE'RE OBSERVING. COULD
BE QUICKLY THEN CLAMPED UP WITH
WHAT RESOURCES WE QUICKLY BRING
ON. IN A COST EFFECTIVE MANNER
BUT AS WE GO INTO THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS OF CONTINUE TO. EXPAND THE
STRATEGIC RESERVE AND I THINK IT
TO THE ADEQUATE D. AS OTHER
POLICY PRIORITIES SHAPE UP WE
CAN THINK THROUGH- YOU KNOW
EXPANDING THAT INTO CLEAN. FIVE
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THAT WE DO
NOT WANT TO INTERFERE. WITH THE
PROCUREMENT OF THE UTILITIES SO
WE WANT TO UTILITIES TO
CONTINUE. MOVING FORWARD
ADEQUATELY TO WORK THE SB ONE
HUNDRED GOALS IN THE IN THE- IN
PROCURING THE CLEAN ENERGY
SOURCES. AND WE GIVE THEM THE
FREEDOM TO DO SO BY ALLOWING THE
FIFTY TWO COULD THERE BUT THE
INSURANCE. THAT'S COMPRISED OF A
BROAD. PORTFOLIO OF WITH CLEAN
AND TRADITIONAL WITH THE I. TWO
WORDS HOW QUICKLY CAN WE BUILD
AT A COST EFFECTIVELY BE CAN BE
BUILT AND PROVIDE FOR. OUR NEEDS
THAT. THANK YOU FOR THAT MISS OF
A CHAIRED. SAID JUST TO. TRY
INTERPRET YOUR- IT'S A LIKE.
THERE SOME NEAR TERM INTO. TO
LEAN ON. A VARIETY OF ASSETS BUT
BUT CERTAINLY- EXPANDING THE USE
OF GAS AND GOING BEYOND SAY THE
ONCE THROUGH COOLING RETIREMENT
TIMELINES DOES NOT SOUND LIKE
IT'S OFF THE TABLE IN FACT
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S VERY MUCH ON
THE TABLE AND- AND PART OF THE
PLAN IN THE NEAR TERM IS THAT IS
THAT FAIR TO SAY. FOR THIS
COMING YEAR. AT YES SENATOR.
OKAY THANK- ARE ALL I WOULD SAY
ON THAT NOTE IS THAT. I WOULD
JUST ASK THAT I KNOW THAT A
PIECE OF THIS PUZZLE IS ALSO THE
AT WITH THE ENERGY COMMISSION.
IF THERE'S IF THERE'S ANY WAY
TO. TO LOOK AT SORT OF A
PRIORITIZATION FRAMEWORK AS YOU
LOOK THROUGH IT FOR THOSE KINDS
OF ENERGY RESERVES. THAT ARE
GOING TO MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS
AS WELL. TO PUT THOSE- YOU KNOW
SORT OF. WITH WITH A RISK ADDER
ON TOP RIGHT WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
AT. WHAT WHAT ACTUALLY ISN'T
RELIABLE ENOUGH- TO MEET THESE
DEMANDS. I WOULD JUST ASK THAT-
YOU YOU ALL CONSIDER- SOME KIND
OF CLIMATE FILTER. THAT PLAN-
THAT ALSO LOOKS AT SPEED-
BECAUSE I THINK THAT. AS I SAID
I THINK THERE'S ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS. IN THE
PIPELINE OF. OF ASSETS THAT
DON'T REQUIRE ANY SUBSIDY THAT
ARE ALREADY BEING PLANNED AND
FOR DEPLOYMENT AROUND THE STATE.
WITH CLEAN STORAGE WITH SOLAR-
THAT SHOULD BE FLEXIBLE ENOUGH
FOR IT TO BE USEFUL TO THE AYE
SO AS WELL AS TO D. W. ARE SO.
HOPE YOU OAK CONSIDER THAT AND
HAVE SOME KIND OF PRIORITIZATION
FRAMEWORK SO THAT. WE DON'T SORT
OF SET OURSELVES BACKWARDS HERE
BUT I DO RECOGNIZE THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGE WE'RE FACING AND-
APPRECIATE. YOU KNOW THE
ENORMOUS PRESSURE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S UNDERSIDE THINK
YOU'RE SMART TO GET. AHEAD OF IT
AND- AND I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
YOU KNOW A GOOD CLIMATE STRATEGY
IS OUR BEST REAL RELIABILITY
STRATEGY SO- I APPRECIATE THAT.
THE ONLY OTHER THING I WANT TO
ECHO WAS JUST- ON WHEN IT COMES
TO. ABOUT FIRE PREVENTION AND
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS OF THESE
READ. POLLUTION'S I WANTED ECHO
MIKE MY COLLEAGUES IN THE NORTH-
WE'VE SEEN TREMENDOUS OUTPUT
FROM. BOTH THE B. C. B. AS WELL
AS OUR CONSERVANCIES AND WOULD
LOVE TO SEE YOU MINISTRATION.
AND KEEP LOOKING AT AT THAT END
OF THE SAID PLAN IS. GOT A VERY
ROBERT FRAME ON THAT FRONT AND I
THINK THE MONEY'S BEEN ABLE TO
BE PUSHED OUT THE DOOR VERY
QUICKLY. BOTH ON FIRE PREVENTION
AS WELL AS ON- ON SOME NATURE
BASED CLIMATE SOLUTIONS THAT
SHOULD HAVE SOME. A VERY
VALUABLE NEAR TERM IMPACTS SO I
HOPE YOU ALL WILL- WILL CONSIDER
THAT BUT I DO APPRECIATE JUSTIN
IN THE VERY NEAR TERM- NOT NOT
WINNING IN YOUR COMMITMENT ON.
ON THE BIODIVERSITY RISKS THAT
THIS DROUGHT AND FIRE CONDITIONS
ALSO FACING. TO DOUBLE DOWN A
WILDLIFE CORRIDOR. AND REALLY
NOT STOPPING AT LIBERTY CANYON
WANNA COMMEND SECRETARY CROWFOOT
FREEZE IT INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP
ON THIS FRONT AND IT'S VERY
EXCITING TO HAVE THE GOVERNOR
DOWN HERE DISTRICT TO DO THE
LARGEST. WILDLIFE QUARTER
PROJECT IN THE ENTIRE WORLD- BUT
I'M I'M TRYING NOT TO GET TOO
ENAMORED WITH IT BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT ONE QUARTER ITSELF WILL NOT
SOLVE THIS ISSUE. AND SO I
APPRECIATE JUST THE CONTINUE
LOOK TO THE FUTURE TO TRY TO-
LOOK TO THOSE SORT OF
BIODIVERSITY RISK HOT SPOTS
AROUND THE STATE. AND PRIORITIZE
THAT AND YOU KNOW DIRECTOR
BOTTOM AND YOUR ENTIRE TEAM
INCLUDING CHECK CALTRANS JUSTIN.
INCREDIBLE SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
WORK AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATION. THANK YOU
I'M- ENERGY COMMISSION ROOM
WATER RESOURCES LET'S STAY WITH
ENERGY FOR A WHILE BECAUSE- I'VE
GOT A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. I
GUESS UNLESS CENTERS DURIN'S
QUESTION DIFFERENTLY ON THE- SIR
THX ELECTRICITY RELIABILITY
RESERVE WHAT'S NOT IN. WHAT'S
NOT INCLUDED IN THAT BECAUSE THE
PARAGRAPH I GOT I GOT EVERY
EXISTING NATURAL GAS PLANT
DIABOLIQUE DABBLE CANYON ANY NEW
RESOURCES THAT MAKE CAN'T COME
ON NOT A LOT OF INFORMATION AND
HOW THAT MAY BE ACCELERATED THIS
SIR ANYTHING THAT'S NOT.
INCLUDED. AND THANK YOU AS
CHAIR- JUST A JUST FUNDING TO
YOUR COMMENT DIRECTLY ON THE
STRATEGIC RESERVE I THINK THE
GOAL OF THAT IS THERE WOULD BE.
DOES THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
DISPATCHABLE WHEN WE NEED THEM
SO THAT WOULD NOT GENERALLY
INCLUDE LARGE- BASED BASED POWER
SUCH AS DIABLO SO AT THIS POINT
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
STRATEGIC RESERVE WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT PUTTING TOGETHER. A
PORTFOLIO RESOURCES BUT IT COULD
BE A CONTRACTED AT THE SOURCES.
WHAT THE PREVIOUS ALREADY NEEDED
TO PROCURE OR THAT HE SOURCES
THAT WE MIGHT- BUT NEW STILL IN
THE GROUND APPLE ARE KIND OF
HOLDING ON TO CONTACT THE DOCTOR
IT'S A PRETTY LARGE- WE WOULDN'T
WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY. TO BE ABLE TO
ORGANIZE OURSELVES INTO AFTER
THEIR STORES POINT DOUBLE OF A
DISPATCH. IN CONSULTATION BUT
WITH THE CARD ON HOW BEST TO
ORGANIZE AT THE FLIGHT DISPATCH
OF THE RESOURCES. IN GENERAL I
THINK UNTIL THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE LARGE- BASELOAD RESOURCES
WOULD NOT BE WHAT WE WOULD THINK
OF FOR A STRATEGIC RESERVE
HAVING SAID THAT- I RECOGNIZE-
YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR I TALKED
ABOUT- PUTTING ALL THE- OPTIONS
ON THE- TABLE. OUT FOR- FOR. AT
PUTTING TOGETHER THE RELIABILITY
AND EXECUTING THE LIABILITY AND
IF YOU KNOW IF YOU KNOW
SOMETHING LIKE THE OUTLOOK AND
YOU WILL BECOME- OR OR OF THIS
AND FIND I DO KNOW THAT WOULD BE
A DISCUSSION. WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. LOOKING FOR. SO I
GUESS ONE OF THE MAIN. FOR A
HUNDRED TO SUPPORT. TO CARBOMER
. PROJECTS AT THAT AT ENERGY
COMMISSION MISS WHAT PROVIDING
MATCHING FOR WE KNOW THE
GOVERNMENT'S HASN'T WORK OUT
THERE. IF WE IF WE'RE GOING TO
ALLOW SOME OF THESE BERNIE- OR
POLLUTING PEAKER PLANTS ARE OLD
NATURAL GAS FACILITIES TO STAY
ONLINE FOR RELIABILITY WOULDN'T
YOU WANT TO INVEST MORE MONEY ON
LET'S SAY NEW NATURAL GAS
FACILITIES THAT MAY BE TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF CARBON CAPTURE OR
SOME BIO FUELS ARE SOME OTHER
THINGS. JUST AS A INSURANCE
POLICY ON THE CARBON GAME IF
WE'RE IF WE'RE TRYING TO BALANCE
OFF WITH OKAY THESE REAL BILL WE
HAVE A PLAN TO TAKE THEM OFF
LINE BUT IF WE- AND I THERE'S
PEOPLE WON'T LIKE THAT BUT BUT
FROM A CAR ANALYSIS WOULD YOU
WANT TO. PUT SOME MORE MONEY IN
THERE SO PEOPLE FEEL A LITTLE
LESS ANXIOUS. SINCE SINCE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT A NATURAL
GAS FACILITY IN ORDER TO CARBON
CAPTURE THEY DON'T GET ANY
CREDIT UNDER CAP AND TRADE AND
IT'S FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO DO THE PROJECT AND- A
HUNDRED MILLION OR EIGHTY
MILLION FOR A BIO MASS. AND THEY
GET THEY DON'T GET THE REDUCTION
OF CARBON. IT I'M I'M LOOKING
FOR SOME BALANCING AGENT HERE
WITH AT WITH. FIVE POINT TWO
BILLION ONE HUNDRED MILLION. NO
THANK. THAT CHAIR FOR THE
QUESTION- I WILL DEFER TO- ARE.
ON THE CALL FROM HE TO X. THE
INTENT OF THE AND ALL- FOR A
CARD TO WEIGH IN ON THE ON THE
BROAD. QUESTION YOU HAD AROUND-
THE CARD IN A BASEMENT- IN
MARKET STRUCTURE. VIRGINIA.
INSERTING YOU REPEAT THE
QUESTION AGAIN. PHYLOGENY COULD
YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN- THE INTENT
FOR THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
AFFECT YEAH I GUESS YOU HAVE A
VICE YOU'RE GOING TO THE IDEA
THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO. INVEST
IN CONTINUE WITH THESE- ARM FOR
RELIABILITY SOME OF THESE
POLLUTING HEAVY POLLUTING
FACILITIES IT AT THE TUNE OF
FIVE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
WHICH WE NEED FOR REAL
RELIABILITY LET'S ACCEPT THAT
YOU HAVE A HUNDRED MILLION TO
SUPPORT CARBON RENEWAL PROJECTS
WHICH SEEMS LIKE. A MAYBE ONE
BIO FUEL PLANT THAT WOULD GET A
GRANT THAT WOULD HAVE WOULD
REDUCE THEIR CARBON AND IF WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
RELEASES REGARDLESS OF ALL THE
OTHER STUFF WE DID WOULD YOU
WANT TO PUT A HIGHER INVESTMENT
WHY AGAIN IT'S FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION TO DO OCCUR- OF NATURAL
GAS PLANT WHATEVER THE NEW
NATURAL GAS PLANT IS THAT WOULD
GET TO. AT LEAST REDUCE THE
CARBON THAT WE EXPECT TO COULD
BE ON THERE WHEN WE NEED THE
ENERGY FOR A BALANCING HER THE
GREAT. I'M HEARING. ON ALL OKAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR KIND OF HIGH
LEVEL QUESTIONS. I WILL KIND OF
START WITH THAT BONTA NOTE ON TO
MY COLLEAGUE VIRGINIA SO I THINK
THAT YOU MAKE A VERY IMPORTANT
POINT ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
KEEPING THE OPTIONS OPEN AND
ESPECIALLY PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES YET TO BE A PART
OF THE POWER SECTOR OUR
CONVERSATION I WOULD LIKE A
VIRGINIA TO LAY OUT THE INTENT
FOR THE HUNDRED MILLION. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE. A CALL BACK
ON THE ON THE BROADER QUESTION
THANK YOU. OKAY SO- SO THIS
HUNDRED MILLION IS FOCUSED ON
AREN'T DETERRED. TECHNOLOGY FOR
DIRECT- CARBON CAPTURE. OF CO
TWO FROM THE ATMOSPHERE. AND
WHAT SIX MAKING BOLD EFFORT-
AGGRESSIVELY- CARBON WE RECKON
THAT. THAT WE'RE GONNA- OPEN IN
ORDER THE CHEESEBURGER-
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS.
AND THE HUNDRED MILLION FOCUSED
ON DIRECTOR CAPTURE BECAUSE
NEEDED TO REDUCE THE AT AND WE
CAN DO TO LIVEHE RESIDUAL
MISSION THE NEEDS TO BE
CONTINUED TO BE A BETA THAT CAN
BE OF THE THROUGH- NORMAL
PROCESSES INTO THIS COULD BE THE
LEGACY FIELD EMISSIONS THAT
NAME. AFTER WE DO OUR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY- INTO- NO POINTS WERE
SCORED CAPTURE AND. THESE OTHER
THINGS. AND THIS. TO HELP TO YOU
REDUCING AND ACCELERATE. AFTER
AIR CAPTURE TECH SO THAT WE CAN
REDUCE THE COST AND THE ENERGY
INTENSITY AND OPERATING
EFFICIENCY. AND TO THE FRONT OF
USED TO SUPPORT- FIVE RESEARCH-
HOTEL AND HIGHLAND BEACH. AND
TESTING OUT OF NEW- TECHNOLOGIES
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND. THE COSTS
AND ALSO DEFINED WAYS ON HOW TO
REDUCE. THE ENERGY YOU AND
OPERATING EFFICIENCY. AND- SO
YOU KNOW WE'RE HOPING THAT THE
FUNDS WILL BE USED TO ALSO HELP
OFF SUPPORT ANY FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT COULD BE COMING- THE- AND
THE AFTER STRUCTURE AND JOBS
ACTORS ABOUT. THREE AND A HALF
BILLION FOR DIRECTOR CAPTURES
HOPING THAT FUN OFFICE EACH YEAR
. HELP BRING SOME OF THE FUNDS
TO CALIFORNIA BY- SOME OF THE
BILLION TO PROVIDE COST YEAR.
NOTES THAT. AND THE- AND ALSO TO
PARTNER OTHER PROJECTS THAT ARE
ON ALSO- YEAH WORKING ON THE
RESTORATION PART HIS A FORTY
FIVE TAX CREDIT. AND OTHER-
PROJECT. OKAY SO WHAT WE WOULD
MAYBE SENATE ADJOURNMENT BECAUSE
HE DOES. A PERFECT CRAWFORD JUST
JUMP AT THE HIGH LEVEL THIS MILL
DOLLAR ISRAEL FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE. CAN TO LEE
INNOVATION WHICH IS MAKING THIS
INVESTMENT IN DIRECT AIR CAPTURE
TECHNOLOGY CAPTURES CARBON FROM
THE AIR TURNS IT INTO AN INERT
SUBSTANCE AND WE THINK IN THE
FUTURE AS WE MOVE TOWARDS CARBON
NEUTRALITY WHICH OF COURSE IS
OUR KEY GOAL. IT'S GOING TO BE
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT. THAT
STRATEGIC RELIABILITY RESERVE IS
ALL ABOUT ENSURING THAT WE
MAINTAIN ENERGY RELIABILITY IN
THE SHORT TERM AND THAT WE HAVE
RESOURCE AS THIS COMMISSIONER
POINTED OUT TO- DISPATCH AT
ENERGY AS WE NEED IT AS WE'RE
EXPERIENCING THESE UNPRECEDENTED
HEAT STORMS. BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE
OUR GOAL OUR TARGET OUR
COMMITMENT IS CLEAR WHICH IS NOT
A 100% I CARBON FREE ENERGY AND
ULTIMATELY CARBON- NEUTRALITY. I
IN SO THIS HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WE THINK IS AN IMPORTANT
INVESTMENT RELEASED STAND UP-
AND ACCELERATE THIS DIRECT AIR
CAPTURE TECHNOLOGY AND THEN AS
MISS LOU POINTS OUT MAJOR
FEDERAL FUNDING- THAT WE CAN
ATTRACT INTO CALIFORNIA- WE
THINK THROUGH THIS INVESTMENT.
RIGHT I JUST I'LL I'LL GET TO
THE LITHIUM VALLEY DEVELOPMENT
NEXT BUT BUT THE ONE OF THE ONE
OF THE TENANTS THAT YOU HAVE
THERE IS TO ACCELERATE
DEVELOPMENT OF STREAMLINING THE
PERMITTING- AND WE DON'T HAVE
THAT IN THE CARBON CAPTURE AND-
THEN I GET. IN WE KNOW THAT
DIRECT AIR CAPTURE IS THE
CADILLAC VERSION I GUESS WE SEE
THE LEXUS VERSION NOW AND THAT'S
VERY EXPENSIVE BUT THERE'S ALSO
NATURE BASE DRUM- A CARBON
CAPTURE THERE'S ALSO THE GOOD
OLD FASHIONED YOU KNOW YOU GOT A
FACTORY GOT IN INDUSTRY YOU
CARBON CAPTURE IT YOU. YOU YOU
SINK IT INTO. EXISTING WELL AND
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH SOMEBODY
AT THE AT THE VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS HE'S GOT A NOTE.
THAT IN THE WORST CASE SCENARIO-
IN THE SUMMER WE GOT ALL THESE
PLAN ON EXTENDING THE LIFE OF
THE NATURAL GAS AND THERE'S
GOING TO BE. A COSTS TO THE TO
THE AIR QUALITY AND SO IF WE IF
WE PUT OF A HUNDRED MILLION INTO
DEVELOPMENT OF A DIRECTOR
CAPTURE LET'S JUST SAY WE BUILD
IT WE CAN ALSO KNOW HOW MUCH
CARBON THAT'S GOING TO. PUT DOWN
AND I'M JUST SUGGESTING THAT YOU
MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT MORE MONEY
FOR A VARIETY OF CARBON CAPTURE
IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO KEEP
THESE. POLLUTING FACILITIES OPEN
YOU KNOW FOR A LONGER TIME A
WEEK IT'S- A IN THE SHORT TERM
AND SHORT TERM BECAUSE SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE WANT TO. WANT TO.
DO THAT- WE'LL GET TO THE ADULT.
THEY'LL REMAIN LET'S GO TO. THE
SALTON SEA AND THE LITHIUM-
VALLEY I THINK THE L. A. YO. CAN
YOU HELP ME OUT HERE DO WE HAVE.
SETH KERSTING ON THE ON THE
LINE- I'M TRYING TO FIND FIGURE
OUT THE- HOWEVER THIS IS GOING
TO WORK THIS THE STATE IS GOING
TO DO- EXCISE TAX. OR PLACE FI
RE. ON THE EXTRACTION AND WE'RE-NOT GOING TO ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DO THAT AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE MONEY BACK
TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS I'M
SURE I BOTCHED THAT UP- BUT- I
DON'T SEE. A LOT CAN YOU HELP
HOLD MY HAND AND EXPLAIN IT
MISTER CHRISTIAN- SURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SAID
CHRISTINE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO WOULD BE-
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGES. IS NOT
YET- AVAILABLE FOR THIS STUDY
WERE SURE OF GOING OFF A
COMBINATION OF THE DESCRIPTION
IN THE- BUDGET SAY IN THE
MEMBERS SUMMARY DOCUMENTS AND
ALSO SOME SOME BRIEFINGS THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION- ARE UNDERSTOOD
THIS IS A PROPOSAL THAT HAS A
VARIETY OF- COMPONENTS- ARE I
DIDN'T DEPART YOU'RE DESCRIBING
IS ONE OF THE WHAT WE DO IS SORT
OF THE CENTRAL COMPONENTS THAT
WE HAVE- I STARTED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT. WHICH IS- SENSUALLY AS
WE UNDERSTAND IT TO PROHIBIT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM IMPOSING
TAXES ON LITHIUM. EXTRACTION AND
INSTEAD TO IMPOSE A STATE TAX ON
LITHIUM EXTRACTION- AND THE- DAY
THE RATE FOR PROPOSED RATE HAS
NOT YET BEEN- SPECIFIED- AND SO.
YOU KNOW IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OUR UNDERSTANDING
IS SORT OF THAT THE MAIN
ARGUMENT FOR DOING THIS IS THAT-
IT WOULD HELP THE INDUSTRY
EXPAND IN PART BY PROVIDING
CERTAINTY ABOUT THE TAX POLICIES
THAT WOULD APPLY TO. LITHIUM
EXTRACTION- AND THERE'S SORT OF
A FURTHER ARGUMENT THAT THE
STATE SHOULD ACT NOW DUE TO
POTENTIAL LOCAL ACTIONS LATER
THIS YEAR PERHAPS IMPOSING LOCAL
TAXES. I AND CERTAINLY IN SOME
SITUATIONS ON CERTAIN LOCAL
POLICIES CAN DISCOURAGE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT WHICH COULD JUSTIFY
PREEMPTION BY THE STATE BUT IN
THIS CASE. ARE YOU MINISTRATION
HAS NOT PRESENTED SO FAR ANY
EVIDENCE IN THE THAT POLICY
UNCERTAINTY IS WEAKENING
INVESTMENT IN THIS INDUSTRY.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHY THE STATE
WOULD BE BETTER POSITIONS TO
COMMIT TO FUTURE POLICIES THUS
PROVIDING CERTAINTY- MORE SO THE
LOCAL GUY- IT IF AS THE
ADMINISTRATION SEEMS TO
ANTICIPATE- A LOCAL ACTIONS ARE
CURRENTLY NEAR FUTURE. AT EVERY
EARLY SO AT THE INDUSTRIES
DEVELOP THAT'S IN LIKE IT SHOULD
CREE MORE. NOT LESS AND FINALLY
- THIS TO CAN PREAMP LOCAL TECH
. ONE OF THE SORT OF UNDERLYING
THERE IS THAT THE STATE WOULD
FIRST HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT YOU
PROCREATE TAX RATE WOULD BE MORE
SO THAN LOCALS. BUT BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
DOESN'T INCLUDE TAX RATE- THAT
SEEMS SORT OF LIKE A
QUESTIONABLE PREMISE AT THIS
IME AND THEN A REVISION
TIMELINE DOESN'T PUT THE
LEGISLATURE IN A POSITION TO
COME UP WITH ITS OWN TAX RATES
SO THAT'S JUST OUR COMMENTARY ON
THAT MAIN PIECE. OF BUT THERE
ARE OTHERS AS WELL AND- IT AND
IF YOU'D LIKE TO DISCUSS THIS
ANYBODY WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION OR FINANCE HAS A
COMMENT THAT MANY SPEECH AT.
SOME LIGHT ON THIS. YEAH IS IT A
MINUTE WOULD. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THE LIBYAN TAX BECAUSE
ON UNFORTUNATELY WAS A LITTLE
BIT SLOW BUT WILL BE UP TODAY
AND FOR ALL THE LANGUAGE WILL BE
OUT THIS WEEK WHICH WILL
IDENTIFY THE TAX RATE- BUT-
LARGELY THE STATE'S STEPPING IN
HERE IN ORDER TO ACCELERATE THIS
INDUSTRY- ARE PARTNERING WITH
THE FEDS IS WHILE IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE THAT- THIS STATE CAN
REALLY TAKE ADVANTAGE. OF WHAT
IS NOW BEING CALLED KIND OF
SAUDI ARABIA LITHIA- I HAVE
BECOME TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THIS WEEK ON THE-
TAX RATE. IT'S BEEN PROPOSED.
OKAY I SEE I SEE THAT WHINY
XCELERATED LITHIUM AND NOT
ACCELERATE LATE SEE YOU- BIOMASS
AND WOODY PRODUCTS IN IN OUR
FORCE WE'VE GOT YOU KNOW WHAT TO
STUDIES TO COME OUT THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE AN INVESTMENT INTO THESE
FACILITIES PROVIDE CERTAINTY
THAT WOULD. WHAT PRODUCTS WOULD
COME IN AND YOU KNOW X.
DEVELOPMENT OF BY STREAMLINING
THAT- THAT THE PERMITTING
PROCESS WE GOT TWO HUGE PROJECT
PROBLEMS WE GOT TOO MUCH WOOD
PRODUCTS WE GOT A LOT OF THINGS
YOU WANT TO DO BUT WE GOT TO GET
IT OUT. OF THE- OF THE FORCE WHY
NOT FROM AN ENERGY POSITION WHY
NOT. HAVE SOME SORT OF. PROGRAM
LIKE THAT. IT TAKES CHAIR AS
SECRETARY GRAVERT HERE YEAH I
THINK IT'S ACTUALLY NOT A FOR
ITS AND SO ON LITHIUM VALLEY WE
RECOGNIZE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
ALMOST THIS UNIQUE RESOURCE IN
THE WORLD THAT WE NEED TO MEET
OUR CLEAN ENERGY GOALS THAT CAN
REALLY LIFT UP THE REGION. AND
WE THINK THIS IS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT RIGHT IN A
WAY THAT ACTUALLY NOT BUILD MORE
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN CALIFORNIA
FOR THAT THE BATTERY SECTOR AND
THAT CLEAN ENERGY SECTOR IN A
WAY THAT BENEFITS FOLKS THAT
LIVE IN THE IMPERIAL THE
COACHELLA VALLEY AND OF COURSE I
ALSO BENEFITS SALTON SEA
RESTORATION THAT'S ONE PIECE. I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT WE NEED TO
DO MORE TO STAND UP ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY ACROSS OUR LANDSCAPE IN
OUR FORESTS ACTUALLY GET THE-
VEGETATION OUT OF OUR FORESTS
THAT ARE BEING- ADDRESSED OR OR
THIN THROUGH THIS ECOLOGICALLY
BASED FOREST MANAGEMENT AND
FRANKLY WHILE THE PUBLIC
INVESTMENTS ARE REALLY ROBUST
HUGE THANKS TO YOU ALL- WE NEED
MORE PRIVATE ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
SO WE ARE WORK TO STREAMLINE.
FOR PROJECTS AND WE MADE A
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS WITH A
LARGE PROGRAM WE CALL THE
VEGETATION TREATMENT PROGRAM-
PROGRAMMATIC ER WHICH IS A
MULTIPLE AND I CAN I CAN DETAIL
THAT BUT THE SHORT OF IT IS
WORKING TO GET THESE PROJECTS
DONE MORE QUICKLY AND COST
EFFECTIVELY AND THEN ALSO AGAIN
THANKS TO YOUR INVESTMENTS LAST
YEAR INVEST IN- IN GROWING
SECTORS FOR THESE PRODUCTS. AND
WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE. A TIMBER
INDUSTRY THAT. THAT IS NOT A
GOOD IN CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S
ALSO THE BUT FOR USE OF THE
VEGETATION THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY PART OF THAT
INDUSTRY. I THROUGH THINGS LIKE
CROSS LAMINATED TIMBER SO
THERE'S A LOT OF INVESTMENTS
THROUGH PARTNERS LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK WHICH ARE
HERE TODAY WHO ARE HERE TODAY-
TO ACTUALLY STAND THIS UP SO WE
NEED TO DO BOTH. WE NEED TO.
ACCELERATE OUR SECTORS TO HELP
US MANAGE OUR FORESTS AND
LANDSCAPES AND WE THINK WE NEED
TO ACCELERATE- SMART LITHIUM
DEVELOPMENT. OKAY OKAY I GUESS.
MISTER REAL YOU HAVE SOMETHING
THAT. I DON'T THINK- GOOD
MORNING CHAIRED THE NEXT CAREER
WITH THE ENERGY COMMISSION I
COULD SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE TO
THE ISSUE OF WITH HIM IF IT-
PRISONS- COMMITTEE. YEAH SO I
WOULD I WOULD SHARE THAT AS WE
KNOW- LITHIUM IS BECOMING AS
CREDIBLE INCREASINGLY CRITICAL
RESOURCE FOR THE STATE AND THE
WORLD AS WE MOVE TOWARD CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE TO TACKLE THAT
BECAUSE I'M A ARE GOING TO TRY
TO PRESENT ABOUT WE ESTIMATE
THAT ABOUT A THIRD OF TODAY'S
GLOBAL LITHIUM THAT MAN COULD
POTENTIALLY BE UNDER THE
SOLVENCY THIS IS A CRUCIAL
INDUSTRY THANKS FOR THE STATE TO
SUPPORT MUCH LIKE WE SUPPORTED
EASY- INFRASTRUCTURE AND GROWTH
IN THE STATE. THE BATTERY IN THE
TECHNOLOGY AND THE FACT
ECOSYSTEM AROUND THAT WILL BE-
INCREASINGLY CRITICAL FOR OUR
GROWTH THAT. THE CLEAN ECONOMY.
OKAY I'M LET'S SWITCH TO THE P.
SEE I KNOW YOU HAVE A- READ. A
PROPOSAL IN THE AND- THE MAY
REVISE I DIDN'T SEE ANY TRAILER
LANGUAGE I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
DID. IS TO ADDRESS ELECTRICITY
RATES TO PREDETERMINED FIXED
CHARGES. ISN'T THAT
CONTROVERSIAL I MEAN THIS IN LOW
INCOME PEOPLE HAVE A HAVE A
HARDER TIME PAYING A FIXED RATE
AND A HIGH INCOME PERSON. I
MEAN- IT'LL SEND A PRICE SIGNAL
THAT I CAN I WILL AGREE I'LL
STIPULATE TO THAT. IT DOESN'T
ABUSE HE HAVE DISABILITY NOW. GO
AHEAD. MISTER BAKER. YEAH HELLO
. THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION-
SENATOR- BEST PC HAS AUTHORITY
TO- APPROVED RESIDENTIAL FIXED
CHARGES- THEY A LECTURE BEST
AROUND UTILITY UP TO A CERTAIN
STATUTORY CAP AT THIS POINT. AND
SO WE HAVE SOME AUTHORITY TO DO
THAT. BUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
THAT CUSTOMERS OF THE ELECTRIC
VALUE THIRD RANKING RATE
PRESSURES. DUE TO WILDFIRE
RELATED TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION COSTS AMONG OTHER
FACTORS AND CURRENTLY MOST
ELECTRIC ARE YOU FOR ARE
COLLECTED THROUGH CHARGES. AND
THAT CREATES. AN ECHO ACROSS
RECOVERY- ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
CUSTOMERS THAT CAN'T AFFORD TO
REDUCE THEIR CONSUMPTION-
THROUGH DISTRIBUTING YOUR
RESOURCES ADOPTION AND WHAT HAVE
YOU AND SO HI BIOMETRIC CHARGES
THEY ALSO CREATE A BARRIER TO
ELECTRIFICATION. AND DEATH RATE
REFORM PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW THE
FEW KEY TO REDUCED CHARGES.
ATTACHED TO VOLUMES OF
ELECTRICITY CONSUMED IT WOULD
ALSO ELP TO CONTROL RATE
VOLATILITY. AND ENABLE I HAVE A
BETTER PRICE SIGNALS TO ENHANCE
THE WIDESPREAD ELECTRIFICATION
EFFORT YOU. YOU ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT IT. THIS PROPOSAL
CONTROVERSIAL. YOU SEE HOW THEY
- AND KANBAN. ON A RACE AND A-
THAT PASSED FEBRUARY WHAT ARE
SECOND HEARING ON THAT MATTER
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS AND
WE'VE BEEN REPORTING ON THAT TO
THE LEGISLATURE THROUGH OUR SB
SIX NINETY FIVE REPORT. AND WE
OBSERVE THAT RESIDENTIAL FIXED
CHARGE RATE REFORM WAS. AMONG
THE STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS THAT
APPEAR TO HAVE. BEEN BROAD
SUPPORT- ACROSS A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDER GROUPS.
AND SO WE SEE THAT THAT- I KEEP
STRATEGY FOR OPENING UP
OPPORTUNITIES- FOR. FURTHER
PARTICIPATION BY CUSTOMERS AND
IN- ELECTRIFICATION OPPORTUNITY
AND WE'RE ALSO PROPOSING TO- AND
THAT- STATUTORY CHANGE DIRECT
THE PUBLIC UTILITY COMMISSION TO
INCORPORATE- AT IN AND INCOME
TAX INCOME FACTOR IN AND HOW-
ANY- FIXED CHARGES ARE ARE
STRUCTURED. IT WOULD ALSO BRING
THE- ELECTRIC- I'LL YOU UP MORE
IN LINE WITH WHAT WE'RE SEEING-
ELSEWHERE IN THE INDUSTRY.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRIC
I USE THAT ARE- ONE OF THE FEW
ELECTRIC UTILITY. OFF THE
COUNTRY THAT DON'T HAVE BIG
CHARGES- IT'S VERY COMMON
ANOTHER INDUSTRY AND- FOR
EXAMPLE THAT SACRAMENTO
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT HAS
A- TWENTY DOLLAR PER CHARGE AND
I THINK THAT THE COURT HAS A
SEVEN DOLLAR. CHARGE AND SO-
THAT WAS- THE PURPOSE IS TO-
PROVIDE MORE FLEXIBILITY THAT
THE PUBLIC UTILITY COMMISSION TO
BE ABLE TO CONSIDER THIS ISSUE
RIGHT OKAY ONE MIGHT WE ARE
EXPECTED BUDGET TRAILER BILL TO
EXPLAIN THIS IN. A GREATER
DETAIL OR LANGUAGE FORGET THIS
LANGUAGE YOU HAVE AN IDEA HI
JERRY THIS IS M. IN OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
EXPECTING IT TO BE UP THIS WEEK
EXCELLENT BECAUSE WE DO YOU KNOW
WHICH WE SEE ONE POINT TWO
BILLION TO PLAY ELECTRIC ARREARS
WHICH IS ACCEPTABLE WHEN WE WANT
TO DO THAT BUT THEN WE'RE GOING
TO RAISE THE RATES GOING FORWARD
YOU CAN SEE WHY SOME MEMBERS
MIGHT. BE CONSIDERED CONCERN I
MISS ELLERS AND WHOEVER'S AT
THAT- ALLEY- I GOT A QUESTION ON
THE CAP AND TRADE- YOU HE- I
KNOW THERE'S AN AUCTION
TOMORROW- IT SEEMS LIKE PRICES
ARE GOING UP IN THAT THAT. IN
GAS- IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE THAT
WE DON'T. RECEIVE OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS IN DEBT I'M ON THE
NUMBERS AGAIN THIS IS MY SEVENTH
YEAR IS SEAT CHAIR NOT MY SIX
YEARS THAT YEAR SO EVERY YEAR WE
HAVE THIS DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT
THE ANTICIPATED REVENUE AS AN-
IN. AND MY UNDERSTANDING WERE
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS LESS OR ABOVE WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE- HAS EVEN
THOUGH WE KNOW WE'VE GOTTEN
THREE POINT FOUR BILLION ALREADY
IN FROM THE THREE OCT. OPTIONS
YOU HINTED AT. AT THE- GANN
LIMIT OF LIMITATIONS AND HOW CAP
AND TRADE MAY BE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR SOME OF THESE- PROPOSALS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS-
THAT MAY NOT BE CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS- THEY HAVE TO A
FARM- THE SATELLITE- METHANE
SATELLITE IN THE AND ALSO MORE
MONEY FOR AB SIX ONE SEVEN WHICH
IS AYE IT I'M INTRODUCTION MARKS
INDICATED THAT THAT DOESN'T
REDUCE METHANE AT ALL IT JUST
TELLS US PRECISELY WHERE IT IS
WHICH IS VALUABLE. BUT YOU KNOW
WE MIGHT WANT TO START SPENDING
SOME MONEY ON REDUCING METHANE
SO CAN YOU HELP ME. OR GIVE GIVE
THE LEGISLATURE SOME GUIDANCE ON
HOW WE MIGHT BE LOOKING AT OUR
EXPENDITURE PLAN VIS A VIS SAID
THE SALT LIMITED AND ALSO SOME
OF THESE- PROPOSALS THAT REALLY.
DON'T REDUCE THE THANK A CAR.
SIR MARKET SHARE AND AGAIN
PASSES TO MY COLLEAGUES BROWN.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ROSS
BROWN WITH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE SO I'LL FINISH NOT GOALS
ARE THE FEW PIECES OF THAT
QUESTIONS SO FIRST ON THE- YOU
MENTIONED JUST SORT OF THE
REVENUE ESTIMATES AND MY CALLING
IS EHLERS MENTION THIS IN HER
COMMENTS WE DO- THAT MAY REGION
DOES INCLUDE SOME ADDITIONAL
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING TO ACCOUNT
FOR. THE MOST RECENT AUCTION-
INCREASES KIND OF THEIR JANUARY
PROPOSAL FROM ABOUT ONE BILLION
TO ABOUT ONE POINT ONE BILLION.
BASED ON OUR REVENUE ESTIMATES
WE DO THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD- COMFORTABLY ALLOCATE A
ROUGHLY FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
MORE THAN THAT IT'S GOING TO
CURRENT PRICES CONTINUE OVER THE
NEXT YEAR SO THAT'S- WANT TO ADD
A COMMENT ON THE BIGGER PICTURE
DDR- FUND INDIGENOUS YOU- ON
THE- MY COLLEAGUE IS A LARGE
ALSO MENTIONS- JUST SOME
CONSIDERATION THAT YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT STRUCTURING YOUR
OVERALL. I GENERAL FUND AND G.
G. R. F. BUDGET- YEAH WE-
MENTIONED THE CLASS MISTAKE
STYLE REQUIREMENTS AND THAT THE
STATE DOES HAVE SOME.
POTENTIALLY WORKS DOING KIND OF
MEETING SOME OF THOSE DAHLE
REQUIREMENTS AND THERE'S THE
POTENTIAL TO FOR ONE OPTION FOR
ADDRESSING THOSE IS SOME
POTENTIAL SHOPS AND KIND OF
WHICH FUNDING SOURCES BETWEEN
GENERAL EUROPE FOR USED TO FIND
SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES AND OF
COURSE WE'RE HAPPY TO- TO HELP
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROFITABLE. FOR YOU AND YOUR
STAFF ARE ON THE FINAL ISSUE
AROUND THE JUST WHAT'S ACTUALLY
BEING PROPOSED AS PART OF THIS
YEAR'S MAYOR VISION GIGI R. F.
PACKAGE THE- BIG INCREASE AS YOU
REFERENCED- WAS A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR METHANE
MONITORING SATELLITES- AND YES
THOSE ARE REALLY TARGETED AT AT
MONITORING I THINK. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INDICATED MAYBE
IF YOU KNOW THE IT WITH
ADDITIONAL MONITORING THERE
COULD BE OPPORTUNITIES TO-
IDENTIFY WHERE THAT WHERE
NOTHING IS- IS BEING ADMITTED
AND PERHAPS TAKE ACTIONS- WE DO
THINK. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT YOU
YOU SORT OF HAD ON I THINK ONE
OF THE CONNECT HE CONSIDERATIONS
HERE IS REALLY IS THIS A HIGH
PRIORITY. FOR WHERE TO SPEND-
LIMITING THAT THE STATE LIMITED
RESOURCES THERE SO IT'S A
HUNDRED DOLLAR PROPOSED. FOR
MONITOR AND THEIR- BUT I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE ANY OTHER WAY IN
WHICH STATE CAN. ABOUT MONEY
ANDREAS CLIMATE REALLY ACTED.
AND THROUGH YEAH- WELL THAT
AMOUNT MONEY IS KIND OF REALLY
THE BEST USE OF A BREEZE. I WANT
TO SORT OF FLAG. ONE OTHER
QUESTION AGAIN WORK THESE ARE
ALL PROPOSALS THAT WERE KIND OF
CONTINUING TO LOOK INTO JUST ONE
OTHER ISSUE ON THE METHANE
MONITORING PROPOSAL- WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO GET SOME OF THE
DETAILS ON EXACTLY HOW THAT.
MONEY WOULD BE SPENT SAID OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT SOME OF
THAT WOULD BE SPENT TO- HELP
KIND OF WATCH SOME OF THE-
SATELLITE- BUT THERE ALSO MIGHT
BE SOME KIND OF ONGOING. COSTS
FOR DATA COLLECTION THAT THOSE
COSTS- DON'T APPEAR TO BE THERE
ARE ANY KIND OF ONGOING SPENDING
PROPOSALS AS PART OF THIS THAT'S
ANOTHER. I FISCAL CONSIDERATION
IF YOU THINK ABOUT. YOU KNOW
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED HERE AND
WHETHER OR NOT IT MIGHT CREATE
SORT OF MORE ONGOING COST SO
THAT'S SOMETHING WILL CONTINUE
TO ADD TO EXPLORE LOOK INTO AND
PROVIDE COMMENTS TO YOU AND WHAT
IS THE GO. YEAH I GUESS I MEAN
WE KNOW SOURCE OF METHANE OUR
GARY FARMS OR LIFE. WE'VE GOT
INFORMATION NOW THAT IN HAWAII
THEY HAVE SOME SEAWEED
PRODUCTION THAT WE CAN FEED TO
THAT THE- ANIMALS AND REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF BELCHING AND BLAH BLAH
BLAH WE'VE GOT. AMPLE WE'VE GOT.
THAT GESTURES WE KNOW IF WE PUT
IN SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
JURY DIGESTED TO SUBSIDIZE IT WE
GET ONE. POINT TWO MILLION
METRIC TONS OF CARBON REDUCTION
. RIGHT SO. SO AND WE KNOW WHERE
OF THE DERRY'S NOT HIDING I MEAN
I GUESS THERE COULD BE SOME
CALLOUS SOMEWHERE WE KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE OUR LANDFILLS ARE. YOU
KNOW WE MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO GET
ON THE BACKSIDE OF LANDFILL WE
KNOW ON THE FRONT SIDE WHAT HOW
MUCH METHANE SUBMITTING WE KNOW
FROM OUR- SEWAGE TREATMENT
PLANTS WERE THE METHODS IT'S-
LIKE THERE'S- SOME SURPRISES
THERE SOME. UNKNOWN SOURCE OF
METHANE OUT THERE I MEAN. THAT
I'M GOING TO WE'LL GET IT FOR A
HUNDRED MILLION WE'RE GONNA
KNOW. OF FINANCE OR MISS. HE
ELAINE- HI MELISSA THIS ON THE
RESEARCH CHIEF CAR- AND I WANT
TO GO TO ABOUT OF THESE OFFICER
THAT THEY LEAVE TO RUN TO MAKE
SO WE WORK WITH BROAD RULE AND
THAT ARE IN PLACE SO YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO TEN EXACTLY- WHERE
ANIMATION IS COMING FROM FOR
EXAMPLE A LEAK FROM THE TANK-
AND YOU'LL BE ABLE TO DO THAT
WITH THESE ADDITIONAL EIGHT
SATELLITES MUCH MORE QUICKLY SO
IT ALLOWS US TO LOOK AT OVER 80%
OF NOTHING AT THE MEETING
INFRASTRUCTURE EVERY TWO WEEKS.
AND THEN WITH THAT WE CAN WORK
WITH OUR REGULATORY PROGRAMS
MORE EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT AND
ENFORCE THOSE REGULATIONS- AND
GET REDUCTIONS NOW AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR METHANE ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE A SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANT AND ANY REDUCTION WE
HAVE NOW WILL HAVE A SOONER FAT-
TO UP WITH NUMBER SEVEN THERE
HOW DOES THAT WORK THROUGH A I
GOT A THE PAETUS CALIFORNIA I'VE
A LANDFILL IT'S EMITTING METHANE
RIGHT NOW THE SATELLITE GOES UP
IT'S SO WRONG IT'S NOT TEN IT'S
TWENTY FIVE HOW DO YOU CHANGE
THAT HOW DO YOU GO OUT TO THE
LANDFILL AND IMMEDIATELY YOU
KNOW WITH THE WITH THE LOCAL
AIRPORT HAVE YES STOP THAT. SO
THERE'S VERY DIFFERENTLY THAT
THE ON WHAT YOU'RE SOURCE IS-
IT'S FOR THE OF WELL I DON'T.
THEN IF YOU SEE THAT A INSPECTOR
SOMEBODY EVELYN CAN GO OUT FIND
WHERE IT IS AND SOMETIMES IT'S
AS SIMPLE AS CLOSING OF DAHLE-
THERE'S BEEN INSTANCES WHERE A
TANK HATCHES OPEN AND IT'S
CLOSING OUT OF TEN CATS. YOU MAY
NOT FIND NOT FOR A WHILE BUT IF
YOU HAVE THESE OVERFLIGHTS
HAPPENING WITH THE SATELLITES
HAPPENING YOU'LL FIND OUT RIGHT
AWAY- SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU CAN FIX QUICKLY.
THAT ARE SORT OF POINTS OR
SOMETHING. BUT I GET MY UNDER.
AND I'M NOT I'M NOT PROMOTING
TERRY DIGEST BUT- AT THAT. IF WE
TOOK A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND AGAIN THIS IS A QUESTION DO
WE DO THAT IN CAP AND TRADE OR
DO WE DO IT IN GENERAL FUND
BECAUSE OF THIS. S. A. L. YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT IS BUT IF WE
INVESTED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. IN SIX THIRTY DIE
CHESTER'S. WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GET SEVEN MILLION
METRIC TONS OF CARP OF METHANE
REMOVED FROM THE ATMOSPHERE. YOU
KNOW THAT NOW IT'S- WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S THERE AND
IT'LL TAKE A TWELVE MONTHS OR
EIGHTEEN MONTHS THE TO DO THIS.
WHY WOULD YOU NOT COUPLE THE
PROPOSAL OF MONITORING AND GET
AND YOU GET MORE MONEY THIS AB
SIX ONE SEVEN SO WE GET MORE
DEVICES OUT THERE SERENO'S AND
THEN JUST DO IT. I MEAN PRETEND
WHAT WILL WORK FOR NIKE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LET'S JUST DO IT
FINANCE WHY WOULD YOU NOT DO
THAT CARP. WHAT AT WHAT IS SET
NOT IN HERE. SO IF YOU DON'T
MIND MISTER JERICHO'S CHRISTIAN
CULTURE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'LL JUST KIND OF-
TALKED THE POINT ABOUT WHY
SPECIFICALLY THE ADMINISTRATION.
WAS- ARE PROPOSING TO UTILIZE
YOUR FUNDS AS OPPOSED TO GENERAL
FUND- SO SPECIFIC THE
UTILIZATION GDR F. AND REASON
WHY WE ARE PROPOSED TO UTILIZE
THOSE FUNDS SPECIFICALLY IS-
MAINLY A LINE. THROUGH THE THAT
THE PURPOSE OF EUROPE AND
REDUCING OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS YOU KNOW METHANE IS
THAT CONSIDERED ONE OF THE MOST
- SHORT LIVED AT POLLUTANT GASES
OUT THERE. AND GIVEN THAT THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL WOULD
DIRECTLY- ACTUALLY REDUCE OR
HELP- IT SPECIFICALLY- I TRY TO
ADDRESS THE WEEKS THAT HARBORS
LIVING TO. THE ADMINISTRATION
FELT THAT THE- POTENTIAL-
INVESTMENTS FROM TO EUROPE
HIDING GOOD AND NEXUS. THAT'S
THE MAIN REASON WHY WE
PRIORITIZE UTILIZING THE DRAFT
VERSUS. GENERAL FUND. NO I MEAN
I MEAN IT'S CERTAINLY THE FIRST.
IN WE WON'T KNOW IT'S- WILL THAT
DE. AGAIN WOULD YOU A LOT OF
INVESTMENT. AB SIX ONE SEVEN HAS
A LOT OF INVESTMENT ON COLLECTED
DATA GETTING PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
WORD LEAKS IS BUT WE'RE NOT.
WE'RE NOT GETTING TO THE
ULTIMATE PROBLEM OF HOW DO YOU
REDUCE THOSE. HAD A HAVE YOU
REDUCE THOSE EMISSIONS OR WARD
BUDGET ALL RIGHT RIGHT I'M- I'LL
GO BACK TO CENTER CRAWFORD MY
LAST QUESTION- YOU KNOW WORDS I
GUESS THIS OFFICIALLY STARTS
NEGOTIATIONS WE HAVE. THE YOU'VE
- WE'VE WE'VE SEEN THE YOUR-
OUTDOOR ACCESS AND- THIRTY BY
THIRTY PROPOSAL WITH THE DETAILS
IN THE MAY REVISE OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT- THAT WHICH
WAS AGREED TO LAST YEAR THE
SENATE PROPOSAL HAS- CHALLENGE
THE ADMINISTRATION WITH THE
BILLION DOLLARS MORE SPENT OVER
A FEW YEARS- IN WE BELIEVE THAT
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE THINGS
IT YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT.
INCREASING EQUITY ACCESS GRANT
PROGRAMS HAPPENING- OUTDOOR
ACCESS FOR THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION URBAN GREENING AND-
URBAN FOREST AND ME THIS GOAL OF
BY THIRTY THIS AT THIS
ADDITIONAL. BILLION DOLLARS FOR
BIODIVERSITY HELPS YOU ACHIEVE
YOUR GOAL DID TO DISTURB WITH
THAT. WELL LET ME FIRST. HUGE
THANKS TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR LAST YEAR FOR
AGREEING TO THREE QUARTERS OF A
BILLION DOLLARS FOR NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS. AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING MAY BE SCRATCHING THEIR
HEADS WHEN WE SAY THAT TERM
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS THIS IS
ALL ABOUT HELPING NATURE HELP US
IN OTHER WORDS IMPROVING OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSERVATION- BOTH
TO REMOVE CARBON AND STORE
CARBON FROM THE ATMOSPHERE OFFER
CLIMATE IMPACTS PROTECT THIS
REMARKABLE BIODIVERSITY WE HAVE
IN TO PROVIDE MORE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE SO EXCITED TO BE ADVANCING
THIRTY BY THIRTY WHICH IS REALLY
I HAVE AN IDEA SEATED IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSERVE 30% OF
OUR LANDS AND COASTAL WATERS BY
TWENTY THIRTY. NOW THIS THREE
QUARTERS OF A BILLION DOLLARS IS
CERTAINLY JUST A DOWN PAYMENT TO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO ACHIEVE
THIRTY BY THIRTY AND ARE IMPROVE
MANAGEMENT OF OUR LANDS FOR THIS
CLIMATE ACTION SO I WOULD SAY IN
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE THE WHITE HOUSE SKI-
RESOURCES INTO ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSERVATION INTO THIRTY BY
THIRTY IN COMING YEARS. HOWEVER
MUCH THEY ARE WILL INDEED.
BENEFIT THESE GOALS. WE HOPE DID
MISS ADMINISTRATION WILL SHARPEN
THEIR PENCILS AND LOOK AT THE
SENATE PROPOSAL ON THE
BIODIVERSITY BECAUSE WE- WE
BELIEVE WE'VE WE'VE BUILT ON
THAT SPIRIT THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT WAX. LAST YEAR ALL RIGHT
I'VE- I'M GONNA STOP ASKING
QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISE AT THIS TIME I WILL
OPEN. THE THE HEARING UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT EVERYBODY AT THE
MINISTRATION ALLEY- ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SO THOSE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MANY REVISIONS ON
RESOURCES PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WHERE'S YOURS. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BURST.
ARTEMI RECALL MASTRODONATO THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND I'M HERE
TO STRONGLY URGE YOU TO CONSIDER
RESTORING FUNDING TO THE STATE
WIDE LOCAL PARKS AND COMMUNITY
REVITALIZATION PROGRAM THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT BY AB THIRTY ONE IS
CURRENTLY OUT OF MONEY. YOU JUST
COMMENTED SENATOR WACHOWSKI
ABOUT EQUITY IN ACCESS THE FIRST
PLACE WE NEED TO START TO GET TO
ACHIEVE THAT IS WHERE PEOPLE
LIVE TO MAKE IT WITHIN WALKING
DISTANCE AND PARKS ARE NOT AN
AMENITY PARKS ARE A CORE
COMPONENT TO A HEALTHY
COMMUNITY. AND THEY PROBABLY
HAVE AS MANY QUALITY CO BENEFITS
AS ANY GRANTING PROGRAM IN THE
STATE A LOCAL PARKS ADDRESS NOT
ONLY EQUITABLE ACCESS BUT
EXTREME HEAT THEY MITIGATE
FLOODING THE IMPROVE AIR AND
WATER QUALITY- THEY OBVIOUSLY
PERCENT RECREATIONAL BENEFITS TO
THE COMMUNITY. SO THERE'S A LOT
OF BANG FOR THE BUCK HERE AND I
SHARE SENATOR MCGUIRE'S
FRUSTRATION ABOUT THIS NOT BEING
FUNDED AND I CAN'T FIGURE OUT
WHY AND TO THE NOTION THAT
CALIFORNIA MAY BE HALFWAY THERE
ARE GETTING CLOSE TO BEING.
PARK- YOU KNOW HAVING ENOUGH
PARKS ARE- UP TO THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND'S ANNUAL PARK SCORE
CAME OUT A LITTLE WHILE AGO
SEVEN CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE IN
THE BOTTOM 25% OF THE LARGEST
CITIES IN THE US WHEN IT COMES
TO PARK ACCESS- AND- A LIST OF.
UP SEVEN DIFFERENT SENATORS AND
SEVEN DIFFERENT DISTRICTS THE A
REPRESENT THOSE CITIES. AND WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. IF YOU'RE PARK POOR
YOU ARE VULNERABLE BECAUSE THERE
IS A 1100% CORRELATION BETWEEN
LOW INCOME. AND PARK POOR AND
LOW INCOME MEANS HIGHER OBESITY
RATES MORE UNDERLYING CONDITIONS
AND MORE- THREAT TO THE
COMMUNITY. SO I URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER RESTORING THIS ARE
GONNA. WE'RE HAVING A RALLY AT
THREE O'CLOCK OUTSIDE THE
CAPITAL SO PLEASE JOIN US NEXT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CENTER STERN AT
MANNING ON BEHALF OF CATALINA
CHANNEL EXPRESS- WE KELLY
CHANNEL EXPRESSES THE COMPANY
THAT OPERATES THE FERRY SERVICE-
EVERYDAY HOURS DAY THREE AND
SIXTY FIVE DAYS A YEAR TO
CATALINA ISLAND SO IT'S LIFE
FLIGHT SO YOU WHY AM I HERE-
CARB ADOPTED A RULE THIS YEAR ON
HARBOR CRAFT AND BASICALLY
REQUIRED- OVERHAULING OF THE
FLEET FOR A VARIETY OF HARBOR
CRAFT VESSELS INCLUDING FERRIES-
WE WORK CONSTRUCTIVELY WITH
CARBONTHAT BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT- IN ORDER TO GET THE
EMISSIONS REDUCTION IN THE
GREENHOUSE GAS BENEFITS. WE WERE
GOING TO HAVE TO REPLACE ALL OF
OUR FERRIES THEY COST TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS A VESSEL TO
REPLACE WE HAVE- TO THE PURITY
YEARS TO DO IT BUT SOME OF THE
BEST REPLACEMENTS HAVE TO START
IMMEDIATELY. SO OUR. SIX NEW
VESSELS OVERTIME. THE THE
PROBLEM WE HAVE IS THAT THE
EXISTING FUNDING PROGRAMS FOR A
MORE FOR EXAMPLE. IT'S ONLY A
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION A YEAR
AND ITS OVER SUBSCRIBED IN SOUTH
BECAUSE THERE'S NO MONEY
AVAILABLE IN THIS FUNDING CYCLE
. SO WHAT REDUCE ASKING IS FOR
TWO THINGS ONE IS- WE HAVE A
MEMBER REQUESTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE BUT WE'RE TRYING TO SEE IF
WE CAN FIND A PART OF FUNDING.
THAT COULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
FERRIES WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR A
100% BUT SOME MATCHING THAT
BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE. THERE ARE
FAIRIES WHO ARE OPERATED BY
PUBLIC ENTITIES- WHO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO FUND SOMETHING LIKE
THIS. CATALINA CHANNEL EXPRESS
IS A PRIVATE COMPANY. THEY CAN'T
GET FINANCING FOR TWENTY MILLION
YOU CAN UP THE FAIREST POSSIBLY
HIGH ENOUGH THE RECOVERY. AND SO
WITHOUT STATE FUNDING IT'S NOT
FINANCE RIPPLE ON AND SO- WE
WERE LOOKING FOR A GRANT
PROGRAM- ONE IDEA- AND I THINK
FINANCES LOOKING AT THIS IS.
THERE TO SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR- SPENDING- PROPOSAL IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR OFF
ROAD VEHICLES TRUCKS AND OTHERS-
AND- THAT WOULD BE ONE PLACE
THAT WE COULD TRY TO INCLUDE-
YOU SEE REGULATED COMMON CARRIER
FERRIES FOR- FUNDING. AND THE
OTHER WOULD BE JUST TO HAVE A
COMPETITIVE POT FOR- THE PC
REGULATED FERRIES THAT ARE
PRIVATE ENTITIES. SO THEY CAN
COMPETE FOR THE FUNDING. SO
APPRECIATE NOW YOU HAVE A LOT ON
YOUR PLATE AND A GAZILLION
DOLLARS OF ASSETS BUT- THIS ONE
MAKES A DIFFERENCE BECAUSE IT'S
THE ONLY WAY TO GET TO AND FROM
CATALINA ISLAND THANKS. THANK
YOU NECKS. HELLO GOOD MORNING
CHAU CASKEY AND MEMBERS STEVEN
MYERS ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- THE CORES ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FIFTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE MAY
REVISED. TO THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS FOR EXPANDING
EDUCATION AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AT LOCAL AND
TRIBAL CORES FOR CLIMATE
LEADERSHIP. OF THIS FUNDING WILL
EMPOWER YOUNG ADULTS FROM SOME
OF THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE TO
ENGAGE IN PROJECTS THAT WILL
CREATE MORE CLIMATE RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES AND TRAIN THEM. TO
BE THE STATE'S NEXT GENERATION
OF- CLIMATE LEADERS. WE'RE ALSO
ENCOURAGED BY THE ADDITIONAL
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE MAY REVISED TO THE TO EXPAND
FUNDING FOR THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. IN LIGHT
OF THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE
WOULD ASK THE SENATE TO CONSIDER
SENATOR GONZALEZ'S REQUEST TO
ALLOCATE. TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
OF WHAT IS NOW ONE BILLION
DOLLAR PART OF FUNDING TO THE
CCC AND THE LOCAL COURSE TO
ALLOW OUR CORPS MEMBERS TO
CONTINUE ENGAGING IN PROJECTS.
TO MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES MORE
WALKABLE AND BIKEABLE AND WILL
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY AND M. AND-
REDUCE VEHICLE EMISSIONS BY
REDUCING VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
LOUIS BROWN HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA COTTON GROWERS IN
JENNER'S ASSOCIATION A WESTERN
AGRICULTURAL PROCESSORS SERVICES
ASSOCIATION. OPPOSED TO THE
EIGHTY PERMANENT STAFF POSITIONS
AT THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD THAT ARE UNFUNDED-
THOSE EIGHTY POSITIONS ARE
PERMANENT. AND THOSE EIGHTY
POSITIONS WILL COME BACK TO US
AND OUR MEMBERS AS FEE PAYERS
THE WATER BOARD. TO COMPENSATE
FOR THOSE IN YEARS TO COME WE'VE
HAD ON GOING ON CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD ABOUT. THE
INCREASES IN FEES THAT WE SEE ON
A REGULAR BASIS AND I'VE GOT NO
WHERE ON THAT. THESE FEES COME
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS WE HAVE
FAMILY OWNED NOT PROCESSING
FACILITIES COTTON GINS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT PAY
MORE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS. IN FEES
TO THE STATE WATER BOARD INTO
ALL OTHER STATE AGENCIES
COMBINED. SO WE GET REALLY
CONCERNED WE SEE ONE TIME
FUNDING ALLOCATIONS. COMBINED
WITH PERMANENT STAFF BECAUSE WE
KNOW THOSE PERMANENT STAFF GOING
TO COME BACK AND WE WILL BE
EXPECTED TO PAY FOR THEM. VIA
FEES THANK YOU. THANK YOU MAX.
JR MEMBERS THANK YOU I'M TOM
KNOX VALLEY CLEAN AIR NOW WE
MANAGED TO CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAM IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY ON BEHALF OF THE VALLEY
ARE DISTRICT. WE APPRECIATE THE
PRIORITY THE ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE AND PUT ON CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL IN THIS BUDGET.
HOWEVER WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE PROPOSED FUNDING SPLIT
BETWEEN HE FIVE DISTRICTS THAT
CURRENTLY OFFER CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL. AND A PROPOSED NEW
STATEWIDE PROGRAM. IF THE
PRIORITY HERE IS TO EXPEDITE
MORE FUNDING FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE PURCHASES IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT MOST NEED TO
HELP. THE EXISTING PROGRAMS THE
FIVE YEAR DISTRICTS SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THIS. THESE ARE
APPROVAL PROGRAMS THAT ARE
OVERSUBSCRIBED MOST OF THE TIME
AND HAVE A LOT MORE CAPACITY TO
SERVE MANY MORE CUSTOMERS. FOR
EXAMPLE OUR OUR CURRENT CUSTOMER
APPLICATION RATE. WITH SUPPORT
ANNUAL I SPENT A FIFTY TO SIXTY
MILLION IN SILICON VALLEY ALONE.
IF THE CURRENT FUNDING PROPOSAL
MAY REVISE IS ENACTED THE TEN
MILLION ALLOCATED TO SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WOULD NOT BE ASSIST. NOT
BE SUFFICIENT TO FUND EVEN THE
CUSTOMERS WHO CURRENTLY HAVE
APPLICATIONS PENDING. ONCE WE
SERVE THOSE PENDING CUSTOMERS
WOULD BE FORCED TO SHUT DOWN OUR
PROGRAM. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THIS COMMITTEE CONSIDER FLIPPING
THE PROPOSED AMOUNTS FOR THE
EXISTING TO SERVE PROGRAMS AND
THE PROPOSED STATEWIDE PROGRAM.
IT IF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
IS ALLOCATED EXISTING PROGRAMS
ALLOW FOR CONTINUED PROGRESS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN THE
DISTRICTS REPRESENT AN ESTIMATED
75% OF STATEWIDE POPULATION.
CONTAIN MORE THAN 90% OF THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- TO
CLOSE BY BY THANKING SENATOR
STERN- HE RECOGNIZED VERY EARLY
ON THAT THIS- PROGRAM NEEDS TO
BE RUN AS A REGIONAL PROGRAM. AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL- BY THE YEAR
DISTRICTS OF THANK YOU CENTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ZACKS. THANK
YOU MELISSA CORTEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION WANT TO OFFER OUR
SUPPORT. FOR THE PROPOSAL TO
CREATE A CDC C. E. C. CITING
OPTION FOR RENEWABLE PROJECTS
AND LARGE STORAGE PROJECTS. ON
THIS IS NOT A NEW CONCEPT THE
STATE ORIGINALLY DID THIS DURING
THE ENERGY CRISIS FOR THERMAL
PLANTS WHEN WE COULDN'T GET
THINGS CITED. ON TODAY WE HAVE A
CLIMATE CRISIS AND WE BELIEVE
THIS OPTION IS NECESSARY TO GET
NEW PROJECTS ONLINE TO SUPPORT
OUR RELIABILITY NEEDS. THE CDC
CITING PROCESS IS VERY THOROUGH
AND RIGOROUS IT ALSO TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION LOCAL CONCERNS SO
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NECKS.
MISTER CHAIR SENATOR STERN
BETHEL ALSO ON BEHALF OF VARIOUS
CLIENTS- STARTING WITH WATER
REUSE CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN FOR HIGHLIGHTING
THE TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF NEED FOR WATER RECYCLING-
CAN'T THROW ENOUGH MONEY AT IT
CREATES NEW WATER SO. WE SUPPORT
THE SENATE'S AGGRESSIVE PLAN FOR
FUNDING MORE WATER RECYCLING.
SECOND FOR INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY THERE THE
PROPONENT OF THE CHINO BASIN
PROGRAM ONE OF THE WITH UP A
PROP ONE. STORAGE PROJECTS
SUPPORT THAT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW YOU DO IT TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX APPROPRIATION.
BUT WE'LL GET INTO THOSE DETAILS
LATER. AND THEN FINALLY FOR THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION I'M ON THE UC'S
FIXED CHARGE PROPOSAL- LIKE YOU
WE HAVE LOTS OF QUESTIONS ON
THAT ARE YOU REDUCING THE WHOLE
REVENUE REQUIREMENT OR DOES THE
RICH EACH I OWE YOU REVENUE
REQUIREMENT STAY THE SAME AND
YOU'RE JUST SHIFTING. YOU KNOW
THAT REVENUE REQUIREMENT FROM
ONE CLASS TO THE OTHER- THAT
SEEMS A LITTLE PROBLEMATIC YOU
KNOW DON'T WANT TO GO FROM
RESIDENTIAL TO AG- SO AS THOSE
<c.blue>ETAILS COME OUT WE JUST URGE</c>
YOU TO ASK THOSE QUESTIONS AND
WILL BE BACK IN AND SEE WHAT. IT
WOULD AFFECT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR SENATOR STERN
ERICA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
NRDC ACTION FUND. I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR FOUR
ITEMS IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET THIRTY THREE MILLION FOR
THE FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM.
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION FOR THE
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM A HUNDRED
AND TEN MILLION FOR THE STATE
WATER EFFICIENCY ENHANCEMENT
PROGRAM. AND FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
POLLINATOR HABITAT PROGRAM. WE
ALSO REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR
FIFTEEN MILLION FIFTEEN MILLION
TO COVER THREE YEARS OF FUNDING
FOR NEW- ORGANIC TRANSITION
PROGRAM AND A HUNDRED MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR TWO YEARS TO EXPAND
OUR STATE'S CLIMATE FRIENDLY
HEALTHY. FOOD ACCESS
INFRASTRUCTURE. BOTH ARE MEMBER
SUPPORTED ASKS. AND ADDITIONALLY
WOULD JUST LIKE TO- ALSO SUPPORT
COMMENTS FROM PARTNERS IN THE
THIRTY THIRTY BY THIRTY
COALITION THAT YOU'LL BE HEARING
TODAY THANK YOU. THANKS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATOR
STERN VANESSA KICKING ON BEHALF
MOSQUITO AND VECTOR CONTROL
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME AND
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOINGS IN ADVOCACY REQUEST SO
THAT MOSQUITO ABATEMENT
DISTRICTS CAN DO BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES ON STATE MANAGED
WETLANDS BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE THESE ARE
METHODS THAT HELP US MOVE AWAY
FROM IDEALLY USING CHEMICAL USE
ON STATE MANAGED WETLANDS HELP
US CONTROL FOR MISKITO
POPULATIONS WHAT THE RURAL AREAS
OF THE STATE THAT HAVE THESE
MOSQUITO POPULATIONS ON THE
MANAGE WETLANDS HAVE MUCH HIGHER
TRANSMISSION RATES OF WEST NILE
VIRUS THAN OTHER AREAS OF THE
STATE. SO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THE SUB COMMITTEE AT THIS TO THE
BUDGET AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU NEXT. MISTER
CHAIR SENATOR STERN DILUTION
HERE- ON BEHALF OF THE FORTY
ACRE CONSERVATION LEAGUE. ONE OF
THE STATE'S ONLY BLACK LED LAND
CONSERVANCY'S ONE EXPRESS.
AWESOME SUPPORT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THEIR
ALLOCATIONS- TO SPECIFICALLY TO
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD.
ALTHOUGH I WILL SAY OVERALL MR
CHEER THAT WE REALLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SENATE'S FRAMEWORK
THAT YOU ALL LAID OUT- IN TERMS
OF THOSE INCREASED INVESTMENTS I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT TWO ADDITIONAL
POINTS. CONCERNING THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD WERE A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THEIR
PROPOSAL- DOES NOT INCLUDE MORE
IN THE WAY OF FUNDING. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS PROGRAMS WHICH WE
SEE IS. CRITICALLY IMPORTANT I
THINK WE WOULD ASK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TO CONSIDER- IF NECESSARY
STATUTORY LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
ENABLE THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD. TO UTILIZE OTHER FUNDING
POTS THAT ARE GENERAL FUND
FUNDED FOR PUBLIC ACCESS SO
THERE IT'S A LITTLE
INTERCHANGEABLE IN THAT SENSE.
AND THEN THE SECOND THING THAT I
THINK WE WOULD ASK YOU AND WE
WANT TO START TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS. ARM WE APPRECIATE
WE SUPPORT WE RESPECT THE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS SET
ASIDE. FOR TRIBES IN THE WAY OF
THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE ROLLED
OUT- BUT WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU
ALL LOOK AT IT NOT A STRICTLY AS
A SITE FOR TRIBES BUT- A BY
PARKS SAID ASIDE BROADLY OR AT
LEAST CARVING SOME MONEY OUT
WHERE. THERE'S A CERTAIN AMOUNT
GUARANTEED TO TRIBES BUT THERE'S
ALSO A CERTAIN AMOUNT IN THE-
RESERVE FOR BLACK INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE OF COLOR SETRA. ARM WE
HAVE I HAVE BEEN PRETTY
SUCCESSFUL IN. WORKING WITH
VARIOUS PARTS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION OTHER PROGRAMS
PRIMARILY RELATED TO HOUSING IN
ARTFULLY CRAFTING- BY POT SET
ASIDE LANGUAGE WITHOUT VIOLATING
ANY- LET'S JUST SAY U. S. OR
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTIONAL ALL
RESTRICTIONS AND SO WOULD LOVE
TO TALK TO YOU A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU NEXT. THANK YOU CHAIR SOONER
STERN KEITH ON BEHALF OF SITES
RESERVOIR WANTED TO- WHAT THE
GOVERNOR THE MINISTRATION AND
THANK THEM FOR THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
COMMITMENTS TO THE WATER STORAGE
PROGRAMS- LIKE THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER WERE CURIOUS ABOUT THE
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX
APPROPRIATION. I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT WE'RE IN A DROUGHT NOW AND
I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT MOVING THAT
APPROPRIATION TO THIS YEAR THIS
IS THE STATE'S INVESTMENT IN THE
PUBLIC- BENEFIT OF ALL THESE
PROGRAMS IS FOR ALL THE PROP ONE
STORAGE PROGRAMS ON HERE FOR
SITES WITH THIS BENEFITS ALL THE
PROP ONE ALL SEVEN PROJECTS.
AGAIN WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE HARD WORK OF THE SECRETARY
AND ALL THE AGENCIES AND MOVING
ALL THESE PROJECTS FORWARD WE
SEE THEIR DEDICATION AND WHAT I
WOULD SUGGEST IS THAT IN THIS
TIME OF GREAT INFLATION AND X.
EXCESS COSTS THE LONGER THAT WE
WAIT THE MORE THAT MONEY IS
GOING TO BE. WORTH LESS SO I
WOULD GREATLY ENCOURAGE US TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR I HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD CONSIDER
MOVING IT FROM A TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX TWO PERHAPS THIS YEAR
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET I THINK THAT
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES FROM
EVERYTHING THAT I'VE SEEN- IN
PRINT IT'S AN INVESTMENT IN THE
PUBLIC. ITS INVESTMENT IN WATER
IN THE LONGER THAT WE WAIT THE
LESS THAT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS GOING TO BE WORTH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- SO MY NAME IS ANNA LENA
I'M WITH THE TRUST OF PUBLIC
LAND- WITH THE LOS ANGELES RAMS
TO BE EXACT GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU- AND- PROVIDE SOME
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF GREEN SCHOOLYARDS. AND MAKING
THE CASE FOR AN INCREASE FOR
FROM FIFTY MILLION TO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION. AS PROPOSED
CURRENTLY. THE PATENT DEMOCRATS
YOU KNOW EXACERBATING ISSUES
SUFFERED BY THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
OPEN SPACE AND PARK ACCESS IS
ONE OF THEM. ACROSS CALIFORNIA
WE WILL FIND MANY COMMUNITIES
WITH NO PARKS WITHIN A TEN
MINUTE WALK. BUT THOSE SAME
COMMUNITIES OFTEN HAVE A SCHOOL.
AND THOSE SAME SCHOOLS HAVE
LITTLE TO NO OPEN SPACE. WITHIN
THEM. GREEN SCHOOLYARDS ARE BY
BRANDS GREEN SPACES WITH NATURAL
PLAY STRUCTURES AND OUTDOOR
CLASSROOMS LEAST CAN PROMOTE
PARK EQUITY CLIMATE RESILIENCE
AND LEADUS TOWARDS A MORE
POSITIVE EDUCATION. AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES WHICH EVERYBODY WANTS.
DESPITE THE BEST BENEFITS GREEN
SCHOOLYARDS CAN PROVIDE THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO FUNDING TO TURN ALL
ASPHALT HEAVY. SCHOOLYARDS INTO
GREEN SCHOOLYARDS. IN LOS
ANGELES WE ARE WORKING ON OUR
FIRST GREEN SCHOOLYARD IN THE
HIGHLY VULNERABLE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE UNION. WE ARE DRYING
FROM DECADES OF EXPERTISE IN
CREATING GREEN SPACES. ARE WHEN
IT COMES TO PARKS IT BETTER
FOCUS ON COMMUNITY LED DESIGN
AND PARTICIPATORY DESIGN. AND
MANY OF THE LESSONS THAT WE HAVE
LEARNED FROM OUR NEW YORK
PROGRAM WHO TO DATE HAS HAVE
TRANSFORM TWO HUNDRED. GREEN
SCHOOLYARDS INTO WHAT WE CALL
GREEN SCHOOLYARDS VERY
SUCCESSFULLY. I AM A PRODUCT OF
LAUSD AND THAT'S A PLAY ON THESE
HOT HOT ASPHALT. PLACE ARCHERS
AND YARDS THAT'S FOR OVER THREE
DECADES LATER I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THAT SEEMS SCHOOL THAT I
WENT TO HAVE STRUCTURALLY BEEN
UPGRADED. BUT THE SCREEN SCHOOL
YOU ARE OR I MEAN THE LACK OF A
GREEN SCHOOLYARD IS CURRENTLY A
REALITY THERE. SO WITH THAT IN
MIND. GREEN SCHOOLYARDS I WANTED
TO JUST EMPHASIZE THE GREEN
SQUARES CAN HELP US CONTACT PARK
INEQUITIES WHICH ARE SUFFERED BY
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
AND REALLY HELP US OFFSET SOME
OF THIS EXTREME HEAT ISLAND
EFFECTS- THAT MANY OF THESE
COMMUNITIES ALSO SUFFER. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU NEXT. HI
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ARIELLE
ELEVENTH AND I'M ALSO WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND I'M WHERE
I WORK WITH COMMUNITIES TO
DESIGN CREATE PARKS AND GREEN
SCHOOLYARDS IN COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO OUR HIGH
QUALITY GREEN SPACE. BURKE
REQUESTING TWO HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THE GREEN SCHOOLYARD PROGRAM
GREEN SCHOOLYARDS ARE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROMOTE CLIMATE
RESILIENCY AND SUSTAINABILITY
AND INVESTMENT COMMUNITY IF ANY
GREEN SPACE THE MOST. WHEN HOT
ASPHALT SERVICES ARE PLEASED TO
TREES AND GREENERY SCHOOL YEAR
IT'S BECOME IMPORTANT COOLING
INFRASTRUCTURE DURING HEATWAES
WHILE ALSO MITIGATING HEAT
ISLAND EFFECT I WORKED WITH THE
OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
SUCCESSFULLY WORKED ALONGSIDE
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES TO TURN
HOT HOT ASPHALT LOCKS INTO
SPACES THAT OUR COMMUNITY
RESOURCES. WE JUST CELEBRATED
THE OPENING OF A GREEN SCHOOL
YARD IN EAST OAKLAND AT MARKHAM
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WHERE STUDENTS
ARE NOT ABLE TO LEARN AND PLAY
IN THE QUALITY GREEN SPACES THAT
THEY DESERVE FUNDING GREEN
SCHOOLYARDS IS FINDING
SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE
FUTURE. THANK YOU. NECKS GOOD
MORNING CHARLIE CASKEY AND
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE MY NAME'S
LYDIA SOLIDIFIED WITH THE
COMMITTEE WATER CENTER AND ON
BEHALF OF THE WATER FOUNDATION.
WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
AND THANK THE SENATE FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP. DEMONSTRATE IN THEIR
DRINKING WATER- BUDGET PROPOSALS
WHICH INCLUDE LONG TERM SUPORT
FOR FINDING A FIRST IN THE
NATION PERMANENT LOW INCOME
WATER RATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
AND CRITICAL DRINKING WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR THE MAY
REVISE WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
INCREASE ALLOCATIONS FOR DROUGHT
RESPONSE. HAS STATE WATER BOARD
STAFF AND UTILITY DEBT RELIEF.
WE URGE THE HARMONIZATION
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE AND SENATE BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAS ACCESS TO SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
THANK YOU. YOU ARE. NOW WILL
MOVE ATTENDING ONE. WISHING TO
TESTIFY TELEPHONICALLY- LET ME
PROVIDE THE PUBLIC WITH- TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IT'S.
844-291-6364 IN THE **** ACCESS
CODE IS FOURTEEN ONE ONE ONE-
FORTY THAT'S FOURTEEN ONE ONE
ONE FORTY- MODERATOR IF YOU'LL
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMIC
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU THEY
DON'T WANT TO PROVIDE COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINES OPEN. GOOD
MORNING I AM CAMPUS SECOND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
TROUT CALIFORNIA TROUT IS-
APPRECIATED AND WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION NAY REVISION
BUDGET PROPOSAL. WHICH INCLUDES
EXPANDED FISH AND WILDLIFE
PROTECTION AND RESTORATION
FUNDING IN THE JOB PACKAGE- THE
HUNDRED MILLION CHECKING AND THE
DESPERATION AND THREE POINT
THREE MILLION. FRESH PASSAGE
INCOME MANAGEMENT FIVE WE ALSO A
LINER COMMENT THAT THEY'RE GIVEN
BY CONDUCTING UP PARTICULARLY
250% SATISFIED BY CONSERVATION
ACTION FOCUSED ON CLIMATE BORDER
. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
LINE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORE
KINDS OF THE- BOUGHT MASON- WITH
THIS FOREST TRUST COULD MORE
KERRY. OF FIRST OFF WE PRE THE
ARE THE OF THE MAJOR BASIL OTHER
FIVE FROM START TO TWENTY ONE-
BUT THE SCALE OF THE CHALLENGE
REALLY DEMANDS MORE THAN THOSE-
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN RESERVES
BRING THAT ARE ON THE ENTIRE
STATED CLEARLY. JUST A DROP IN
THE BUCKET IF WE'RE GONNA REALLY
ADDRESS OUR THIRD PATHWAYS A
THIRTY BY THIRTY IN OUR OTHER
CLIMATE CHALLENGES. SO WE REALLY
AND THE SENATE TO YOU KNOW
FOLLOW THE PLAN THAT YOU HAVE
PLAYED OUT TO MAKE SOME MORE
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS IN
BIODIVERSITY CONSERVATION. AND
ATTAINING SOME OF THOSE GOALS I
ALSO WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE
SENATE ON THEIR- WATERSHED
RESILIENCE PACKAGE WITH THAT
EXCELLENT WAY TO ALSO. ADDRESS
MATRIX LOOSENED AND AGAIN MANY
OF THESE THINGS ARE EXCLUDABLE
FROM THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
LIMIT. AND FINALLY I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT WILL BE LOOKING TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO REALLY THRIVE ON
WILDFIRE DEFENSE MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE GETTING BACK TO
ANSWER BILLION DOLLAR A YEAR
RANGE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
. AND NEXT WE GO TO LINE IF YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE ZERO. HI
THINKING ABOUT GOING ON BEHALF
OF WELL VARIOUS CLIENTS AND
FIRST ON BE HAPPY ABOUT IT AND
FIND THE BIG WILD TO FORMALLY
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION
AUDUBON CALIFORNIA AND VALLEY
ATWATER COLLISION- ON MULTI
BENEFIT LAND RECORDS THE PROGRAM
DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION. WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE FUNDING. THE
FUNDING MAY REVIVE- FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS WALDRON SHORT OF
DEMAND ESPECIALLY THE AMOUNT OF
PLAN PROJECTED RETIRE BECOME
YEARS YOU THINK THAT. THE FIRST
ROUND AFTER TO PROGRAM ALONE
TOLD OVER A HUNDRED ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. IF YOU ARE
ALREADY LINING UP TO THE SECOND
ROUND WE ARE THEREFORE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF BENNETT'S PROPOSAL
FOR FIVE HUNDRED MILLION. THAT
ARE BEHALF OF THE NATURE. TROUT
UNLIMITED CALTRAIN OUTSTANDING
VITAL DEFENSE FIND- WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSED FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR DROUGHT RESILIENCE
GOOD STEP FORWARD TOWARDS
PROVIDING THE RESOURCES WE NEED
TO DEAL WITH. ARE FREQUENT
YOU'RE DRIVING. THE KILEY
CHANGES BRING THE STATE. NINE OF
OUR LAST WEEK SENIOR AND CLEARED
BY MERGING FEES INITIATIVES
YEARS THE WA BOARD IS NOT ABLE
TO REACT ENOUGH TO MAKE AN
IMPACT. NEED BOLDEN BACK NOW DO
THE ONGOING DROUGHT THE NEED.
MORE NEED FUNDING OF FIFTEEN IS
MOVING. MORE EFFICIENT AND IF
ACTION ONE DROP OF HER. WE HAVE
TO FIND YOU TO BE OUT. TO THE
WATER- DIVISION OF WATER RIGHTS
TO ESTABLISH A DROUGHT SECTION.
WE FIFTEEN TO TWENTY EMPLOYEE.
WOULD PLAN FOR AND REACT DRIVING
BEFORE TO LATE. FINALLY I BEHALF
OF RON CAME PEOPLE RISE FOR
DISTRICT TWO ALFA COUNTY. WHAT
YOU CAN. FOR THE TWO THIRD
POINTS YOU KNOW FOR WILDLIFE
RESPONSE MANAGEMENT AT THE F. W.
BUT URGED THE PARTIES. TO
INCLUDE ALPINE CAL WHICH FOR
NEVADA BASIN AND BLOCK HAS ABOUT
OF ACRE. IN THE LAST YEAR MANY
WHICH WERE HABITAT- DO THE
CAMERA CALDERON FIRES. AND OF
THE RIVER IN THE INCREASE IN
BEAR AND OTHER WILDLIFE ACTIVE
RESIDENTS LIKE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT. LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING DANIEL BRAY
ON BEHALF OF CARE CLUB. WE
STRONGLY THE PROPOSAL IN THE CAB
MAY REVISE TO ACCELERATE FUNDING
FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FOR EQUITY
BASED GREEN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. WE OFFER SUPPORT THE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FREE TRADE THAT THE
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION TO HELP
PAY UTILITY BILLS AND THE NINE
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION FOR
DISTRIBUTED SOLAR AND STORAGE.
ADDITIONALLY WE APPRECIATE THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS FOR MUCH
NEEDED INVESTMENT. INTO VARIOUS
BOARDS AND AGENCIES TO FOR
AMERICA THIRTY BY THIRTY AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE. HOWEVER WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO PASS A
FINAL BUDGET THAT INCLUDES
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE INVESTMENT
THAN THIRTY BY THIRTY IN COASTAL
RESILIENCE THAT'S MORE IN LINE
WITH THE SENATE PER. WITH WHAT
THE SENATE PROPOSED IN ITS
CLIMATE BUDGET. FINALLY WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED THAT THE ENERGY
RESERVE PROPOSAL WILL PROP UP
POLLUTING FOSSIL FUEL
INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN WE NEED TO
TRANSITION IMMEDIATELY AWAY FROM
THESE TECHNOLOGIES. AND THAT THE
PROPOSED FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR WATER STORAGE PROJECTS WILL
FIND ECOLOGICALLY IRRESPONSIBLE
PROJECTS LIKE SITES RESERVOIR.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU.
THANK YOU NECKS. ONE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR ACCOUNT-
ON BEHALF OF MY NAME'S JOSH
COULDN'T EVEN ABOUT HALF A GREAT. EVERY WHERE YOU. BRING
ACCORDING TO THE GOVERNOR NAME
ONLY BY THE LINE INCLUDING
FISCAL FOUR EIGHT BUT IF CLUB
YOU ALL RIGHT YEAH THE PROPOSAL
. ALL RIGHT JUST NOT THE DOLLARS
OF INTEREST AND ECONOMIC OUTPUT
INPUT TWENTY OKAY THEY ARE
RATHER THAN FROM HARM'S WAY.
MEDIA WITHOUT. YOU MAY BE.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE CRUNCH AND FUTURE
GOING FOR INCLUDING DOUBLING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TO YOUR- THE
TOKEN CARE OF. WHO WERE GOING.
TO ONE BILLION. CRITICAL OCTOBER
THIRTY IN REST PRO TO BE
INQUIRED OF RELATED TRAVEL THAT
WE. I HAVE WORKED WILL ROGERS
WILL PROJECT IN THE MAYOR ALONE
THE PROPOSAL STATE FUND SUPPORT. IN A LETTER CO SIGNED THE
BEARS KHALKHAL SILICON VALLEY
LEADERS GROUP VALLEY WA. ALONG
WITH FROM LOCAL LIKE LEADER
THROUGHOUT THE AREA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK THE EX. I FIFTY
NINETIES GO. THE MORNING CARE
NUMBER THAT'S WHAT NOT OF THE
CONTRACTOR. YOUR ON A COUPLE OF
ITEMS FIRST OFF WE WANT SUPPORT
AND ALLOW ARE. WITH EIGHT THIRTY
BY THIRTY. OFF. ONCE THE
PRESSURES WHAT BIRD WE HADN'T.
NOT HUNDREDS ODD NO DOLLARS ON A
TOWARD SOLAR STORAGE BUT WITH
HER DOWN TO ALLOCATE THE DOLLARS
SHE- KEY THINK. THAT THERE IS A
STRONG PLANNING ELEMENT THAT'S
BOTH RICH YASSER WITH FEDERAL.
BOB IN THE EFFORT TO BRING-
FARMS ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
WE'VE WORKED FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS TO PRESERVE AND WE OUR
TRYING TO PROMOTE ENVIRONMENT.
WHERE IT'S STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE PROPOSED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR
YOUR FAITH CALIFORNIA
UNDERSERVED AND SMALL PRODUCER
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
DROUGHT FINANCIAL RELIEF AND
ENERGY EFFICIENT. EQUIPMENT
UPGRADES. IN THE FUNDING FOR
THIS IS GROUNDWATER ACT TAKE MY
IMPLEMENTATION WE STRONGLY
RECOMMEND YOU CONSIDER ADDING
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR CENTRAL
OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT A SMALL
SCALE AND UNDERSERVED FARMERS.
ARE FARMERS HAVE NOT RECEIVED
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
ENGAGE AND LOCAL SAID MY
IMPLEMENTATION AND WE HOPE THAT
YOU CONSIDER THESE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS. THANKS FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK AND LEADERSHIP AND
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU NEXT.
NINE SIXTY EIGHT. HELLO NUMBER
TRANSFERRED FROM ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE. HAPPY CALIFORNIANS
ARE PLAN THEN ASIAN BERMAN WILL
NOT. TWENTY TWO MILLION EIGHT
WHITE WELL INCOME BUILDING
EQUITABLE BUILDING OUR PROGRAM
IN ADDITION THE TRUCK WITH THE
PART OF WHAT SEVENTY MILLION TO
THE GOVERNOR NEWLY REVISED
EIGHTY BILLION. HOWEVER WE ARE
OF WHAT MILLION THE CONSTRUCTION.
WHAT. PART OF THE GOVERNMENT. WE
CANNOT GET INTO A BAD ONE THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU ANNEX.
LINE SEVENTY SEVEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BRENDAN TAYLOR GONNA
HAPPEN THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER SMALL THIRTY
FIVE AIR DISTRICTS GIVEN THE
HISTORIC BUDGET SURPLUS THE MAY
REVISION MISSES A SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH BY NOT INVESTING MORE
FUNDING INTO COST EFFECTIVE AIR
QUALITY PROGRAMS AGRICULTURAL
DIESEL REPLACEMENTS AND UPGRADES
OR FARMER PROGRAM AND THE EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION PROGRAM. WE
APPRECIATE THE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IN FUNDING FOR THE FINAL
PROGRAM IN THE JANUARY BUDGET
BUT WE RESPECTFULLY ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE THAT
AMOUNT SECOND WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THE GENEROUS BUDGETS
PROPOSED FIFTY MILLION FOR A
DISTRICT IMPLEMENTATION AT
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY
PROTECTION PROGRAM HOWEVER
DESPITE ADDITIONAL COMMUNITIES
BEING ADDED THIS IS THE SAME
AMOUNT IN PREVIOUS YEARS
JAPANESE STARKLY BEEN
INSUFFICIENT TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE STATE
MANDATED MANDATED PROGRAM. AND
IMPLEMENTATION PLANNING GOES FOR
INTERMOUNTAIN HEARING COMMUNITY
OUTREACH DEVELOPING COMMUNITY
EMISSION REDUCTION PLANS AND.
OTHER ACTIVITIES. PLEASE
REMEMBER AS TO MILLION COMMAND
PROTECTION AND PLAN IS BRINGING
THE TO TWO MILLION. IT'S STILL
23% CUT FROM THE TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY MILLION PROVIDED LAST YEAR
ON A DIFFERENT NOTE THANKS TO
YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES MISTER
CHAIR. LAST YEAR'S SYSTEM
ADOPTED BUDGET INCLUDED FUNDING
FOR THE WOOD SMOKE REDUCTION
PROGRAM. ACTION PLAN IS HAS BEEN
TO BUY. REPLACE DIRTIER. IN
DEVICES WITH CLEANER PRICES THE
PROPOSED BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR THIS COST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM AND WE ASK YOU TO
INCLUDE FUNDING IN THE FINAL
BUDGET AND FINALLY. EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TO WILDFIRE SMOKE
IMPACTS IS INCREASINGLY CRITICAL
NEED BUT DUE TO LACK OF SENDING
AIR DISTRICTS ARE LIMITED IN
THEIR ABILITY TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES AND
ASSISTANCE TO DO THE JOB. WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THIS ISSUE AND
SHARED INFORMATION WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF ON HOW RESOURCES
COULD BE INVESTED. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU. APPRECIATE
IT NECKS. EIGHTY ONE. LINE
EIGHTY WHEN. THANK YOU SIR AND
MEMBERS ARE BACK IN MARKETS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST CALIFORNIA CHROME IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK THE CARBON
CYCLE INSTITUTE AND THE
CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED ORGANIC
FARMERS FIRST I WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR DEEP APPRECIATION
APPRECIATION TO BOTH THE SENATE
AND GOVERNOR NEW PLAN ON THEIR
COMMITMENT TO CLIMATE CHANGE
SOLUTIONS ALL THAT BEING SAID WE
ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT BOTH IN
THE REVISED THE FUN OF BUDGET
PLAN DID NOT INCLUDE MORE
INVESTMENTS IN THE WORKING LANDS
AFTER. FARMERS AND RANCHERS WANT
TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION BUT
YOU NEED INCENTIVES AND
RESOURCES TO DO SELF
SPECIFICALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR
AGRICULTURAL LAND CONSERVATION
IN AXACT CROP PLANTS ARE MISSING
FROM THE LAND TYPES WHICH WHICH
CAN ACCESS CONSERVATION DOLLARS
AND BOTH THESE PLANTS WE URGE
YOU TO FIND THE CALIFORNIA FARM
LAND CONSERVANCY PROGRAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD LIKE
INVESTMENTS TO THE ALTERNATIVE
YOUR MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
PRESCRIBED GRAZING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND ORGANIC
TRANSITION PROGRAM WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND SET ASIDE FOR
PROGRAM EVALUATION OF THE
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE
PROGRAMS AT CDFA WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING OUR PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE EX. ALIGNED AT SIX FIFTY
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHEROKEE
MEMBERS TIFFANY FAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA EFFICIENCY AND
DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL WHILE
WE AWAIT THE DETAILS WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOGNITION OF THE ROLE DEMAND
RESPONSE IN ITS ROLE AND A GREAT
RELIABILITY WE APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF TWO HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE MILLION IN THE MAY REVISION
TO SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. IN DEVELOPING DEMAND
SIDE GRID SUPPORT INITIATIVE
DEMAND RESPONSE AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY OR COST EFFECTIVE
DEMAND SIDE RESOURCES READY AND
AVAILABLE TO BE DEPLOYED TO EAT
CALIFORNIA'S GRID WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
ON CONTINUING TO EXPAND THE
POTENTIAL FOR DEMAND RESPONSE
THANK YOU. NEXT SEVENTY THREE IF
I HAD. IF YOU CAN REMEMBER
SOVIET BELIEVE SHOP ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT. THE
BIRTH EXPLORATION OF FUNDING
PREDICTING PARKS FOR ALL
PROGRAMS HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT
MOST OF THAT SPENDING SHOULD GO
TO THE EIGHT EIGHT OF COURSE THE
PRICE PROGRAM CURRENTLY SERVES
AS MANAGING COMMUNITY BUT THE
REMAINDER OF THE FANS GOING AND
THE NEW PROGRAM. IN ADDITION THE
DISTRICT OFFICE RESPONDING FOR
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURAL
AGRICULTURE SPECIFICALLY PENDING
FOR ELECTRIC I THINK INCLUDING.
MARCH NINTH AND- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INTEREST. THANKS NECKS.
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN. MORNING CHAIR
NUMBERS ARE GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS BILLY MCKAY ON BEHALF OF
GREEN MANUFACTURING AND STRONG
SUPPORT AT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THE NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO MILLION FOR STATEWIDE LOW
INCOME BUILDINGS RUSSIA FOR
EQUITABLE BUILDING THE
COMBINATION PROGRAM THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NEXT. SEVENTY FOUR. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR MARK SPENCER MAKER
ON BEHALF OF THE NORMAL WATER
BUT WATER AGENCIES SERVING
CINEMA COUNTY FAIR AND STRONG
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR TEN MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
FOR ATMOSPHERIC RIVER FORECAST
INFORMED RESERVOIR OPERATIONS
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO CALL
BACK MORE WATER IN OUR
RESERVOIRS TO RESPOND TO CHANGES
IN PRECIPITATION PATTERNS.
PHYSICIAN WE ALSO REQUEST THAT
THE LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATE FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR TWO
YEARS TO HELP WITH COSTS THAT
USERS ARE FACING AT CIGNA IS
IMPLEMENTED- FIXED COSTS AT
CIGNA COMES ONLINE THAT ARE
GOING TO DRIVE REALLY HIGH WATER
FEES FOR CERTAIN- BAKING THAT
HAVE SMALL AMOUNT OF USERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT.
LINE ONE WE HEAR ONLINE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KIM DELFINO ON THE
BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
HEALTH WE NEED TO. THE AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA AND NO LAND TRUSTS
AND I GUESS BUT BOTH OF THEM FOR
YOU WITH A THIRTY BY THIRTY
COALITION OF THE FOLLOWING
COMMENTS ON THIRTY BY THIRTY IN
CLIMATE INVESTMENTS WE SUPPORTED
PRECIADO MINISTRATION. OF BUDGET
PROPOSALS WERE CONDUCTED INTO
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
DEPARTMENT FISH WILDLIFE
CONSERVANCIES AND DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION DEPARTMENT THIRTY
BY THIRTY CLIMATE RESILIENT. I
IN PARTICULAR VERY PLEASED THE
FUNDING PROPOSED FOR THE NEW
PROGRAM AT THE W. C. T. FELT THE
SUPPORT THE MINISTRATION HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
TRIED. HOWEVER WE URGE THAT THE
FINAL BUDGET INCLUDES
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT THE SENATE HAVE PROPOSED IN
THE CLIMATE BUDGET PROPOSAL
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN WHITE HOUSE
HE UP FOR THE THIRTY BY THREE
AND COASTAL RESILIENCE THE
SENATE PROPOSAL WORK BUT GALE OF
WHAT'S NEEDED TO ACHIEVE THIRTY
BY THIRTY AND KLAMATH FALLS AND
PARTICULAR NOTE LIKE TO SEE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN BATH AND
WILDLIFE CORRIDORS AND GAMMA
MOVE ALL WITH AN ADDITIONAL
THREE MILLION TO THE W. T. B.
TWELVE MICROGRAMS. WHILE THE
ORDER PROGRAM AND HUNDRED
BILLING FOR DAM REMOVAL OF THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY WE ARE THE
FINAL BUDGET INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THE CAPACITY
BUILDING ORGANIZATIONS WORKING
ON THIRTY BY THIRTY UP
PARTICULARLY IN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND WE URGE THE
FINAL BUDGET INCLUDES MORE
INVESTMENT IN FRANCE. BEFORE
THIRTY BY 30 DEGREES FORTY
MILLION TO COMPLETE THE FATE OF
THE DICTATION MAPPING REGARDING
THE PRIOR PROPOSAL ON THE BEHALF
OF DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE THE
NTSB LOOKS LIKE MORE INVESTMENT
ALONG THE LINES AGAIN OF THE
SITE AND ITS CLIMATE PROPOSAL IN
TERMS OF FUNDING FOR CERTAIN
FEES. INCREASED INVESTMENT BY
RESILIENT OVER WE'D ALSO LIKE TO
SEE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD LAY OUT THAT ARE REPORTING
ON AN INCREASED MONITORING OF
THE PROJECT THE STATUS THING AND
WE CAN UNDERSTAND AND LEARN FROM
THESE PROJECTS UP TO DATE THAT
IS NOT HAPPENING. AND FINALLY
REGARDING THE PROPOSAL ON THE
BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
SUPPORT THE FUNDING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED BECAME
A WILDLIFE COMPLEX NAME
RESTORATION WITH WETLANDS
RESTORATION TRIBAL. CO
MANAGEMENT AND MANAGEMENT IN
ONLY. BUT WE OPPOSE THE FOR
GROUP TO FINISH IMPLEMENTABLE.
AGREEMENT WHICH ARE NOT
SUPPORTED BY A SINGLE. WORKING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
EX. SEVENTY TWO IS GO AHEAD.
MMHM AFTERNOON MISTER TERRY
MEMBERS HERE ON THE ON BEHALF OF
THE BUILDING COLLISION ENERGY
ACTION FUND CENTRAL COAST ENERGY
ALL SERVICES CALLING FROM AT THE
NINE HUNDRED TO TWO MAY DOLLARS
FOR EQUITABLE BUILDING. AND THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL AND WE HOPE TO
SEE THAT DEFINE BUDGET PACKAGE
IT COULD BE EQUITABLE THE
CALIFORNIA'S BUILDING SECTOR
WILL BE CRITICAL TO BOTH MEETING
OUR CLIMATE GOALS INCLUDE THE
HOMES THAT ARE MOST PEOPLE IN
ALL COMMUNITIES THERE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
SUPPOSEDLY STREAM HE'S SATISFIED
CONSTRUCT UPGRADE COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTER. WE ARE
REQUESTING A TOTAL OF ONE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE CENTER
THANK. YOU NEXT. FINE SIX FOUR
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU YOUR
NUMBER'S THIS IS MEGAN CLAIBORNE
COMPANY CONSERVANCY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS MARY FRANK
CAN'T BE APPRECIATE THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS INCLUDED
FOR IMPROVING TRAFFIC LIGHTS ARE
ON BRAND AND MIGRATORY BIRD
HABITAT UTILIZING THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FUNDING DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN THE
BURGER CHAIN'S PROGRAMS.
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA RICE
COMMISSION PARTNER PROGRAM IT'S
A VERY IF I CAN SEE HOW QUICKLY
THE PROGRAM CAN BE DEPLOYED AT
AN UNPRECEDENTED SCALE THE
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE
COLLECTIVE PROGRAM PROGRAM HAVE
PROVIDED OVER OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES OF HABITAT TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACT WORKOUT. IF
YOUR MAIN CHALLENGE IS HOW TO
GILBERT RETURNS AND MAKE IT MORE
DURABLE PROGRAM I CAN DELIVER I
THINK TRICK BIRD HABITAT
MULTIPLE BENEFITS MEDICAL
TREATMENT. ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THE FIRM FOR THE PROGRAM
INCLUDED IN THE BY. RIGHT YOU
HAVE TO BE TO WORK WITH. ON A
NETWORK. THAT IS THE PRICE OF
REGIONAL HUB PEOPLE OF MEANS.
HAVEN'T HAPPENED MARKETS
TAILORED. THE TELEVISION NETWORK
. FOR THE HABITAT FOR MIGRATORY
BIRDS HABITAT FOR MIGRATORY WHY
BIRDS EAT CALIFORNIA I CAN BE
TAILORED THE KEY COUNTRY JOHN
OPPORTUNITIES AND DIFFERENT
REGIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NECKS. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT. HI
THERE THIS IS MY YELLOW ROCK
SHOW FROM THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON THESE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS WE SUPPORT
THE OVERALL FOCUS ON CLIMATE-
QUALITY AND EQUITY PROGRAMS THAT
PRIORITIZE LONG. FIRST THE
REPORT FOUND THAT TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS ON TOO MANY DAYS
LIVE WITH UNHEALTHY AIR IN THIS
YEAR'S REPORT WHICH CAME OUT
LAST MONTH- WE FOUND THAT SIX
CALIFORNIA CITIES RANKED TOP TEN
CORNER- ZONE IN THE U. S. AND
SEVEN CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE IN
THE TOP TEN FOR PARTICLE
POLLUTION FOR THESE REASONS WE
NEED TO MOVE QUICKLY TO
TRANSITION VEHICLES TO THEIR
MISSION WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ACCELERATE IT CELEBRATE THEIR
MISSION TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS ESPECIALLY IN EQUITY
BASED PROGRAM. TO ACHIEVE THESE
GOALS WE FAVOR SHIFTING A LARGE
PORTION OF THE EQUITY BASE HE BE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL FUNDING TO
DISTRICTS TO FIND EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT THE
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT THE
MOST WE ALSO SUPPORT THE SENATE
WORK ON EXPANDING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S WILDFIREPROPOSAL
WITH A MORE ROBUST PACKAGE TO
REDUCE. HEALTH HARMS- FROM
WILDFIRE. SMOKE THANK YOU. NECKS
NINE EIGHT NINE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF
OF THE CLIENT THIRTY WENT THAT
THE AMERICAN READ A WATER
DISTRICT- EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT A MODERATE ONE
APPLE REALLY THANKFUL FOR THE
INCLUSION OF THE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR WATER RECYCLING IN THE MAY
REVISE. HOWEVER AS THE ****
STERN SAID IN ORDER TO FIT THE
NEED RIGHT NOW JUST THE PIPELINE
A PROJECT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT MANY INCREASE CLOSER TO
WHAT'S IN THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN
IN ADDITION ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STORM WATER QUALITY
ASSOCIATION. WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE FUNDING FOR STORMWATER
CAPTURE IN MANAGEMENT ALSO
SIMILAR TO WHAT'S IN THE SENATE
POINT FIVE BILLION POP FOR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
INCLUDING FUNDING FOR STORMWATER
PROJECT A WHILE URBAN STORM
WATER MANAGEMENT IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT WAYS WE CAN
PROTECT OUR PRECIOUS WATER RATES
WHILE ALSO INCREASING VALUABLE
WATER SUPPLIES. IT CONTINUED TO
BE ONE OF THE MOST CHRONICALLY
UNDERFUNDED INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
FACING LOCAL GOVERNMENT TODAY-
THANK YOU SO. MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. NEXT NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SANDERS MY NAME IS CHRIS
SHOPPERS I'M WITH COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR IS A MEMBER CHARGE AHEAD
CALIFORNIA WITH SPONSORED SB
TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE OF
LEGISLATION TO CREATE CALIFORNIA
SUITE OF TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
PROGRAMS WE'RE ALSO PART OF THE
INVESTMENT CLEAN AIR CAMPAIGN.
NOW MORE THAN EVER CALIFORNIA
STREAM TO CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
STRATEGY NEEDS TO CENTER ON
EQUITY. ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
FEELING THE PINCH FROM GASOLINE
PRICES ARE DISADVANTAGED AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES ARE FEELING
THE PAIN ABOUT. CALIFORNIA IS
ALSO HOME TO THE DIRTY AFFAIR IN
THE NATION AND TRANSPORTATION
THE STATE'S NUMBER ONE SOURCE OF
POLLUTION. WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSAL
TOOK CELERY CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENT. THE STATE'S RECORD
ISSUE TO THE STATE RECORD
SHATTERING BUDGET SURPLUS GIVE
CALIFORNIA THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INVEST IN CLEAN AIR. OUR
PRESIDENT LET LEVEL. FEEDING UP
INVESTORS PARTICULARLY IN THE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY SECTOR WE
WILL COMMIT TO GET CLIMATE AND
HEALTH BENEFITS. WE DO HOWEVER
HAPPENS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM.
THE BUDGET PROPOSES TO ALLOCATE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION TO
FUTURE STATEWIDE EXPANSION AND
ONLY FIFTY MILLION TO EXISTING
PROGRAMS. WE BELIEVE THIS NUMBER
SHOULD BE FLIPPED. THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS HAVE AN IMMEDIATE NEED
AND INVESTING IN THEM NOW WILL
CREATE IMMEDIATE BENEFITS THAT
ARE MOST POLLUTED AIR BASE. WE
ALL HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT CARBS CURRENT CONTESTS FOR
STATEWIDE EXPANSION CLEAN CARDS
FOR ALL. AND BELIEVE THAT THESE
ISSUES NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
BEFORE PROCEEDING WITH THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
NEXT LINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS ALAN ABBAS
WITH THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CAPCO NOTED WHILE
GOVERNORS MAY REVISION AS TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN INCENTIVES THIS AMOUNT
IS STILL 23% LESS THAN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET ADDITIONALLY THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL CONTINUES TO
FUND THE IMPLEMENTATION PORTION
OF BABY SIX SEVENTEEN AT ONLY
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS
THE SAME AMOUNT IT'S FOUR YEARS
AGO WHEN THEY WERE SEVEN LEFT
COMMUNITIES IN THE PROGRAM.
INCREASING FUNDING FOR AN
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD PROVIDE
MORE MONITORING ENFORCEMENT AND
COMMUNITY OUTREACH AMONG OTHER
THINGS AND WE HOPE TO SEE AN
INCREASE IN THIS AREA IN
ADDITION THE MAY REVISE PROPOSES
EXHILARATING THE CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL PROGRAM BY CREATING A NEW
PARALLEL STATE RUN PROGRAM IN
AREAS WHERE AIR DISTRICTS
CURRENTLY RUN PROGRAMMES AS MY
COUNTERPART FROM VALLEY CAN
NOTED EXISTING AIR DISTRICT
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE THE MAJORITY
OF DISADVANTAGED IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. WOULD BE STARVED OF
FUNDING IT TEN MILLION DOLLARS
PER AIR DISTRICT WITH TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS GOING TO A PARALLEL
STATE WIDE PROGRAM IT WOULD BE
MORE EFFICIENT TO INCREASE
FUNDING THE CURRENT AIR DISTRICT
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAMS IN
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER
REBALANCING THE FUNDING PROPOSED
IN THE MAY REVISE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. NINETY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS THEY'RE
TURNING ON TOP OF THE SUBJECT ON
BEHALF OF TURLOCK IRRIGATION
DISTRICT CALLING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE FUNDING FOR
FORECAST INFORMED RESERVOIR
OPERATIONS AND THE COLLECTION OF
AIRBORNE SNOW OBSERVATORY DATA
TO IMPROVE THE ACCURACY OF THE
RUNOFF FORECAST IN ADDITION TO
OUR NATION DISTRICT IS ALSO
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FUNDING
PROPOSAL OR SOLAR DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS ASSOCIATED WITH. WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IN FOR THE REMAINING PEOPLE
ON THE LINE EIGHT IF WE COULD
KEEP OUR COMMENTS ABOUT A
MINUTE- I'VE BEEN TOTALLY FIGURE
TO KICK ME OUT HERE. HAD
SOMETIME. X. NEXT LINE. NINETY
FOUR. HIS PATRICK OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
SITUATION RESTORE REVIEWING ALL
THE WATER AND ENERGY PROPOSAL SO
KEEP MY COMMENTS JUST ON THE
NATIONAL FUNDING FOR UTILITY
ASSISTANCE TODAY WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
ANOTHER ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
RESEARCH PAYMENT PROGRAM WHICH
IF SUCCESSFULLY HELPED OVER ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION CUSTOMERS
STATEWIDE. THANK YOU COMMENTS
FOR THE COMMITTEE AND WE URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT-
FEDERAL CODE RELIEF DOLLARS AT
THE FUNDING SOURCE I WILL
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION TO THE
COMMITTEE ON WHY THAT'S
IMPORTANT AND- WE ALSO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO MAINTAIN B. AFTER
FINDING MECHANISM WHERE THERE IS
A SEPARATE PART OF FUNDING FOR
I'LL USE CC A CUSTOMERS AND
STAFF ARE PART OF FUNDING FOR
ELECTRIC COOPERATIVE IN PUBLICLY
OWNED ELECTRICITY CUSTOMERS
REFLECTING THE DIFFERENT
FINANCIAL STRUCTURES OF THE
UTILITY SO WE CAN BEST AND MOST
EFFICIENTLY HELP OUR CUSTOMERS.
THE POOR TO WORKING WITH YOU- ON
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION AND
ADOPTION OF THIS PRODUCT THANK.
YOU NEXT THANK YOU. I NINETY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
NATALIE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE SENATE
PROPOSAL WE MUST FIND UNIVERSAL
INCOME RATE ASSISTANCE FOR WATER
AND WASTEWATER SERVICES AND
ENSURE THAT ALL WATER
PORTABILITY PROGRAM START THOSE
BOOKS AND DOCUMENT THE
CALIFORNIANS ARE FUNDING
BIRTHDAY MONTH WOMEN PATIENT
MUST INCLUDE A 30% THE FACT THE
PROJECTS THAT BENEFIT DRINKING
WATER DISADVANTAGED MAYBE WORK
MAYBE. I WE APPRECIATE BOTH
PROGRAM AMERICA WHY THAT WE NEED
TO ENSURE THE FUNNY AVAILABLE TO
ALL REGARDLESS OF THAT IS A THE
INVEST WE CAN TO FOR THE
DELEGATES FOR COMMUNITY AT THE
IF THE AND AMENITIES. THAT
PROVIDE MULTIPLE TO RESIDENTS
LIVING NEAR THE FOOT THERE NEEDS
TO BE IN ORDER TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS AND HAVE
TRADITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
FOR LIFE OR DEATH AND PUBLIC
HEALTH- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
HUNDRED SEVEN HUNDRED SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION FOR
EXCELLENCE CENTERS WHICH ARE A
CRITICAL PIECE OF PHYSICAL AND
SOCIAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND ARE
INSTRUMENTAL IN BUILDING
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE BOTH.
EXTREME CLIMATE EVENTS AND IN
THE LONG TERM WE ARE EXCITED THE
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET AND WHILE
WE ARE ADVOCATING FOR A TOTAL OF
ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO MAKE A
WIDE SCALE OF NEED FOR THE ARE
THESE ARE THE HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLAR LOCATION BECAUSE
WE'LL START. WITH THE BOARD
EXONERATED THE FUNDING PROGRAMS
LIKE THE P. FOUR EIGHT ARGUED
MUCH NEEDED TO MAKE THE EASY
ACCESSIBLE TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WHO ARE HARMED BY-
HARM THE MOST BY HIGH GAS PRICES
THE PROGRAMS INCLUDE INCLUDING
THE GOVERNOR CELEBRATION ALCOHOL
AT HOME CHARGING FIFTY FOUR
EIGHT THE FEELING OF THE
STRUCTURE ARE ALL CRITICAL TO
ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
THE VEHICLE AND DOUBLE EQUITABLY
ADDITIONALLY WE STRONGLY URGE
COLLABORATION WITH COMMUNITY
GROUPS EMPLOYMENT VERIFIABLE.
FOR GRANT ME QUITE A BIT COLD. A
LOT IT IS PRETTY. TO ENSURE THAT
ALL THE E. FEELING SECTOR
SPENDING TO GETTING. A LOT OF A
QUARTER AT IN. THANK YOU. X. MY
NINETIETH. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
THIS IS FOR A PROBLEM BECAUSE IN
THE WE APPRECIATE YOU SIX
INFORMATION FUNDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR A DISTRICT
HOWEVER- THE PRO IS TO UNDER IT
BY MY COLLEAGUE WE ASK THAT YOU
PROVIDE INCREASED ITS DATA
FUNDING TO COVER PRO COSTS
NUMBER THE COMMUNITIES IN THE
PROGRAM HAS GROWN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW. REGISTERS ARE
WORKING AT A DEPTH IN THE STATE.
PROGRAM WE APPRECIATE THE EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN INCENTIVE FUNDING
INCLUDED ESPECIALLY THE
ADDITIONAL TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ADDED TO THE MAY REVISE.
HOWEVER OVERALL THE TOTAL
ALLOCATION THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IS STILL A REDUCTION FROM WHAT
IS IT MADE AVAILABLE IN PREVIOUS
YEARS. WE HAVE TO PROVIDE
INCREASED AND SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING TO PRIORITIZE THIS
REDUCTION THAT PROTECT THE
HEALTH OF STATE THE STATE
DOESN'T MANAGE COMMUNITY.
SIGNIFICANCE INCENTIVE FUND IT'S
CRITICAL FOR MEETING HEALTH
BASED FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS AND EXHILARATING
SORELY NEEDED NEAR TERM EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. WE SUPPORT FUNDING
HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY BEING DEVELOPED FOR
MASS DEPLOYMENT IN THE FUTURE.
HOWEVER GIVEN OUR NEED TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH NOW WE
SUPPORT FUNDING TO REPLACE HEAVY
DUTY DIESEL TRUCKS WITH NEAR
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS THAT ARE
LOWER COST. MORE COST EFFECTIVE
TO PROVIDE MORE IMMEDIATE AIR
POLLUTION AND GHG EMISSION
REDUCTIONS THANK YOU THE NEXT.
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAUL
WOODS WITH CALIFORNIA ADVISORS
ON BEHALF OF SMART THANK YOU IN
THE COMMENTS OF THE C. MUA IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FUNDING FOR THE CAP.
THANK YOU. NECKS. ONE OH FIVE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS IN PARTICULAR FOR HERE
WITH CLEMENT RESULT THE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION IN LOS
ANGELES. WORKING TO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR CLIMATE
RESILIENT IN THE FACE OF EXTREME
HEAT. WELL WE APPRECIATE THE MAY
REVISE APPROPRIATING THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR EXTREME
HEAT. FROM LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
SURPLUS WE NEED ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS FROM THIS YEAR'S
HISTORIC BUDGET SURPLUS. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST SUBSTANTIAL
AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH FOR THE COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE IN EXTREME HEAT
PROGRAM. ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR
SP ONE FIVE FIVE. HERE'S WHY.
FIRST RURAL AREAS AND CITIES BIG
AND SMALL THE PROPOSED BUDGET
DOES NOT ADEQUATELY OR DIRECTLY
ADDRESS. THE UNDERLYING FACTORS
CONTRIBUTING TO EXTREME HEAT.
TOO MANY HEAT ABSORBING SURFACES
INCLUDING STREETS AND ROOFTOPS
SECOND. ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS
ARE NEEDED TO EXPLICITLY TARGET
HE- IN ORDER TO PREVENT DEATHS
AND PREPARE FOR THE PREDICTED
INCREASE IN HEAT WAVES AND POWER
OUTAGES LAST WEEK THERE'S A DIRE
NEED TO INVEST. AND PLAN FOR
HUMAN CENTRIC APPROACHES. TO
REDUCE AMBIENT HEAT. WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION THAT
EXTREME HEAT IS EXACERBATING
IMPACTS ON VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES WE WOULD INCREASE
THE SENATE TO CONSIDER
INVESTMENTS. THAT WILL DELIVER
IMMEDIATE RELIEF AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST SUBSTANTIAL
AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH FOR THE COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE AND EXTREMELY
PROGRAM. THAT WAS LAST YEAR F.
B. ONE FIVE FIVE. NEXT YOU MIGHT
WANT TO WAIT. GOOD AFTERNOON
TASHA NEWMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL LAND TRUSTS
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF GREATER CONSERVATION
DISTRICT- I WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF KIM
DELFINO AND DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE. AND JUST- SPECIFICALLY
STRESSED THE NEED FOR. AFTER THE
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FUNDING
THAT WILL HELP THE RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT LAND TRUST
ANOTHER LOCAL PARTNERS TO
IMPLEMENT THE GOLDEN THIRTY BY
THIRTY AND THE CLIMATE SMART
STRATEGIES THANK YOU THE NEXT.
LINE ONE CAN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- MY NAME IS OUR
DERIVATION- COME ON BEHALF OF
DAIKON LEADING MANUFACTURER OF
HEAT PUMP SOLUTIONS. WHERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR THE NINE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
STATE LOW INCOME BUILDING YOUR
DROP IT INCREDIBLE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION PROGRAM. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS PROGRAM WILL
PLAY A CRUCIAL ROLE TO
ACCELERATE STATES BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION APPLES AND ALSO
WILL HELP MEET OTHER EMPLOYMENT
AND RELATED TO STATE GOALS SUCH
AS THE C. SEES SIX MEDIUM HEAT
PUMP INSTALLATION GOAL BY TWENTY
THIRTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NECKS LINE. FORTY FIVE. NINE
FORTY FIVE. HELLO HERE SORRY-
HELLO THIS IS SHERRY MEMBER THE
GUN CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM WE'RE REQUESTING BUDGET
INVESTMENTS BUT YOU SPECIFIC
ITEMS NUMBER ONE UNDER CDSA WE
ASKED FOR TWO MILLION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS TO
CONSTRUCT AND FACTORIES THAT
PRODUCE BENEFICIAL ORGANISMS. OR
ETHICAL LOGICAL INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT NUMBER Q. UNDER THE
COUNTER UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION WE OFFER FIFTY
MILLION FOR GRANTS TO DEVELOP
AND EXPAND REGIONAL FARMER
TRAINING CENTERS BUT MY
CULTURALLY RELEVANT ASSISTANCE
FOR SOCIALLY ADVANCED
DISADVANTAGE FARMERS AND FARM
WORKERS REASON COULD BE THAT
IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS IN THE
BUDGET. THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
EX. ONE OF. NO MEDICARE MEMBERS
BRIAN WHITE ON BEHALF OF
OFFSHORE WIND CALIFORNIA A
BUSINESS TRADE GROUP OF OFFSHORE
WIND DEVELOPERS INTERESTED IN
RESPONSIBLE DEVELOPMENT OF
OFFSHORE WIND WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO DEDICATE FORTY FIVE MILLION
FOR PORT FACILITY PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES HELPS FOR
OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY IN FEDERAL
WATERS OFF CALIFORNIA'S COAST-
CLEARLY IN LINE WITH PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S MAKES ONE THIRTY
GIGAWATTS OFFSHORE. GOLD BUT THE
PREPARE FOR ALL WHEN WELL WE
RESPECT REQUEST THAT ADDITIONAL
FIFTY MILLION. HE DEREK FOR YOU
STILL A PLANNING. TO BRING THE
TOTAL TO A HUNDRED MILLION. WE
ALSO COMMEND THE CALIFORNIA%
ENERGY COMMISSION COURT
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN BEGINNING
IMPLEMENTATION EIGHTY FIVE TO
FIVE. WHICH JUST RELEASED THE
REPORT THEIR DRAFT REPORT LAST
WEEK WHICH IS VERY ENCOURAGING
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION OF THREE
GREAT WALKS BY TWENTY THIRTY.
AND TEN FIFTEEN GIGAWATTS BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE BUT AGAIN WE
WILL NEED THIS. FACILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING TO REALLY
MAKE IT COME TO LIFE. FINALLY WE
WOULD RESPECT YOUR QUEST TO BE
ENGAGED IN THE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THIS EASY FOR MYSTERY MONEY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RENEWABLES
THIS MAY BE HELPFUL FOR OFFSHORE
WIND. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THE
COMMITTEE AS BEFORE THANK. YOU
NEXT. NINE FOUR. NUMBER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY ALEX. I
ALREADY HAVE SEVERAL CLIENTS
TODAY. YEAH MY CREDIT REPORT
COALITION WE SUPPORT- THAT
DISTRIBUTED ELECTRICITY BACK UP
AFTER THE UNDERMANNED FIVE
FLEXIBILITY REPORT IDENTIFIED
UNDER THE STREET YOU CAN REPEAT
IT ELECTRIC RELIABILITY
RESEARCH. AND DEATH REQUEST THAT
THEIR CLARIFICATION THAT MICHAEL
GRANT WILL BE INCLUDED UNDER ONE
OR BOTH OF THOSE CATEGORIES AND
THEY CAN PROVIDE NOT ONLY BACKUP
POWER BUT CAPACITY IN TIMES OF
NEED I'M FOR RELIABILITY
CHALLENGES- THANK YOU WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE FIXED CHARGES
RATE REFORM PROPOSAL TO LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING MORE OF
THOSE DETAILS. AS THEY COME
FORWARD NOT BE HALF OF THE BIO
ENERGY- SECTOR WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST MORE FUNDING FOR CAL
FIRE DID WORK WORKED IN BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT AS IT RELATES TO BUY
AMOUNT. ONE OF THE PROGRAMS WAS
VASTLY OVERSUBSCRIBED THIS YEAR
SHOWING A SUBSTANTIAL NEED FOR
BIOMASS UTILIZATION AND THE
DEMAND THE REQUEST WILL LIKELY
REQUEST MORE FUNDING FOR
BIOENERGY BIOMASS. UTILIZATION
THANK YOU. NEXT NINE ONE SECOND
ONE I NINETY SO PLEASE. H. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROB
BREWER FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON- WE'RE HERE TODAY TO SAY
THAT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
MAY REVISE PROPOSAL FOR THE CAP
PROGRAM PHILIP FORTY FOUR
FURTHER DISCUSSION. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION NEXT.
PEOPLE CLOSE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THAT-
KENNEDY BALLARD TERRELL OF
BLOCKERS WITH PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY- WE'RE VERY
ENCOURAGED BY THE OVERALL
DISCUSSION IN THE PROPOSALS THAT
RECOGNIZE THE AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGE THAT- MANY OF OUR
CUSTOMERS ARE FACING WITH BY
PROPOSING STATE INVESTMENTS THAT
MAY HAVE TRADITIONALLY BEEN
BORNE BY OUR CUSTOMERS SUCH AS
RELIABILITY ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND EQUITABLE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION- SPECIFICALLY WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED ONE POINT
TWO BILLION- FOR UTILITY
CUSTOMER AND PAID BILLS- ONTO
THE SUCCESSFUL CAP PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA- HERE'S PAYMENT
PROGRAM. WE STAY READY TO WORK
IMPLEMENTATION TO GET THE MONEY
TO OUR CUSTOMERS THAT ARE
CONTINUING THEIR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AT THIS TIME. AND
FINALLY P. JEANNIE LOOK FOR TO
SEE MORE DETAILS ON OTHER
PROPOSALS SUCH AS A STRATEGIC
RELIABILITY RESERVE STORAGE AND
SOLAR INVESTMENTS AND THE
PROPOSED FIXED CHARGE AND AGAIN
OF COURSE STAND READY TO WORK
WITH THE- LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR. ON THESE PROPOSALS
THANK YOU NEXT. LINE. SEVENTY
NINE SEVENTY. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS THAT THAT I'M FIVE YEAR
MARK AND I'M REPRESENTING YOU
ORGANIZATION I STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION THE COALITION FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL EQUITY AND
ECONOMIC. AND OF WHICH WE ARE
OPPOSED AROUND OR WHAT THE LONG
WOULD BRING THE CHURCH AND A
SOUND WORKING- BASED MICRO
BUSINESS INCUBATOR OF WHICH I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND CO
FOUNDER CAFE CO OP AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PROPOSED BUDGET FOR-
THE CLEAN CARD FOR ALL PROGRAM
IN OUR TOWN MARKING VALLEY. WE
SUPPORT CLEAN CARTS FOR ALL
BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN IT MAKE A
REAL DIFFERENCE IN OUR MEMBERS
WHITE REPLACING OLD UNRELIABLE
CARS WITH AFFORDABLE YOU PLUG IN
CARS MEANS THAT OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS CAN GET TO WORK SCHOOL
AND MEDICAL CARE WITH MUCH LESS
COST. AND MUCH LESS AIR
POLLUTION THE CURRENT BUDGET
PROPOSAL WOULD CUT NEARLY ALL
THE SPENDING FOR THE EXISTING
CLEAN CARDS FOR ALL PROGRAMS IN
OUR SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. TIS
WOULD ELIMINATE A PROVEN PROGRAM
THAT IS MAKING A DIFFERENCE
WHERE IT IS NEEDED MOST PLEASE
CONSIDER SHIFTING THE STATEWIDE
CLEAN CARDS FOR ALL SPENDING
BACK IN THE AIR DISTRICT SO THEY
CAN CONTINUE OFFERING THAT THE
SEC BASKETBALL PROGRAM THANK YOU
FOR YOUR. CONSIDERATION NECKS.
LINE ONE HUNDRED. HI JANE HOW BE
UP TO NEITHER SHOULD COUNSEL AND
THE ENERGY INVESTMENT- WE
SUPPORT THE NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
AND EQUITABLE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION IN THE JANUARY
BUDGET HOWEVER IN ORDER FOR TO
TRULY EQUITABLE THAT NEEDS TO
TARGET INVESTMENTS TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS INCLUDE HOMELESS HOME
UPGRADES INCLUDING
WEATHERIZATION AND HABITABILITY
REPAIRS. ALL HOMES ARE ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM ELECTRIFICATION AND
INCLUDE TENANT PROTECTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT THE ENERGY
IMPROVEMENTS. LEAD TO
DISPLACEMENT. FOR THE ADDITIONAL
ONE TWO BILLION FOR LIKE
ELECTRICITY UTILITY EARLIER BUT
ALL IN THE ELIGIBILITY FOR THIRD
DATA TAKEN ON BY RIGHT. TO STAY
CURRENT THEIR BILLS. REGARDING
INVESTIGATION LOOKING
EXTRACTIONS. WE ARE GLAD TO SEE
A FIVE MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN COMMUNITY PLANNING AND
ENGAGEMENT. HOWEVER COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT MUST HAPPEN NOW AND
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS NOT HAVE
TO KEEP LENDING DECISIONS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN MADE. ALSO ALL
INVOLVEMENT IN AND COMMITMENT IS
TO MINIMIZING COMMUNITY IMPACTS
AND MAXIMIZE COMMUNITY BENEFITS
MUST INCLUDE IVERSIDE COUNTY
RESIDENTS. IN THE SALTON SEA
REGION. CALL ON THE CALL FOR THE
TWO AND FIFTY MILLION INVESTMENT
ADDITIONAL TRANSMISSION IN THE
REGION CONCLUDED ABOUT
TRANSITION TRANSMISSION TO
REPRESENT IMPLEMENT THE REGION
COULD FACE THE CURRENT POWER
OUTAGES. DURING PERIODS OF
EXTREME HEAT. ARE WE SUPPORTING
OF MILLION DOLLARS IN HOCKEY
GRANTS THAT HE OWES THE COST OF
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COMPUTER HE
AND BY. THE CONCEPT OF A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FROM G. R. OUT
FUNDING FOR ADDITIONAL METHANE
DATA COLLECTION AND ENFORCEMENT
ON THIS DATA TO BE MADE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE ON AND USUALLY
ACCEPTABLE WEBSITE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NECKS LINE. ONE FIFTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
BRITNEY BENNETT B. ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR THE
PREVETION OF CRUELTY TO ANIMALS
AS PART OF A COALITION OF
FARMERS- THE JUSTICE ADVOCATES
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
BUSINESSES RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING YOUR SUPPORT FOR AN
AGGREGATE PROPOSAL FOR THE
INCLUSION OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
RESILIENT FARMS AND RANCHES
GRANT PROGRAM FIRST WELFARE
THIRTY. UNDER CDFA AMID HIGH
CONSUMER DEMAND IMPENDING
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE
ACCORDING ARE SMALL AND MID
SIZED FARMERS EFFORTS TO OBTAIN
ANIMAL WELFARE CERTIFICATION
WE'LL GIVE OUR AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY IT'S VITAL TOOL IN
ENHANCING THEIR ECONOMIC
RESILIENCE EXPANDING LOCAL
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY IMPROVING
HEALTH CLIMATE RESILIENT AND
ENSURING CONSUMERS AND PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS ALIKE ARE ABLE TO
SHOP. WITH THEIR VALUES THANK
YOU. NOW ONE EVERYBODY HALAL
SLOW TECHNIQUES RIGHT ISN'T IT.
ONE SIXTEEN. I WANT SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT. HI THANK YOU
OUR MEMBERS MY NAME IS GEORGE
SPRINGER. I AM WHERE LOCAL MEDIA
ORGANIZATION OUT OF ACTION. MY
GROUP STRONG CLEAN PARTS FOR ALL
PROGRAM AND I'M LOOKING DOWDY
REQUIRES IN A PERFECT SEVEN
TALKING ABOUT TWENTY SIXTEEN I
HAVE MEMBERS WILL REPLACE THE
CAR WITHIN YOUR PLAN KERR.
THANKS PLAYING CARDS FOR ALL-
BUDGET WHAT CUT NEARLY ALL
FUNDING THE EXISTING GREEN CARDS
FOR ALL PROGRAM AND FOUND
WORKING ABOUT. I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SHIP A WHITE PAPER
CARD. ALL FUNDING BACK INTO THE
AIR DISTRICT'S WHAT THE PROGRAM
IS PROVEN SUCCESSFUL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION NEXT.
THIRTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND BOARD
THIS IS NATE NOT WAS STOCKED IN
REPRESENTING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COALITION FOR WATER I
HAVE DRIVEN HYBRID PLUG IN
ELECTRIC CARS AND I'VE ALSO
WRITTEN DOWN WALKING RTD'S ARE
REVOLUTIONARY ONE TIME A HYBRID
BUSES AND ALL ELECTRIC BUSES IS
ALL OF YOUR VEHICLES AND HYBRID
VEHICLES MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE
IN THE CLIMATE OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND THEY OFFER A
SMOOTHER AND QUIETER AND BRING
ABOUT GREAT CUSTOMER
SATISFACTION. I BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO FUND THE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS FOR THE
CLEAN AIR CARD THE CODE CLEAN
CARS FOR PROGRAM AND KEEP THE
MAJORITY THE STATE FUNDING THERE
RATHER THAN SHIFTING UP FUNDING
TO THE STATE OR LOCAL AGENCIES
CAN PERFORM THIS- WE ARE MUCH
MORE. GETS MORE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NECKS. ONE TWENTY. HELLO MY
NAME IS DENNIS HUDSON I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATORS AND- THE
STAFF AND SECRETARY CRAWFORD BUT
THE TEMPTATION TO PARTICIPATE.
BENEFACTION I'M A PASTOR OF THE
R. MOAN AND THE MORE UNITED
METHODIST CHURCHES. I'M A
RESIDENT OF ALLEN'S WORK AND I
AM- ADVISER TO THE ALBERTA
PROGRESSIVE ASSOCIATION. CALLING
YOU FROM MY REGENERATIVE FARMING
IN ALLEN'S WORK. HOURS IS A TOWN
THAT WAS FORMED BY COLONEL
ALLENSWORTH WHO CAME TO
CALIFORNIA AT THE END-
EMANCIPATED SLAVES. AND FORMED
THE ONLY BLACK FOUNDED TOWN IN
CALIFORNIA OUR FAMILY GROUP OF
BUSINESSES NONPROFITS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE NOW
WORKING TO CONTINUE TO ADVANCE
THE COLONEL'S VISION. FOR AN
INCLUSIVE THRIVING ECONOMIC
TOWNS AND REGION WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR DECADES AND
ARE HOPEFUL. THAT THIS WORK WILL
BE REALIZED AS WELL AS THE-
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS THERE WE ARE
WORKING TO ACCOMPLISH WE ARE
VERY EXCITED TO HEAR ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO BRING
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS- TWO HOURS
WORK THROUGH THE STATE PARKS.
HAVING SAID THAT. WE HOLD THE
VISION FOR COMPREHENSIVE
REGIONAL COMMUNITY PLAN WHICH WE
HAVE SUBMITTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE OF THE ARE GREAT
HOLLY AT CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK BOX. UNDER THE LEADERSHIP
OF SENATOR BRAD WHO WAS QUOTED
AT HIS REPARATIONS FORCE HERE AS
NOTING QUOTE WE MUST MAKE OURS
WERE CALLED IN TO FORM. SO WE
HAVE- THEY ASKED ABOUT THE WORK
WITH THE STATE PARK. DOWN WERE
THE LINE IN THE COMMUNITY AND
OTHER REGIONAL PARTNERS TO
CONTINUE THE WORK THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS TO BE IN FULL SWING. AND
ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO ADDITIONAL
FUNDING BEING CONSIDERED THE
CONTACT HOURS WORTH THE MUNITY
DATA RAPIDLY THROUGH COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT OPERATIONS. DESIGNED
TO TAKE DECADES OF WORK TO THE
NEXT LEVEL AND THIRD THE URGENT
NEEDS OF THIS COMMUNITY AND ITS
PEOPLE WE STAND EAGER TO- ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS BE IN CONVERSATION
WITH THE LEGISLATURE THE BLACK
BOXES AND BUDGET COMMITTEE. AT
THE SCHOOL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR GREAT WORK AND. TIME THANK
YOU NEXT. LINE. ONE SIXTY. ONE
SIXTEEN GO AHEAD. ARE YOU MAY
HAVE YOU MEET ON. MAYBE GO TO
THE NEXT AND FINAL CALLER. ONE
SECOND HERE WE'LL GO TO LINE.
ONE TWENTY FOUR. BUT TWENTY FOUR
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
YEAH MY NAME'S RYAN I'M UP HERE
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I JUST
HAVE A- CONCERN WITH A LOT OF
THE- SPENDING GOING ON HERE
SEEMS FRIVOLOUS- AS FAR AS
CARBON SEQUESTRATION- I JUST
WANTED TO RUN THIS BY YOU GUYS
IF YOU KNOW THAT TREES ABSORB
CARBON DIOXIDE SO. AS FAR AS
LIKE- LOW COST SOLUTIONS TO SOME
OF THESE- THE BIG PROBLEM THAT
YOU KNOW- WE WERE GONNA BE UNDER
WATER TWENTY YEARS AGO ACCORDING
TO AL GORE AND WERE NOT SO I
JUST ALL THIS FEAR PROPAGATION
TO KIND OF COOKED THE BOOKS IS
MY CONCERN. AND THAT SEEMS LIKE
MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR MONEY
LAUNDERING THING ELSE SO I'D
LIKE TO SEE A LITTLE BIT MORE
CLEAN STREAMLINED ENERGY- BACK
TO DATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS AND
WITH THAT WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING AND THANK ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS. IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION- WE
HAVE CONCLUDED TODAY'S HEARING
THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE TO. CONSIDER.